ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
BRADFORD CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DOLLY [inaudible]
DODD.
THERE AWESOME.
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HUESO -- TADA [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
AROUND [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
RAW [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
AMBERG.
LIKE OWSKI.
WIENER.
WILK.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS BE ON THE
RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE.
WE'LL BE LETTING PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN
THE CONTENT A SCORE SUCH OF A
SAINT JOSEPH MORELLO CATHOLIC
CHURCH.
IN GRANITE BAY DIESIS OF
SACRAMENTO.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
BY SENATOR MONNING.
LET US TAKE A MOMENT TO CENTER
OURSELVES AS WE INVOKE THE
DIVINE BLESSING [inaudible]
ALMIGHTY GOD.
AS CALIFORNIANS WE HAVE MANY
BLESSINGS FOR WHICH WE ARE
THANKFUL.
OUR RICH HERITAGE.
OUR ABUNDANT NATURAL RESOURCES.
OUR SCENIC BEAUTY.
OUR GREAT DIVERSITY.
WITH MANY CULTURES AND RELIGIOUS
BACKGROUNDS AND TRADITIONS.
AND THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR
CREATIVE AND HARDWORKING
POPULOUS.
WE ARE BLESSED WITH A PROSPERITY
THAT IS UNMATCHED.
LET US ALWAYS BE WILLING TO
GENEROUSLY SHARE OUR GOOD
FORTUNE.
WITH THOSE WHO ARE IN NEED
[inaudible]
THE HUNGRY [inaudible]
THE THIRSTY [inaudible]
THE STRANGER [inaudible]
THE NAKED [inaudible]
THE ILL [inaudible]
THE HOMELESS.
THOSE WHO ARE VICTIMS OF CRIME.
AND THOSE IN PRISON.
MAYOR LAWMAKERS DEFEND OUR
FREEDOM TO FOLLOW OUR
CONSCIENCES IN SERVING GOD AND
OUR NEIGHBOR.
ACCORDING TO OUR FAITH.
AND AS WE GO ABOUT OUR BUSINESS
TODAY.
LET US FOCUS ON THE COMMON GOAL.
OF HAVING.
A SEARCH FOR THE GOOD WITH THE
SPIRIT OF COOPERATION
[inaudible]
OPENNESS [inaudible]
COMPROMISE [inaudible]
RESPECT [inaudible]
AND KINDNESS [inaudible]
HEY MAN.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS PLEASE JOIN
ME AS WE PLEDGE OUR FLAG.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES
[inaudible]
BOB IT IS A LITTLE [inaudible]
FOR ALL.
WE ARE NOW ED PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR [inaudible]
SENATOR PAN.
IF YOU WOULD ALL PLEASE GIVE
YOUR ATTENTION TO SENATOR PAN.
AT THE BACK OF THE FLOOR. FOR A
MEMORIAL PRESENTATION.
SENATOR PAM THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
SENATORS [inaudible]
TODAY.
WE MOURN AND COMMEMORATE
SACRAMENTO POLICE OFFICER TERRA
CRISTINA SOLOMON.
BADGE.
THREE FORTY NINE WHO WAS KILLED
IN THE LINE OF DUTY ON JUNE
NINETEENTH.
TWENTY NINETEEN RESPONDING TO A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE INCIDENT.
THIS SENSELESS ACT OF VIOLENCE
IS A REMINDER OF THE SACRIFICES
MADE.
BY THOSE WHO WEAR THE BADGE AND
SWORE TO PROTECT.
AND SERVE OUR COMMUNITY.
THIS IS A MOMENT OF GRIEVING FOR
THE ENTIRE SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY.
HER ACT OF BRAVERY AN ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE TO SERVE OTHERS WILL
ALWAYS BE REMEMBERED.
WHILE THE LEGACY SHE LEAVES
BEHIND WILL FOREVER BE AN
INSPIRATION TO US ALL.
DEREK CRISTINO SULLIVAN WAS BORN
IN WALNUT CREEK CALIFORNIA TO A
WARM AND LOVING FAMILY.
SHE ATTENDED COLLEGE PARK HIGH
SCHOOL IN PLEASANTVILLE PUSHY
ESTABLISHED MANY LAW OFFLINE
LIFE LONG RELATIONSHIPS.
AND FRIENDSHIPS.
COMPETITIVE EDGES FORCE AT A
YOUNG AGE WHEN SHE JOINED HER
FIRST SOCCER TEAM AT AGE.
FOUR AND SHE CONTINUED TO PLAY
SPORTS AND MADE PHYSICAL FITNESS
A LIFELONG PASSION.
OFFICERS SULLIVAN'S LOVE OF
POLICE WORK AS A PARENT AT A
VERY YOUNG AGE AND IT FIFTEEN
SHE STARTED WITH THE MARTINEZ
PLEASANT HILL EXPLORER PROGRAM.
OFFICER SELVIN CONTINUED HER
EDUCATION AT THE APPLE VALLEY
COLLEGE AND SHE ULTIMATELY
GRADUATED FROM CALIFORNIA STAE
UNIVERSITY SACRAMENTO IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EARNING A BACHELOR OF ARTS
DEGREE IN CHILD DEVELOPMENT.
WHILE AT SAKS STATE OFFICERS.
WAS ALSO A TOP COMMANDER OF THE
INAUGURAL CLASS OF GRADUATES
FROM THE LAW ENFORCEMENT KENNEDY
SCHOLARS PROGRAM.
IN JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
JOIN THE POLICE SACRAMENTO
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
FAMILY IS THE COMMUNITY SERVICES
OFFICER WHO SHE LEARN THE
FOUNDATIONAL SKILLS AND
EXPECTATIONS.
OF A SACRAMENTO POLICE OFFICER.
IN JULY THE SAME YEAR SHE
ENTERED THE POLICE ACADEMY FOR
SHE EXCELLED AND EARNED RESPECT
FOR INSTRUCTORS AND CLASSMATES
AND SHE TOOK ON HER DUTIES WITH
PASSION AND COMMITMENT.
OFFICER O'SULLIVAN WAS KNOWN FOR
A COMPETITIVE INQUISITIVE
ENCOURAGING.
AS WELL THE SMILE THAT JUST
WOULDN'T QUIT.
SHE CONTINUED TO BE A PART OF
THE ACADEMY AFTER SHE GRADUATED.
ASSISTING WITH SCENARIOS AND
PARTICIPATING IN THE CATEGORIES
FINAL FIVE MILE RUN.
DECEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN TARA
GRADUATED FROM THE SECOND A
POLICE ACADEMY CLASS EIGHTEEN B.
R..
TWO AND WAS UPGRADED TO POLICE
OFFICER WHERE SHE CONTINUED HER
JOURNEY LIVING HER LIFE LONG
DREAM.
SHE LEFT SHE LEFT LIFE PEOPLE
AND POLICE WORK AND WILL FOREVER
BE REMEMBERED.
HERE TODAY TO ACCEPT THIS
RESOLUTION HONORING TERO
SULLIVAN'S LIFE IS SACRAMENTO
POLICE CHIEF HAN.
CAPTAIN WENDY BROWN.
AND HER FAMILY DENNIS O'SULLIVAN
HER FATHER KELLY OF SOLOMON.
AND CRISTO SULLIVAN.
HER ON AIR ERIN KAISER.
AND TO GOD FATHER GERRY RICH AND
ON THE BALCONY WE ALSO HAVE
COLLEAGUES FROM ACADEMY CLASS
INSTANCE ACURA POLICE DEPARTMENT
AS WELL AS HERE.
THE FLOOR -- SELF AGAIN I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
TERRACE ALL THAT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN AND THANK
YOU TO THE FAMILY CLEARLY AN
EXTRAORDINARY WOMAN GONE FAR TOO
SOON.
OUR CONDOLENCES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
THANK YOU AND I WOULD LIKE THE
PERMISSION TO PRESENT TOMORROW
RESOLUTIONS THAT WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
IN COLLEAGUES WHY DON'T WE ARE.
IDENTIFY ENSURE A MOMENT OF
SILENCE.
IN MEMORY OF THIS EXTRAORDINARY
YOUNG WOMAN
.
THANK YOU ALL AGAIN CONDOLENCES
TO HER FAMILY A REMINDER OF JUST
HOW DANGEROUS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IS IN THE HEROISM OF SO MANY OF
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
PEOPLE WHO PUT THEMSELVES IN
HARM'S WAY. TO HELP THOSE WHO
WERE THE VICTIMS OF THIS
TERRIBLE BEHAVIOR
.
I COLLEAGUES LET'S SAY IF WE
WILL TURN.
TO THE ISSUES OF THE DAY.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES.
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
UNDER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES.
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT PLEASE REMOVE FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE FIFTY NINE A. B.
FIFTEEN FIFTY EIGHT ALMOST FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
THAT WILL BE SO NOTED THANK YOU
ANY OTHER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES.
SEEING NONE WE WILL MOVE ON NOW
TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE SECOND READING FARM MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX SEVENTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS TEN OH FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS FOR THIRTY WITH
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
FORTY SIX ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
EIGHTY ONE WITH AMENDMENTS
SECOND READING FAR WILL BE
DEEMED READ.
MOVING ON THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS [inaudible]
SENATOR WILK [inaudible]
MADAM SECRETARY.
CENTER WORLD THE FLOOR'S YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN IS A
CONFIRMATION OF CAR CARL.
GUARDINO TO THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION MR
GUARDINO IS THE PRESIDENT AND
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP.
HE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JUNE NINETEENTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
COLLEAGUES OF UNTIL SUCH TIME AS
NOTICE OTHERWISE WE WILL BE
GOING THROUGH THE ROLE ONCE AND
PUTTING ALL ITEMS ON CALL WE DO
HAVE A NUMBER OF MEMBERS.
WHO ARE CURRENTLY PRESENTING --
IN THE ASSEMBLY SO WE'RE GOING
TO CALL THE ROLL ONE TIME AND
THEN PLACE ALL ITEMS ON CALL.
WITHOUT SEEING NO DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALAN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
WELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DOLLY [inaudible]
I DON.
THERE ARE SO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HI GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible] FIVE HILL
[inaudible] FIVE HUESO.
I TADO.
I JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER
[inaudible]
WILK.
HI SENATOR WILK MOVES A CALL THE
NEXT GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT-SENATOR WILK THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN IS A CONFIRMATION OF
LUIS PAULSON. TO THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS BOARD FOR THE
LAST FOURTEEN YEARS MR PAULSON
SERVICE PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
FOUNDATION IN CO SPONSOR THE
CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTER JOINT
APPRENTICESHIP COMMITTEE HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON JUNE NINETEENTH ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
APPOINTMENT IS THERE ANY DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND HEARING
NONE BàN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALAN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
HI FOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG.
DOLLY.
I DON.
THERE ARE SO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADO.
I JACKSON.
AYE JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LIKE [inaudible]
I MORRELL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I UMBERG.
WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
HI.
CENTER WILL MOVES A CALL.
NEXT ITEM NEXT APPOINTMENT
CENTER WILK THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN IS A CONFIRMATION OF
GENEVIEVE SARAMA. TO THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
PRIOR TO THIS APPOINTMENT MISHA
ROMA SERVED AT SIR FOR TWENTY
YEARS AS AN APPOINTEE TO THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOURS RELATIONS
BOARD.
SHE ALSO SERVED ON THE
SACRAMENTO MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICT BOARD SHE WAS APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON JUNE
NINETEENTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SENATOR PAN ON THIS DEBATE AND
DISCUSSION THANK YOU I MATTER
PRESENT CENTERS I TO RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF JENNY V.
SARAMA FOR THE PUBLIC AT FOR THE
PC OBVIOUSLY A VERY IMPORTANT
POSITION GIVING THE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE FACING NOW.
I KNOW SOMEONE WHO IS A SERVICE
OR A LONG TIME ON THE SMUD BOARD
HERE LOCALLY IN SACRAMENTO SHE
BRINGS THE EXPERTISE THAT WE
GONNA NEED ON THE PC.
I CERTAINLY ALSO URGE AN AYE
VOTE ON HER CONFIRMATION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE ALL
RIGHT NO CLOSED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALAN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DOLLY [inaudible]
DODD.
THERE ARE SO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
AYE GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I TADO.
I JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
MY KOWSKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL SENATOR
WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN IS A
CONFIRMATION OF MONA PASQUALE
ROGERS TO THE STATE PERSONNEL
BOARD.
MISS PASCO ROGER SERVED AS
APPOINTMENTS SECRETARY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR OVER EIGHT
YEARS.
THANK CONTINUES TO SERVE THE
ADMINISTRATION AS A SENIOR
ADVISER AT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON THE NINETEENTH OF JUNE ON
UNANIMOUS VOTE.
RESPECTFULLY ASKFOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER WORLD
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
I FELL.
I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO.
CHIANG.
HI DOLLY [inaudible]
JOHN.
THERE ARE SO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER.
AYE GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES.
HI I LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LIKE [inaudible]
I MARROW [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I NUMBER.
WHY KOWSKI?
I WIENER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS
.
MEMBERS WE ONLY HAVE THREE ITEMS
ON UNFINISHED BUSINESS TWO OF
THOSE AUTHORS ARE CURRENTLY OFF
THE FLOOR SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN
SENATOR MONNING.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO HUNDRED BY
SENATOR MINING AN ACT RELATING
TO DRINKING WATER MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR MONNING.
WELL THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
IT'S INDEED MY HONOR TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL TWO HUNDRED TO
ESTABLISH THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND
WHICH IS BACK TO THE SENATE
FLOOR ON CONCURRENCE.
FROM THE STATE ASSEMBLY.
BEFORE HIGHLIGHTING THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
HISTORIC NATURE OF THIS VOTE.
AS IT REPRESENTS CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO THE NEARLY ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WHO DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO CLEAN SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
IN THEIR HOMES IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
OUR YES VOTE TODAY WILL PROVIDE
A LONG AWAITED ACTION TO THE
MANY CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE%
ADVOCATED ORGANIZED AND TRAVELED
TO SACRAMENTO. TO SEEK REDRESS
TO THIS FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN RIGHTS
ISSUE THE RIGHT TO CLEAN SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
pTODAY MEMBERS WOULD NOT BE
POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE EFFORTS OF
MANY.
BUT I FEEL IT IS IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR PRESIDENT PRO
TEM.
AND HER TEAM INCLUDING KIP
CLIPPER WHO HELPED TO NEGOTIATE
THIS AGREEMENT ALONG WITH
ASSEMBLY SPEAKER ANTHONY RENDON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS EDUARDO GARCIA
AND RICHARD BLOOM.
AND SENATE CO AUTHORS MY
COLLEAGUES FROM SALINAS AND
SINGER.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE LEADERSHIP.
OF GOVERNOR NEW SOME IN HIS TEAM.
WHO COMMITTED TO FINDING A
SOLUTION?
IN HIS INAUGURAL SPEECH.
AND AT THE TIME THAT HE
INTRODUCED HIS TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET.
IT WAS GOVERNOR NEW SOME.
WHO IN HIS FIRST WEEK IN OFFICE
LET A BUS TOUR TO THE CENTRAL
VALLEY? TO VISIT THE IMPACTED
COMMUNITY OF MONTEREY PARK WHERE
HE UNDERSCORED HIS COMMITMENT.
TO SECURE A SOLUTION THIS YEAR.
THERE ARE MANY OTHERS WHOSE
TIRELESS EFFORTS HELP TO BRING
US TO TODAY'S VOTE.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE SOME OF THEM WHILE
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THERE ARE
MANY OTHER INDIVIDUALS AND
ORGANIZATIONS WHO I WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO THINK.
BY NAME.
SOME OF THOSE WHO HELPED TO
BUILD AND LEAD THE SAFE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER COALITION.
INCLUDE THE COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER.
THE LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
CLEAN WATER ACTION.
THE WATER FOUNDATION.
THE LARA SWEAR TO AND THE DOOR
SWEAR TO FOUNDATION.
AND THE MANY COALITION MEMBERS
REPEAT REPRESENTING A BROAD
CROSS SECTION OF RURAL.
AND URBAN CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE WITH US TODAY SOME
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY OF LAND
THERE.
WHO'VE TRAVELED COUNTLESS TIMES.
TO VISIT US HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
FOR MANY YEARS SEEKING OUR
SUPPORT IN HELPING THEM TO
ACCESS CLEAN SAFE DRINKING WATER
I WELCOME THEM AND ACKNOWLEDGE
THEIR COMMITMENT. TO THIS EFFORT.
MANY STAFF MEMBERS ALSO LABOR TO
LAND THIS AGREEMENT.
BUT I DO WANT TO SINGLE OUT NICK
KNOWLEDGE MY STAFF POINT PERSON
ON SENATE BILL TWO HUNDRED
TREVOR TAYLOR.
FRIENDS THE AMENDMENTS BEFORE US
TODAY ON CONCURRENCE REPRESENT A
NEGOTIATED AGREEMENT ON THE
ESTABLISHMENT.
OF THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER FUND.
SOME FURTHER DETAILS ON THE
ADMINISTRATION OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT WILL BE
EXERCISED AS PART OF ITS
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND THE RECOGNITION.
THAT COMBINED WITH THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET ACT.
SENATE BILL TWO HUNDRED WILL
GUARANTEE A STEADY RELIABLE IN
RECURRING UNDING SOURCE FOR TEN
YEARS TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THIS OFF DELAYED GOAL OF
BRINGING SAFE CLEAN DRINKING
WATER TO ALL CALIFORNIANS CAN BE
TRANSFORMED.
FROM AN ELUSIVE DREAM TO A NEW
REALITY IN THE LIVES OF MANY
CALIFORNIANS.
MEMBERS I ASKS THAT YOU JOIN ME
IN CONCURRENCE AND LEND YOUR
NAMES TO THIS BIPARTISAN AND
HISTORIC AGREEMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER MINING
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE CENTER
HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
WE STAND ON THIS FLOOR.
AND WE PRESENT MANY.
NEW MATTERS NEW LEGISLATIVE
IDEAS.
IN ALL AREAS OF PUBLIC POLICY.
BUT THERE ARE MOMENTS ON THIS
FLOOR.
WHERE DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE
SENATOR FROM MONTEREY GIVES
RECOGNITION TO OTHERS HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE HAS
BEEN NOTHING LESS AN
EXTRAORDINARY HE HAS BEEN DOGGED
HE HAS BEEN FOCUS HE HAS BEEN
PASSIONATE?
IN EVERY RESPECT THIS MEASURE
WOULD NOT BE BEFORE US TODAY BUT
FOR SENATOR MORNINGS
EXTRAORDINARY LEADERSHIP HE IS
SEEN THE VALUE WE IS TAKEN
PEOPLE ALL THE STATE HE WAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE GOVERNOR
GOING TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
HE IS GOING TO BE INSTRUMENTAL
IN SO MANY PEOPLE'S LIVES WHO
NEVER WILL KNOW HIS NAME BUT
THAT IS THE GENIUS OF OUR
BUSINESS BUT THERE'S TIME TO WE
CAN STEP UP.
WE DO THE RIGHT THING WE EXTEND
BEYOND THINGS OUR OWN COMMUNITY
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENED HERE
TODAY THIS IS A GREAT BILL
THERE'S A GREAT TESTAMENT TO
EXTRAORDINARY DETERMINED
LEADERSHIP I ASK YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
CENTER ATKINS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT WELL
THAT'S GOING TO BE HARD TO TOP --
AT LEAST THE ENERGY LEVEL IS --
I WILL SAY BUT I I WANT TO ADD
MY VOICE TO THIS SB TWO HUNDRED
PROVIDES.
AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT --
MULTIPLE TIMES ON THIS FLOOR AN
ONGOING SOURCE OF FUNDING TO
PROVIDE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER TO COMMUNITIES.
THAT NEED IT THE MOST AND I'M
GLAD SOME OF THOSE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS ARE HERE TODAY. TO
WITNESS THIS TODAY IS A GOOD DAY
IT IS A VERY GOOD DAY -- BECAUSE
THIS BILL PROVIDES FUNDING
WITHOUT ANY NEW TAXES OR CHARGES
ON WORKING CALIFORNIANS ARE OR
ON OUR FARMING COMMUNITY.
THAT'S WHAT WE SAID WHEN WE
DISCUSSED IT ORIGINALLY IT'S
GONE AWAY IT'S COME BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE WE MAKE PROMISES.
THAT WE WOULD KEEP THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL ODD TO SUPPORT
COMMUNITIES AND NOT -- ADD NEW
CHARGESOR NEW TAXES -- FOR
CALIFORNIANS IT WAS A KEY
ELEMENT OF THE SENATE'S APPROACH
TO THE ISSUE WE CAN HAVE SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
WITHOUT PUTTING NEW BURDENS ON
WORKING CALIFORNIANS.
THROUGH CHARGES ON WATER BILLS
AND WE'VE DONE THAT.
ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL SIDE THE
SENATE OPPOSED ANY SPECIAL
BREAKS UNDER WATER QUALITY LAWS
FOR THOSE WHO POLLUTE OUR
DRINKING WATER.
IT'S A BALANCED PACKAGE THAT
PROVIDES CLEAN DRINKING WATER IN
A MANNER THAT SERVICE ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
IT'S A PRODUCT OF OVER THREE
YEARS OF WORK. FOR THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM MONTEREY.
IT'S TO ENSURE THAT ARE
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS DO NOT
GO WITHOUT SAFE WATER IN THEIR
HOMES IN THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY.
THAT WE DO NOT ALREADY PROVIDE
THIS IS INCREDIBLE FOR ME TO
EVEN FATHOM.
AND I SPOKE A LONG AGO TO LONG
ON A WOMAN WHO WAS ON THE FLOOR --
BEFORE IT WENT OVER TO THE
ASSEMBLY BECAUSE I REALLY WANTED
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT MEANS NOT TO
HAVE.
I CLEAN DRINKING WATER I GREW UP
WITHOUT THAT I KNOW WHAT IT
MEANS AND WHEN I MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA I THOUGHT.
CALIFORNIA THAT IS THE FUTURE
THAT IS A CUTTING EDGE THAT IS
ALL THINGS THAT -- PEOPLE ASPIRE
TO BE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD.
SO TO BE HERE AND TO BE IN THE
ASSEMBLY YEARS AGO WHEN WE WERE
DISCUSSING THIS ISSUE.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE.
THAT WE DIDN'T ALREADY HAVE THIS
SO I WANT TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES AND COMMENDING
MY COLLEAGUE FROM MONTEREY. FOR
HIS PERSEVERANCE HIS STEADFAST
COMMITMENT. TO THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE MOST IN NEED IN OUR
GREAT STATE.
OUR STATE WILL BE GREAT.
WHEN WE INSURE THAT THERE IS
CLEAN DRINKING WATER? FOR PEOPLE
IN THE STATE.
SO I'M THRILLED TO SEE THAT HE
HAS GOTTEN THIS ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE WITH YOUR HELP TODAY.
MAKE NO MISTAKE SB TWO HUNDRED
IS A MAJOR STEP FORWARD FOR ALL
OF THE COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE.
THAT SUFFER FROM GROUND WATER
POLLUTION AND A LACK OF TWO
MINUTES FOR WATER SUPPLIES TO
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
IT'S NOT OFTEN WE CAN STAND ON
THE FLOOR AND SAY THAT A SINGLE
VOTE FOR A BILL WILL HELP
TRANSFORM THE LIVES.
OF MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS SB
TWO HUNDRED WILL DO JUST THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEN SENATOR
WHY CAL SKI.
MADAM PRESIDENT WITH.
GREAT RELUCTANCE IN -- GREAT
RESPECT FOR THE AUTHOR WHO I'VE
WORKED WITH AND CLEAN WATER I
MUST RISE IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TWO HUNDRED TODAY.
I'M I VOTED FOR THE MAIN BUDGET
BILL WITH THE THE COMPROMISE
INCLUDED -- THAT'S BEFORE US
BECAUSE I SUPPORT THE GOOD
INVESTMENTS IN THE MANY TO
SERVING PROGRAMS IN AB --
SEVENTY FOUR BUT I RAISE
CONCERNS A FEW WEEKS AGO THAT
MUST RISE IN OPPOSITION TODAY.
SENATE BILL TWO HUNDRED
APPROPRIATES GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND MONIES AND
EXPENSIVE TYPE OF ACTIONS THAT
GREENHOUSE GAS -- THE GT R. F.
IS REQUIRED TO FUND WITHOUT
REQUIRING A DIRECT NEXUS TO
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTIONS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
REDUCING CARBON AS REQUIRED.
BY A. B..
THIRTY TWO THIS IS SUPPOSED O
BE A TRAILER BILL ABOUT WATER HE
SAID IT'S A POLICY BILL THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN OPENLY DEBATED
AMENDED INS.
AND COMMENTED ON IN A MUCH MORE
ROBUST MATTERS IT DOESN'T TAKE
AWAY FROM THE DILIGENT WORK THAT
MY COLLEAGUE HAS THAT NO FOR
THREE YEARS AND RAISING
AWARENESS OF THE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE.
PROVIDING SAFE DRINKING WATER
BUT WE SHOULD NOT BE CREATING A
FALSE DICHOTOMY MADAM PRESIDENT
THAT IS A BY PRODUCT OF THIS
DEAL REPEATING CLEAN WATER
AGAINST CLEAN.
AIR AND WE KNOW THE CALIFORNIA'S
CAN AND MUST HAVE BOTH OF THEM.
MEMBERS WERE FAR WERE FALLING
FARTHER BEHIND ON OUR COMMITMENT
TO MEET THE PARIS.
ACCORDS WE SHOULD BE ACTING MORE
AGGRESSIVELY TO CHEERING TO
KEEPING OUR CREEK CLEAN AIR
STANDARDS.
THAT IS GOING TO REQUIRE SOME
BOLDNESS ON THE PART OF BARS AND
DISCIPLINE AND COMMITMENT BY
THIS LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THE
GREENHOUSE GAS.
DOLLARS ARE INVESTED WILD WISELY
ESPECIALLY FROM OUR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND BEYOND.
DIVERTING LIMITED GREENHOUSE GAS
DOLLARS AWAY FROM CUTTING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS THE
OTHER IMPORTANT AND NOBLE CAUSES
UNNECESSARY CLASSES IS NOT A
PATH THAT WE SHOULD GO DOWN NOW
WE'RE IN THE FUTURE.
REGRETFULLY GIVEN THAT I AM
UNABLE TO SUPPORT IT BUT I DO ON
A PERSONAL NOTE.
APPLIED MY FRIEND FOR ALL THE
WORK THAT HE'S DONE FOR SAFE
DRINKING WATER IN FOR THE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES THAT
DESERVE BETTER.
THE USER RIGHT CAL SKI SENATOR
WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
IN RELUCTANT SUPPORT FOR SB TWO
HUNDRED I HAVE LONG SUPPORTED
INCREASE MONEY FOR CLEAN
DRINKING WATER PROJECTS. FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES IN NEED IN FACT I AM
CO AUTHOR OF A SEE A THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMAN GARCIA WHICH WOULD
HAVE SET ASIDE 2% OF GENERAL
FUND REVENUES FOR CLEAN DRINKING
WATER PROJECTS.
IT PRIOR IT PRIORITIZE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER THE WAY WE
PRIORITIZE EDUCATION FUNDING
THROUGH PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT MY RELUCTANCE TO
THIS MEASURES THAT USES
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
REVENUES IF WE ARE SEROUS ABOUT.
COMBAT IN GLOBAL WARMING WITH A
CAP AND TRADE FUNDS IT SHOULD BE
USED FOR ITS INTENDED PURPOSES
REDUCE IT REDUCING GLOBAL HOUSE
A GLOBAL.
HOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
THE GLOBAL HEALTH GAS ADMISSION
FUND IS NOT A SLUSH FUND.
AND IN GLOBAL WARMING IS A
SERIOUS PROBLEM AND IT CANNOT BE
ADDRESSED SOLELY THROUGH
REGULATIONS OR MANDATES WE MUST
INNOVATE OUR WAY INTO A GREENER
AND CLEANER WORLD.
BY USING THOSE FINES AND
LEVERAGING THE INTELLECTUAL
CAPITAL THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO CREATE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WILL HELP US.
OVERCOME -- THESE CHALLENGES TO
BE CLEAR EVERY CALIFORNIA SHOULD
HAVE RELIABLE SOURCE OF GOOD
CLEAN DRINKING WATER.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
ALL THIS WORK IN THIS EFFORT.
BUT THEY SHOULD NOT BE FOR MANY
OF US AN AFTERTHOUGHT IN
GOVERNMENT POLICY SO WHILE I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
MOVING FORWARD I ASK AND I PLEAD
THAT WE WORK TO ENSURE THAT CAP
AND TRADE FUNDS ARE SPENT ON
REDUCING GLOBAL EMISSIONS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER WILK CENTER HER
TADO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I WANT TO THANK.
SENATOR MONNING AND PRESIDENT
PRO TEM ATKINS FOR FIGHTING FOR
THIS MEASURE WHICH WILL BENEFIT
MY COMMUNITY FOR MANY YEARS TO
COME.
JUST LAST YEAR -- THIS TIME LAST
SUMMER I WAS IN A SMALL
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY AND MY
DISTRICT.
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO TO MEET
WITH A LOT OF OF THE PEOPLE OF
THE COMMUNITY BUT I WAS THERE
BECAUSE I WAS DELIVERING BOTTLED
WATER TO COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE ANY ACCESS TO
CLEAN WATER AT THE MOMENT.
AND I CAME ACROSS -- A COMMUNITY
MEMBER.
WHO WAS JUST HIRED AND
FRUSTRATED AND FED UP
[inaudible]
WITH.
THE CONTAMINATED WATER IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND SHE EXPRESSED HER
FRUSTRATION TO ME.
AND SAID YOU KNOW.
THERE'S TWO FAMILIES DOWN THE
STREET.
EACH HAVE A YOUNG CHILD AND THE
BOTH.
HAD TO GO THROUGH CANCER.
IT WAS A VERY DIFFICULT.
BEING THE HERE AND THE BLAME.
WAS THE CONTAMINATED WATER IN
THIS IN THIS COMMUNITY.
AND SO.
THIS BILL IN THE EFFORT BY
ARCTIC SENATOR OF MARIE -- WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY PROVIDE SUPPORT TO
MY DISTRICT IN THOSE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS.
AND IT GOES WAY BEYOND -- SAFE
DRINKING WATER IT'S QUALITY OF
OF OF THE HEALTH.
IN HOUSE THERE [inaudible]
AND SO.
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE.
CALIFORNIANS CANNOT GO WITHOUT
THE SAFE DRINKING WATER THIS IS
A MAJOR STEP.
FORWARD FOR THE COMMUNITIES IN
MY DISTRICT THAT SUFFER FROM THE
GROUND WATER POLLUTION AND THIS
IS A BILL THAT.
IT'S THREE YEARS AT OUR COULD
CENTER HAS WORKED ON AND SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE.
AND I WILL LET YOU KNOW LET YOU
KNOW THAT.
OUR COMMUNITIES.
ARE EXTREMELY GRATEFUL BUT ALSO
WILL ALWAYS REMEMBERED THE WORK
YOU HAVE DONE.
NOT JUST FOR OUR COMMUNITY BUT
FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIANS TO HAVE
ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING WATER
SIPPING Q..
AND FOR THESE REASONS I ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER HURTADO SENATOR
MITCHELL.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT OF
LIKE TO WHAT ECHO OUR COLLEAGUES --
KNOWLEDGE MINT -- OF THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE OVER THE PAST
THREE YEARS THE STEADFAST WORK.
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE HOLDING ON TIGHT TO AN
ISSUE YOU CAN'T CROSS THE GOAL
LINE THAT THREE YEARS FELT LIKE
I'M SURE A HUNDRED IN DOG YEARS
BUT YOU'VE MADE IT ACROSS I WANT
TO CONGRATULATE YOU.
YOU KNOW SB TWO HUNDRED IS THE
TRAILER BILL FOR FAITH IN
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
I KNOW THAT THERE WAS SOME
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN RAISED -- I
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THIS
BILL IS SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO
AB ONE HUNDRED WHICH WE DID HERE
IN SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE ON
JUNE TWENTY FOURTH.
WHICH HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND SO WHEN I SAY SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR I WANTED TO PROVIDE VERY
CLEAR -- EXAMPLES OF WHAT THAT
MEANS.
SB TWO HUNDRED MADE MINOR
CHANGES TO AB ONE HUNDRED MINOR
INCLUDED IT ADDED CO AUTHORS WE
ADDED FINDINGS AND DECLARATION
THAT WE CHANGED ONE TERM FROM
FUND INFORMATION PLAN. TO FUND
EXPENDITURE PLAN.
SO FOR THOSE WHO FELT THAT
THEY'VE NOT BEEN ABLE TO HEAR
AND FULLY THAT THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THIS BILL -- I WOULD
ARGUE TO THE CONTRARY.
THIS IS THE TOP BUDGET PRIORITY
FOR THE SENATE DEMOCRATS THIS
YEAR TO CREATE THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUN
WITH A DEDICATED ON WHEN REVENUE
SOURCE WITHOUT.
HAVING TO TAX MIDDLE CLASS
CALIFORNIANS AND THIS BILL DOES
EXACTLY THAT.
AND I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
CENTER STONE.
THINK ABOUT A PRESIDENT I STAND
IN SUPPORT OF SB [inaudible]
TWO HUNDRED HA.
I REPRESENTS SOME IMPOVERISHED
AREAS WERE I THINK -- THEY'RE
GOING TO BECOME THE
BENEFICIARIES SOME FUNDS TO
ENSURE.
WHAT I CONSIDER TO BE A BASIC
HUMAN RIGHT?
THAT YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE
DEPENDABLE CLEAN DRINKING WATER
ANYWHERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
H. TWO O. BOTH THE MOLECULE OF
LIFE BY FRIENDS -- I WANT.
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
MONTEREY -- I HAVE BEEN SO
IMPRESSED WITH HIS FOCUS -- THE
THE CHALLENGES THEY YOU'D THINK
A SIMPLE BILL LIKE THIS WOULD.
BE ABLE TO BE DONE WITH
[inaudible]
COMMONSENSE.
PEOPLE LIKE WE HAVE A THE
LEGISLATURE BUT IT SHOWS YOU
THERE'S NO EASY TASKS.
HERE ON THE RED FLOOR OR THE OR
THE GREEN CARPET.
BUT TODAY IS A THE CELEBRATION
IS THE CELEBRATION OF LEADERSHIP.
BECAUSE I HONESTLY DON'T BELIEVE
THAT WE WOULD BE HERE TODAY.
I WITHOUT THE THE TREMENDOUS --
WORK.
OF OF MY FRIEND FROM MONTEREY
WHO.
CAME AND SAT WITH THE EARLY ON
DURING THIS PROCESS IN THE ONLY
ISSUES WHAT WE HAD.
REALLY WITH HIS GOALS WAS THE
WAY THAT WE ARE GOING TO FIND IT.
HERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SOME OF
THE MOST IMPOVERISHED AREAS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT.
ADDING ANOTHER FIFTY OR TAX TO
THEIR WATER BILLS OF THE TAP --
CAN MAKE IT VERY ONEROUS AND
VERY PAINFUL FOR FOR MANY THESE
PEOPLE.
SO I'M VERY PROUD TO SAY THAT I
I REPRESENT.
A DISTRICT I REPRESENT.
WITH YOU FORTY MILLION PEOPLE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT AFTER THIS.
PASSES AND GETS TO THE GOVERNOR
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHO
ARE.
I I APPLIED FOR SIGNING THIS
BILL THAT WE CAN ALL STAND IN
UNITY AND SAY.
THAT EVERYONE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IRRESPECTIVE OF THEIR
FINANCIAL STATUS.
WHETHER IMMIGRATION STATUS.
CAN HAVE SAFE DRINKING WATER IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- I
KIND OF WISH WE COULD CALL IT.
MORNINGS LAW BECAUSE HE
CERTAINLY DESERVES THE CREDIT
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP.
AND IT'S AN HONOR TO STAND ON
THE FLOOR WITH HIM.
AND I'M GLAD TO SEE THEY WERE
CARRYING IT OVER THE FINISH LINE
TODAY SIR.
THANK YOU CENTER STONE SENATOR
STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT IS
MEASURE.
AND ONE OF KNOWLEDGE AS SO MANY
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE THIS SOLDIER.
OF JUSTICE FOR SO MANY YEARS.
FINALLY MAKING GOOD ON A PROMISE
TO SO MANY PEOPLE SUFFERING --
AND IT'S NOT JUST A CENTRAL
VALLEY ISSUE.
BUT THEY'RE HURTING THEIR
IMPORTER BILL LIKE TO HURT IN
SOUTH LOS ANGELES LIKE THEIR
HURT IN THE NORTH SALINAS VALLEY
IT'S IT'S TRUE ALL OVER THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND RARELY DOES ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICY FOR MANY OF US GET SO
GROUNDED IN IN LIFE.
BUT I DID WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
ALSO BY SENATOR -- MY COLLEAGUE --
ON THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE SOME
OF THE CONCERNS RAISED YOU KNOW
I CONSIDER THIS VOTE TODAY.
BOTH.
A MEASURE SUPPORT FOR CLEAN
WATER IN CALIFORNIA BUT IT ALSO
HAS TO BE EMBEDDED IN IT A
PROMISE.
BECAUSE THE FUNDS THAT WERE CUT.
TO MAKE ROOM FOR THIS CLEAN
WATER PRIORITY WHICH I
COMPLETELY AGREE HAS TO BE A TOP
PRIORITY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BUT THE FACT THAT WILD FIRE
RESILIENCE FUNDS WERE CUT TO
MAKE ROOM.
OVER A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
FUNDING FOR RESILIENCE.
IS SIMPLY A CHOICE THAT WE
SHOULDN'T BE MAKING.
THE CARBON PRICE RIGHT NOW IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
FIFTEEN DOLLARS AND TEN CENTS.
THE SOCIAL COST OF CARBON
DEVELOP BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION BASED ON THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE.
IN THE WORLD PEER REVIEWED
RESEARCH SAID IT'S ABOUT THIRTY
FIVE DOLLARS A TON.
SO WHY IS INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
PAYING HALF OF WHAT THEY SHOULD
BE. TO THE CARBON PRICING
CALIFORNIA.
I DON'T THINK WE'LL BE FACED
WITH THIS CHOICE OF DECIDING
BETWEEN CLEAN CLEAN AIR AND
CLEAN WATER IF THEY ACTUALLY
REFLECT.
THE SYSTEM ACTUALLY REFLECT AN
ACCURATE CARBON PRICE.
SO I THINK THERE'S WORK TO BE
DONE AND AT THE ADMINISTRATION
AT THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD TO
MAKE OUR CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM.
HONEST AND STRAIGHTFORWARD ABOUT
CARBON PRICING.
AND THEN WE CAN ACTUALLY MAKE
SOME BIGGER DECISIONS HERE
BECAUSE I THINK WE CAN ACTUALLY
DO BOTH IN THE STATE.
I THINK WE CAN SOLVE WILD FIRES
IN CLEAN AIR AND WE CAN SOLVE
CLEAN DINKING WATER.
SO I HOPE WITH THIS AYE VOTE
TODAY.
HOW WE ALL COMMIT OURSELVES TO
FILLING THAT FULL PROMISE -- TO
BRING A MEASURE OF JUSTICE TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN THING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR MONEY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES -- AND A REMINDER
THIS LIKE ANY SUCCESS IN THIS
BUILDING IS A TEAM EFFORT.
AND THIS IS BEEN.
POWERED BY THOSE FROM THE
GRASSROOTS IT'S BEEN POWERED BY
THOSE WHO HAVE STRUGGLED TO HAVE
THEIR VOICES HEARD FOR YEAR
AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR.
SO WE ARE PRIVILEGED.
AS MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AS
WHERE MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY.
TO BE ABLE TO FINALLY.
PROVIDE A REMEDY.
A SOLUTION.
AND TO CONVERT HOPE. TO PROMISE
IN REALITY.
I DO WANT TO JUST COMMENT VERY
BRIEFLY THOUGH -- SOME HAVE
RAISED VERY RESPECTFULLY THEIR
CONCERN -- OF THE USE OF G. G.
R. F. FUNDING MADAM PRESIDENT
WITH PERMISSION TO READ.
FROM THE BILL WITHOUT OBJECTION
THIS IS THE BILL BEFORE US
MEMBERS CLIMATE CHANGE IS
EXACERBATING THE WATER IMPACTS
ON DISADVANTAGED AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY BURDEN TO
COMMUNITIES.
BY REDUCING SURFACE WATER FLOWS
ACCELERATING DECLINING GROUND
WATER BASINS AND CONTRIBUTING TO
INCREASING CONCENTRATIONS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL CONTAMINATION.
THE LANGUAGE GOES ON IF YOU WANT
TO REFER TO IT IN ARE SENATE
BILL.
TWO HUNDRED BUT MEMBERS THE
NEXUS BETWEEN CLIMATE CHANGE
REALITY TO DAY.
AND THE VICTIMS LIVING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ISRAEL.
AND WHILE I AM A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF OUR CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM AND DOING MORE TO
ADVANCE IN INVEST MORE. TO
OFFSET.
IN LIMIT AND REDUCE CARBON
EMISSIONS.
MUCH OF THAT WORK IS LOOKING
PROSPECT OF LEE TO TRY TO
PROTECT AND SAVE OUR PLANET.
SENATE BILL TWO HUNDRED BEFORE
YOU TODAY.
OFFERS A DIRECTION OF SOME OF
THOSE RESOURCES. TO THE
COMMUNITIES OF VICTIMS TODAY.
I SEE OURSELVES WITH THIS BILL
AS FIRST RESPONDERS.
AS EMERGENCY FIRST RESPONDERS TO
COMMUNITIES FOR HOME MANY OF US
THIS IS A BE A RADICAL.
CHALLENGE BECAUSE WE ENJOY IN
TAKE FOR GRANTED CLEAN SAFE
DRINKING WATER WHEN WE TURN ON
THE TAP.
BUT FOR THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SUPPORTED THIS EFFORT IN THE
COALITION'S THERE BEEN ORGANIZED
IT'S NOT A THEORETICAL ISSUE.
IT IS A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
EXACERBATED BY CLIMATE CHANGE
TODAY AND TOO OFTEN WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE.
WE REFER TO A FUTURE RISK.
MEMBERS CLIMATE CHANGE IS UPON
US WHETHER IT'S WILD FIRES IN
THE NEW ABNORMAL THE FORMER
GOVERNOR BROWN TALKED ABOUT.
OR THE EXACERBATIONS AND
STRESSES ON OUR WATER SYSTEMS
RESULTING IN GREATER
CONTAMINATION AND RISK
MEMBERS THIS BILL REPRESENTS
NEGOTIATIONS AMONG OUR
LEADERSHIP.
THE PRO TEM THE SPEAKER AND THE
GOVERNOR.
IN WITH YOUR SUPPORT WE WILL
MOVE THIS TO GET THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK.
WITH AN URGENCY BILL THAT WILL
MAKE IT EFFECTIVE UPON SIGNING.
IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
SOUGHT  REMEDY.
CAN NOW GET IN LINE TO BE
CONSIDERED. FOR SUPPORT THAT
WILL BE REAL.
TANGIBLE IN TRANSLATE TO SAFE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER THANK YOU
MEMBERS I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MINING MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
I WELL.
I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DOLLY [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROW.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL [inaudible]
HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES.
HI LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I MORRELL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AM BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
NO WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY FIVE SENATOR WIENER.
BEN SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SORRY PASS TEMPORARILY
-- GROW
FOR WHAT PURPOSE YOU RISE.
WE CAN CAUCUS IN THE COX LOUNGE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN THE COX
LOUNGE
WELL GOOD EVENING
SENATORS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO GET
STARTED IN ABOUT SIXTY SECONDS
WE'RE GONNA ASK FOLKS TO BE ABLE.
TO RECONVENE HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS A WE'RE GONNA GET
STARTED IN ABOUT SIXTY SECONDS
[inaudible]
CENTER PORTANTINO IF YOU RIGHTS
I RISE TO RECONVENE THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE FROM
OUR RECESS EARLIER TODAY IN ROOM.
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE NOW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
PORTANTINO.
ALL APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CAN YOU PLEASE REPORT TO
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE AT
THIS MOMENT.
ALL APPROPRIATION NUMBERS IF YOU
COULD PLEASE REPORT TO THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE AT THIS MOMENT
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE ADVANCING
IN OUR FILE THE FILE ITEM.
FORTY SEVEN SENATOR MITCHELL'S
PREPARED TO PRESENT.
MADAM SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
THREE NINETY TWO ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER AN ACT
RELATING TO PEACE OFFICERS.
SENATE MITCHELL THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU VERY MISS VERY
MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
TODAY.
I PROBABLY RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINETY TWO
THE CALIFORNIA ACT TO SAVE LIVES.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO RAISE
CALIFORNIA'S LEGAL STANDARD FOR
WHEN POLICE CAN USE DEADLY FORCE.
TO MATCH BEST PRACTICES ALREADY
IN PLACE IN SOME DEPARTMENTS.
AND THAT WE KNOW WORK TO KEEP
BOTH OFFICERS AND THE PUBLIC
FACE.
THIS BILLS GOAL IS TO SAVE LIVES
BOTH IN FRONT.
AND BEHIND THE BADGE.
THIS BILL WILL NOW WORK BECAUSE
OF THE BUY IN FROM BOTH LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE.
I'D LIKE TO UP LIVE THE ADVOCACY
OF THE FAMILIES THAT HAVE TURNED
OUT.
WHO SHARED THEIR TRAGEDIES THAT
THEY'VE BEEN DOOR INTO A
MOVEMENT TO ENSURE THAT NO OTHER
FAMILIES EXPERIENCE THE LOSS OF
A LOVED?
ONE MORE TIMES THAN NOT.
AND AN ARMED LOVED.
ONE COLLEAGUES AB THREE NINETY
TWO WAS ABOUT PREVENTING
UNNECESSARY DEATHS BY CLEAR FINE
LONG FORCES OBLIGATIONS WHEN
MAKING THE DECISION TO USE
DEADLY FORCE.
AB THREE NINETY TWO REPLACES THE
CURRENT VAGUE STANDARD THE
OFFICES CAN USE DEADLY FORCE
WHENEVER QUOTE REASONABLE
STANDARD WHAT THEY HIGHER
STANDARD THAT AUTHORIZES DEADLY
FORCE.
ONLY WHEN NECESSARY TO DEFEND
AGAINST AN IMMINENT THREAT OF
DEATH OR SERIOUS BODILY INJURY.
THE BILL IS SQUARELY IN LINE
WITH BEST PRACTICES AND
STANDARDS RECOGNIZED BY
ACADEMICS AND EXPERTS IN THE
FIELD.
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND IS
MODELED AFTER POLICIES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN PLACE AT SEVERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
THESE STANDARDS ARE KNOWN TO
REDUCE SERIOUS USES OF FORCE
WITHOUT HAVING ANY NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON OFFICER SAFETY OR
PUBLIC SAFETY.
AS A RESULT OF THIS BILL AND IT
SING IT SENATE COMPANION BILL.
ALL AGENCIES WILL BE REQUIRED TO
UPDATE THEIR POLICIES TO INCLUDE
THESE BEST PRACTICES.
AND TO ENSURE THAT OFFICERS ARE
TRAINED TO THE STANDARDS.
CALLING WITH REGARD TO THE
TRAINING.
BUDGET ACTIONS WERE TAKING THIS
YEAR TO SUPPORT THIS NEW
EXPECTATION [inaudible]
MORE OVER.
PEACE OFFICER IN STANDARDS
TRAINING PULSE TRAINING.
THE BUDGET INCREASE THIS YEAR
ABOVE THEIR BASELINE FUNDING.
IS A 75% INCREASE.
IN ADDITION TO TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
PACIFIC WE IDENTIFIED FOR
TRAINING FOR DE ESCALATION OVER
THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
SO IN THIS INSTANCE WE HAVE PUT
OUR MONEY WHERE OUR CORE BELIEFS
STAND.
A TRAINING AND WE HAVE PROVIDED
FUNDING FOR THE TRAINING.
THERE'S BEEN LOTS OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS BILL IN
THESE HALLOWED HALLS AND IN THE
PUBLIC AND IN THE MEDIA.
I HOPE EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS THAT
AND APPRECIATE THE BILL
SPONSORED BY OVER TEN
ORGANIZATIONS AND HAS OVER ONE
HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED GROUPS IN
SUPPORT.
THE POWER OF LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
USE DEADLY FORCE.
UNDER THE COLOR OF AUTHORITY IS
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
RESPONSIBILITY WE CONFER ON ANY
PUBLIC OFFICIAL OUTSIDE OF THE
MILITARY.
AND IT MUST BE GUIDED BY THE
GOAL OF SAFEGUARDING HUMAN LIFE.
FOR THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE OF A. B..
THREE NINETY TWO THANK YOU
CENTER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE SEVERAL.
SENATORS WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
ON THIS BILL WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
GO THROUGH OUR FIRST.
THREE REGULAR SENATOR MORLOCK.
SENATOR NIELSEN.
AND THEN TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR BRADFORD.
THEY'RE MORE LIKE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
NINETY TWO AND ITS COMPANION SB.
TWO THIRTY COLLEAGUES AS VICE
CHAIR OF PUBLIC SAFETY I LISTEN
TO LENGTHY AND PASSIONATE
TESTIMONIES PRESENTED.
WHEN NT CALLED OUT FOR
TEMPORARY REQUESTED TO OTHER
COMMITTEE MEETINGS?
BUT A VERY MOVING.
COLLEAGUES WHEN I SERVED AS
ORANGE COUNTY SUPERVISOR.
THERE WAS AN INCIDENT WHERE A
DEPUTY SHERIFF.
SHOT AND KILLED A MAN WHO
DECIDED TO MOVE HIS PARK ISSUE
BE FORWARD.
HE HAD HIS TWO DAUGHTERS IN A
ROW OF SEATS DIRECTLY BEHIND HIM.
THE OFFICER SHOT INTO THE DOOR A
FEW TIMES [inaudible]
KILLED HIM.
THE MAN WAS BLACK.
HE WAS A DRILL SERGEANT FROM.
THE CAMP PENDLETON MARINE BASE.
HE COULD HAVE ACTED AND BEHAVE
IN A CALMER MANNER.
BUT THE DEPUTY SHERIFF COULD
HAVE WITH HELLFIRE.
OR SIMPLY SHOT OUT A TIRE.
TO WHEN THE MATTER CAME TO A
CLOSE SESSION AND I DON'T WANT
TO BETRAY ANY CONFIDENTIAL
MATTERS BUT WHEN IT CAME TO
CLOSE SESSION I SIMPLY STATED.
THAT WE SHOULD GIVE THE WIDOW
AND HIS CHILDREN WHATEVER THE
REQUESTED.
I WAS IN NO [inaudible]
MOOD.
TO VOTE TO FIGHT.
IN A LAWSUIT.
OR TO MEET THEM IN COURT.
THE COUNTY WOULD SETTLE FOR FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
THE DEPUTY WOULD BE CLEARED OF
THE FATAL SHOOTING.
THE PROSECUTOR SAID THE SHOOTING
WAS TRAGIC IMPOSSIBLY
PREVENTABLE BUT THE DEPUTY HAD
ACTED REASONABLY AND HAD DONE
NOTHING TO WARRANT CRIMINAL
CHARGES.
COLLEAGUES WE NEED TO REDUCE.
THESE TRAGIC.
AND POSSIBLY PREVENTABLE.
EVENTS DEADLY FORCE SHOULD ONLY
BE USED WHEN NECESSARY.
THEY ARE DEVASTATING TO FAMILIES
THEY DISTURB THE COMMUNITY.
AND THEY'RE COSTLY TO TAXPAYERS.
TO THE LOGGINS FAMILY.
AGAIN EXPRESS MY SINCERE
CONDOLENCES. TO OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMUNITY LET'S HOPE THE
ADDITIONAL TRAINING KEEPS
EVERYONE SAFE.
FOR AB THREE NINETY TWO HAS BEEN
A SOUL SEARCHING EXERCISE ONE
THAT HAS BROUGHT BACK OLD IN
SAID PERSONAL MEMORIES.
I HOPE THIS BILL STRIKES THE
RIGHT BALANCE MISTER PRESIDENT --
AS PUBLIC SAFETY PERSONNEL HAVE
DIFFICULT RESPONSIBILITIES
[inaudible]
WE LEARN THAT TODAY.
BY HONORING TURNER O'SULLIVAN ON
THE FLOOR WHEN WE STARTED OUR
SESSION.
POLICE OFFICERS SOMETIMES LIKE
AIRLINE PILOTS THEY CAN ONLY
MAKE A MISTAKE ONCE.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON AB THREE NINETY TWO
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS JUST.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO THE DEAN AND
SENATE CENTER NIELSEN.
JUST PRESENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE THE EARLY
VERSIONS OF THIS BILL.
I ACTIVELY WORKED AGAINST.
BEFORE IT WAS EVEN BEGINNING TO
MEN.
WHEN ITS WAY THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE?
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN.
THE DISASTER FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND SAFETY IN OUR COMMUNITY.
AND FOR JUSTICE.
I COMMANDED THE IMPROVEMENT THAT
HAS BEEN MADE IN THE
COLLABORATIVE WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND VARIOUS.
GROUPS WHO WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
IT.
AND THIS PRESERVES OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT FACTORS IN THESE VERY
DIFFICULT SITUATIONS.
AND KEEP IN MIND IF YOU'RE A LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONAL ON THE
LINE.
THERE'S A FURTIVE MOVEMENT.
AND YOU DO FEEL THAT YOUR LIFE
IS IN DANGER YOU DO NOT HAVE
TIME TO SAY HEY BUDDY CAN WE SIT
DOWN AND NEGOTIATE CAN WE LOOK
TO SOME ALTERNATIVES COULD YOU
TRY THIS OR THAT OR THE OTHER
THING. FOR THE SAFETY OF THAT
OFFICER IN THE COMMUNITY AS WELL
THERE IS NO TIME. FOR THOSE
DECISIONS.
AND THOSE OFFICERS DO NOT HOLD
THE TOTALITY OF THAT EXPERIENCE
MEANING FROM WHEN THEY GOT THE
DISPATCH WHAT WAS.
FOR WHEN THEY WENT TO THE SCENE
AND SAW WHAT THEY WERE
RESPONDING.
TO AND WHEN THEY SOUGHT AND
APPREHENDED FOR EXAMPLE AN
INDIVIDUAL.
OR CAME UPON.
THE SCENE OF AN INCIDENT.
THEY TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT.
AND THEY ALREADY ARE THOROUGHLY
TRAINED.
IN ALL ARGUE THAT THERE'S NOT.
ANON DO NUMBER.
OF THESE TRAGEDIES.
BUT THEY ALL ARE TRAGEDIES.
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO.
DIED.
THEY HAVE FAMILY.
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS THE
VICTIM.
OF THAT CRIME WHATEVER THAT
CRIME MAY HAVE BEEN EVEN A
RESIDENTIAL BURGLARY.
THEY PAY A PRICE.
TO THEY HAVE A SENSE THAT THEY
HAVE TO SERVE [inaudible]
FEAR.
BUT THIS DOES PROVIDE FOR THE
TOTALITY OF THAT CIRCUMSTANCE TO
BE CONSIDERED.
BY THAT OFFICER [inaudible] TO
BE.
HEATING THEIR TRAINING.
AS A ALREADY DO.
BUT THESE EXTRA PRECAUTIONS THE
RESULT IN COCKADED INTO THE BILL.
DO MAKE IT I THINK.
A STEP.
IN A POSITIVE DIRECTION. TO
ALLEVIATE CONCERNS OF MANY OF
THOSE WHO FEEL VERY STRONGLY.
AGAINST THE NUMBERS OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE BEEN
KILLED.
IN ONE FORCED MINISTERS AND THEY
ALSO ARE ACCOMMODATING TO THOSE
OF US.
WHO ARE STRONG SUPPORTERS?
OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY.
AND THOUGH I WILL VOTE YESTERDAY.
I RESERVE MY OPPORTUNITIES TO BE
VIGILANT IN THE FUTURE.
IF THERE ARE ANY ATTEMPTS TO
CHANGE.
THE VERBIAGE IN THIS LEGISLATION.
HARKENING TO THAT FORMER
LANGUAGE.
THAT WOULD BE SO ONEROUS.
WE MUST NOT PUT [inaudible]
THE HANDCUFFS.
ON A LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALS.
AND ASK THEM. TO PROTECT US.
AND TO PRESERVE JUSTICE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MEMBERS WOULD
LIKE TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER THE
CENTER BRADFORD THEY WERE GONNA
GO TO SENATOR SKINNER.
AND SENATOR ARTILLERY.
CENTER BRADFORD THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
AND I STAND HERE TODAY AS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR AND BY SURE OF
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE NINE TWO A MEASURE WHOSE
TIME IS LONG.
OVERDUE AND IT'S CALM.
IN MANY WAYS TO SPREAD THE MOST
IMPORTANT MEASURE I WILL VOTE ON
AS THE LEGISLATURE.
BUT SINCE MANY OF YOU'VE NEVER
SPENT A DAY IN MY FAIR GOBBLES
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT IT MEANS TO
BE BLACK.
AND FACE LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THERE'S BEEN MUCH DEBATE.
ABOUT THIS ISSUE [inaudible]
WELL NEEDED.
THIS MEASURE STARTED OUT AS A
POLICE REFORM BILL.
WELL WHAT WE HAVE THE DAY AS FAR
FROM IT IT'S A TRAINING BILL.
AND I'M OKAY WITH THAT.
BECAUSE I'VE COME TO THE REALITY
IT'S NOT ART POLICE DEPARTMENT
THAT NEEDS REFORMING IT'S OUR
HEARTS AND MINDS WHEN IT COMES
TO RACE IN THIS COUNTRY.
BECAUSE THIS COUNTRY WAS FOUNDED
ON RACISM IT WAS FOUNDED ON THE
SLAVERY OF BLACK PEOPLE.
THE ANNIHILATING OF THE RED MAN.
AND EXPORT EXPLOITATION OF THE
BROWN.
AND YELLOW MAN.
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE WHITE.
AND YOU LIVE IN MALIBU.
IN SAN FRANCISCO IN BEVERLY
HILLS YOUR LAW ENFORCEMENT WORKS
FOR YOU.
WE SAW JUST A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
A WOMAN WHO LET LAPD AND HIGHWAY
PATROL ON A MAT CHAOTIC CHASE
FOR HOURS [inaudible] FOUR HOURS.
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF PROPERTY
DESTRUCTION. THREE PEOPLE SENT
TO A HOSPITAL AS WELL AS TWO
DOGS INTO THE HOSPITAL.
SHE AT EXIT HER VEHICLE AND RAN
NOT ONE SHOT WAS FIRED HE IS
LIVE TO TELL HER STORY THAT
INDIVIDUAL WAS WHITE.
BUT JUST TWO WEEKS AGO.
A YOUNG AFRICAN AMERICAN IN MY
DISTRICT WHO WAS SIMPLY BACKING
HIS CAR OUT OF A DRIVEWAY.
VERY SLOWLY IN THE APARTMENT
BUILDING HE LIVED IN. THIRTY
FOUR SHOTS. THIRTY FOUR SHOTS.
ON ARMED BLACK MEN.
AND WILL BROOK LOS ANGELES THERE
ARE TWO DIFFERENT.
AMERICA'S FOLKS.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
OF WERE.
I WANT TO DRIVE HOME.
THE RACE ISSUE.
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO IN FORT
MYERS FLORIDA.
WE HEARD ABOUT THE MAYOR --
BARRICADED HIMSELF IN HIS HOUSE
AND SHOT REPEATEDLY AT LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
REPEATEDLY AT LAW ENFORCEMENT HE
IS ALIVE TODAY TO TELL HIS STORY
NOT ONE SHOT WAS FIRED AT THIS
INDIVIDUAL.
DID I FILL THE MENTIONED THAT
INDIVIDUAL WAS QUITE.
THEY DO NOT FEAR FOR THEIR LIVES
WHEN THEY ENCOUNTER WHITE MEN
WITH GUNS BUT THEY FEAR FOR
THEIR LIVES WHEN THEY ENCOUNTER
AFRICAN AMERICAN WITH NO MORE.
THAN A CELL PHONE RUNNING.
FROM POLICE SO MEMBERS WE NEED
TO REFORM OUR HEARTS.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
HISTORY.
OF USE OF DEADLY FORCE WHICH WAS
INTRODUCED IN.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO THERE WAS
NO RISING CRIME IN CALIFORNIA
LET ALONE AMERICA AND EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO WHAT HAPPENED IN.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO BLACK FOLKS
WERE FREE AND THAT WAS ANOTHER
TOOL. TO EXECUTE AND KILL BLACK
FOLKS SO I'M DEEPLY SADDENED
WHEN LAST WEEK.
AND HIRE A AT TWO OF OUR
COLLEAGUES VOTED TO AGAINST
ETHNIC STUDIES BECAUSE OF WE HAD
ETHNIC STUDIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ARE UNIVERSITIES
WOULD PROBABLY TELL THE STORY OF
RACE A LOT BETTER THAN WHAT WE
DO TODAY.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE AGAIN I WANT TO
MAKE THE COMPARISON OF RACE. TWO
YEARS AGO IN MINNESOTA.
A OFFICER SHOT ON ON ARMED.
WHITE WOMAN.
HE STATED HE FEARED FOR HIS LIFE.
THE CHIEF QUICKLY ONE ON PUBLIC
TV.
EVERY TO KILL THE OFFICER FOR A
SHOOTING OUT OF POLICY THAT
OFFICER WAS QUICKLY FIRED.
AND SURELY THERE AFTER HE WAS
CHARGED.
WITH MURDER. TWO MONTHS AGO HE
WAS CONVICTED OF MURDER WAS
BECAUSE THE VICTIM WAS WHITE AND
UNARMED.
WAS IT BECAUSE THE OFFICER WAS
BLACK AND HE WAS MUZZLE.
THERE IS A DOUBLE STANDARD HERE.
AND WE NEED TO ADDRESS IT WHEN
IT COMES TO OUR OUR LONG PORTS
BUT I DON'T HOLD OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
RESPONSIBLE BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S
ROOTED IN RACE DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING SAID THE NEGRO IN AMERICA
GETS.
TWICE AS MUCH AS WHAT IS BAD IN
ONLY HALF OF WHAT IS GOOD IN
AMERICA THAT.
DEALS WITH OUR COURT SYSTEM OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM ON HOUSING.
R. I. N. YES OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENTS.
HE'S STILL EXIST TODAY.
DR KING ALSO STATED WE CAN NEVER
BE SATISFIED AS LONG AS THE
NEGRO IS THE VICTIM UNSPEAKABLE
HORRORS OF POLICE BRUTALITY.
THAT WAS IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE
IS STILL APPLIES TODAY.
IT STILL APPLIES TODAY.
SO COLLEAGUES.
I WANTED TO REFLECT.
ON WHERE WE ARE AND WHY WE'RE
HERE TODAY.
AGAIN IT WAS NOTHING HAPPENING
IN AMERICA IN.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO THAT
WARRANTED THE USE OF DEADLY
FORCE OTHER THAN THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE ME.
WHO WERE FREE?
AND I CHALLENGES.
TO REALLY LOOK AT THIS ISSUE OF
RACE.
FAR BEYOND AGAIN OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT IT'S TIME FOR US TO
CHANGE OUR HEARTS.
AND OUR MINDS [inaudible]
BECAUSE AGAIN.
STEP ON CLARK SIMPLY RUNNING
FROM THE POLICE.
ANY LOST HIS LIFE IN HIS
GRANDMOTHER'S.
BACKYARD EASIER FOR A MENTALLY
CHALLENGED INDIVIDUAL WHO COMPLY
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THE CITY
OF A LACK LA WITH HIS HANDS UP.
WE SHOT THREE TIMES IN HIS BACK.
OSCAR GRANT RAN REALLY PULLED
OFF A TRAIN IN OAKLAND.
ON NEW YEAR'S DAY.
SIMPLY BECAUSE HE LOOKED LIKE A
GANG MEMBER AND HE WAS SHOT IN
HIS BACK.
EVEN IN NEW YORK WERE THE AMP
IMPLEMENTED STOP QUESTION
IMPRESSED.
DURING MAYOR BLOOMBERG'S TENURE.
70% OF THE INDIVIDUALS WERE
STOPPED QUESTION AND PRESSED
WERE AFRICAN AMERICAN OR LATINO.
OF THE MAJORITY NINE HAD A
WEAPON.
NONE KICK COMMITTED A CRIME AND
NINE HAD OUTSTANDING WARRANTS
BUT YET IT YET AGAIN 70%.
STOP QUESTION IMPRESSED.
I HOPE THIS TRAINING THAT.
AB THREE NINETY TO BRING FORTH
AGAIN WILL CHANGE NOT ONLY THE
PRACTICES BECAUSE AGAIN. ONE
FORCE WE GET TO WRITE WHEN THEY
ENCOUNTER.
FOLKS THAT DON'T LOOK LIKE MAY.
IT'S A DIFFERENT STANDARD AND
PEOPLE OFTEN ASK WHY DO AFRICAN
AMERICANS RUN FROM POLICE.
WE'VE BEEN RUNNING FROM THE TORY
SINCE YOU BROUGHT US HERE IN
SLAVE SHIPS FOUR HUNDRED YEARS
AGO.
WE HAVE BEEN RUNNING FROM THE
TOWARD.
AND MY MOTHER USED TO CALL MY
GRANDMOTHER.
HE IS TO SAY IT'S BETTER TO SAY
THERE HE GO.
IN THERE HE LIVES.
WE HAVE BEEN TAUGHT.
AND ALSO THERE IS A DOUBLE
STANDARD WHEN IT COMES TO AGAIN
TEACHING AND AFTER AMERICAN HOME
WHEN HE ENCOUNTERS LAW
ENFORCEMENT VERSUS AND WHY DON'T.
THE FIRST TIME I EVER SPENT THE
NIGHT AWAY FROM.
OUR HOME THAT WASN'T WHAT A
FAMILY FRIEND WAS AT MY BEST
FRIEND'S HOUSE ANTI WEISS.
AND I LISTEN TO HIS FAMILY AND
THEIR INTERACTION.
WHAT POLICE IN WAS FAR DIFFERENT
IN THE CONVERSATION WE HAD IN MY
HOUSE SO?
IN THAT HOUSE SO IT WAS.
HEY IF YOU'RE STOP YOU GET THAT
BADGE NUMBER YOU GET THAT
OFFICER'S NAME AND YOU MAKE SURE
YOU LET HIM KNOW WHAT YOUR MOM
AND DAD AS IN MY HOUSE SOLD.
YOU WERE TOLD TO SHUT UP.
MAKE SURE YOUR HANDS -- IN CLEAR
SIGHT AND SAY YES SIR NO SIR AND
HOPE YOU MAKE IT HOME SAFELY.
AGAIN I USED EXAMPLE FIVE YEARS
AGO AND HEARING THE COMMITTEE
HERE.
SELECT COMMITTEE ON BOYS AND MEN
OF COLOR AND WE WERE DEALING
WITH THE INTERACTION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND WE HAD A POLICE
CHIEF.
WHO WAS TESTIFYING?
AND WE ASK THEM ARE THERE
DIFFERENT CHALLENGES WHEN YOU
ENCOUNTER BLOCKING BROWN.
ANY HESITATED FOR A MOMENT
[inaudible]
AND HIS EYES WELLED UP WITH
TEARS.
AND HE SAYS YES THERE IS HE SAYS
BECAUSE THE CONVERSATION I HAD
TO HAVE WITH MY SIXTEEN YEAR OLD
SON.
THE DAY HE GOT HIS DRIVER'S
LICENSE IS A CONVERSATION MY
COLLEAGUES DO NOT HAVE TO HAVE.
THAT POLICE CHIEF WAS AFRICAN
AMERICAN.
AND HE SAID HE HAS HE'S HERE
WITH HIS SON IS NOT.
IF YOU'LL BE STOPPED IT'S WHEN
YOU WILL BE STOPPED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
SO COLLEAGUES I ASKED FOR A YES
VOTE.
BECAUSE THERE ARE DOUBLE
STANDARDS BUT AGAIN IT'S NOT OUR
POLICE DEPARTMENT AT A WHOLE OF
FOG MY WHOLE RACISM AT FAULT AND
IT'S TIME FOR US TO DEAL WITH-THAT.
TOO AND CALIFORNIA IN AMERICA
[inaudible]
AS PRIVATE.
SIR BRADFORD WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR ELOQUENT TESTIMONY.
NOW LIKE TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER
TO SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THANK
YOU MEMBERS AND THANK YOU -- MY
COLLEAGUES FROM.
GUARDIAN AND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOS ANGELES FOR VERY ELOQUENT
TESTIMONY -- AS CHAIR OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY POLICY COMMITTEE
AND THE PUBLIC SAFETY BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
I AM VERY PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL.
AND ALSO TO HAVE IN THE BUDGET --
PART -- SHEPHERDED MUCH OF THE
FUNDING FOR THE POST TRAINING
MULLIN REATTACH ABOUT WHY.
WE USE TERMS LIKE IMPLICIT BIAS
THERE'S A LOT OF TERMS WE USE
NOW.
BUT THE FACT IS.
THAT VAST AMOUNTS OF RESEARCH
VAST AMOUNTS.
DEMONSTRATE THAT EACH AND EVERY
ONE OF US.
REGARDLESS OF OUR COLOR.
REGARDLESS OF OUR PROFESSION I'M
TALKING ABOUT AMERICANS.
DUE TO THE LONG SEATED.
AND SYSTEMIC RACISM.
THAT OUR CULTURE AND OUR COUNTRY.
WERE FOUNDED ON WERE BUILT ON
THAT THE LAWS WERE BASED ON THAT
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM WAS BASED
ON JUST EVERY SINGLE INSTITUTION
IN OUR COUNTRY AND I STATE THIS.
NOT TO SAY THAT I AM NOT A PROUD
AMERICAN.
NOT TO SAY THAN I AM AT THE
LEAST BIT EMBARRASSED ABOUT OUR
BILL OF RIGHTS OR OUR
CONSTITUTION.
I LOVE THEM.
BUT I KNOW ALSO.
THAT THOSE WORDS.
WERE NOT DESIGNED TO PROTECT
EVERYONE AND THAT OVER TIME
WE'VE UNDERSTOOD THAT.
AND WE ARE WORKING TO CORRECT IT.
AND WE HAVE TO HAVE WE HAVE HAD
TO DO MUCH TO CORRECTED MUCH AND
WE STILL HAVE TO DO MORE.
SO I SEE IT MORE JUST TO BE
CLEAR AND HONEST AND RECOGNIZE
IT [inaudible]
ENACT RESULTS IN THAT EACH AND
EVERYONE OF US MAKE ASSUMPTIONS
[inaudible]
ABOUT [inaudible]
BLACK PEOPLE.
BROWN PEOPLE OFF ALSO OFTEN
SOMETIMES A P. I. BUT PRIMARILY
BLACK PEOPLE [inaudible]
THAT.
THEY HAVE A CRIMINAL INTENT.
THAT THEY HAVE A TENDENCY TO
VIOLENCE.
ANY NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS.
WE SHOW THESE SURVEYS WHERE.
WE ARE DESCRIBED THERE'S
DESCRIBED A CRIME THAT OCCURRED.
AND THEN WERE -- THE PERSON IS
DESCRIBED AND THEN WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO CIRCLE YOU KNOW WHO
THEY WHO THAT PERSON MIGHT ABED.
ANOTHER'S PICTURES [inaudible]
IT'S THE PERCENTAGE OF ARE
CIRCLING THE BLACK PERSON AND
THAT'S AGAIN NO MATTER WATER
COLORS.
IS WAY HIGH SOFT THE CHARTS
[inaudible]
SO.
BECAUSE OF THESE ASSUMPTIONS.
THE RESULTS IN MANY MANY BAD
CONSEQUENCES.
BUT THE WORST.
IS THE PROVEN INCREASED
POTENTIAL FOR A BLACK PERSON TO
DIE AT THE HANDS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND I DON'T BLAME ONLY LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR THAT THOUGH
CERTAINLY THERE ARE SOME LAW
ENFORCEMENT INDIVIDUALS WHO
REALLY ARE NOT GOOD APPLES.
BUT THESE BIASES ARE SO DEEP.
THEY CAN ONLY BE CORRECTED IF WE
ARE INTENTIONAL.
IF WE RECOGNIZE IT AND IF WE ACT
WITH PURPOSE.
AND THIS BILL.
IS AN ACT WITH PURPOSE.
IT IS IN FACT THAT BY RAISING
THE USE OF FORCE STANDARD.
IT WILL LESSEN.
THE DANGER AND RISK.
THAT A BLACK PERSON WILL DIE AT
THE HANDS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY OUR
RESPONSIBILITY.
TO TO ABSOLUTELY.
NOW WILL IT A TOTALLY ELIMINATE
NO.
AND WE MAY FIND OVER TIME.
WE HAVE TO GO A LOT FARTHER.
BUT IT DOES STRIKE A VERY
IMPORTANT BALANCE AND WITH THE
POST TRAINING AND WE HEARD FROM
SECTION ELOQUENT RESEARCHER.
IN OUR PUBLIC SAFETY.
COMMITTEE RECENTLY AND I AM
FEELING VERY EMBARRASSED THAT I
CANNOT REMEMBER HER NAME.
BUT SHE'S DONE RESEARCH ON HOW
WE CAN TRAIN [inaudible] TO
BASICALLY.
BECAUSE THAT THAT JUST CHANGING
THE USE OF FORCE STANDARD ALONE
WILL NOT DO IT.
AND THAT ONLY CERTAIN KINDS OF
TRAINING WILL ACTUALLY CHANGE
OUR BIAS.
AND THERE'S GOOD RESEARCH THAT
SHOWS THE KIND OF TRAINING THAT
WILL.
THAT WILL THEN.
NOT ONLY.
PROTECT.
THAT BLACK PERSON FROM THAT RISK
AT THE HANDS OF THE OFFICER BUT
PROTECT OUR OFFICERS.
SO TO ME THIS BILL IT'S SO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT DOES THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCING.
IT RECOGNIZES.
THAT OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS THEMSELVES EVERY TIME
THE DONNED THEIR UNIFORMS.
AND WALK OUT THEIR DOOR.
THEIR LIVES ARE AT RISK.
AND NONE OF US WANT TO INCREASE
THE RISK. TO OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS.
AND THE WORK DONE BY THE AUTHOR.
FIRE PRO TEM IN HER STAFF.
BY OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY
FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS TO SIT
DOWN AND WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
[inaudible]
THAT WORK.
AND OTHERS WERE INVOLVED IN A
TWO RESULTED IN A BILL.
THAT APPROPRIATELY PROTECTS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT IT MOST
IMPORTANTLY CORRECTS.
CALIFORNIA'S USE OF FORCE
STANDARD. TO PROTECT EACH AND
EVERYONE OF US.
BUT ESPECIALLY THOSE RESIDENTS
WHO ARE MOST AT RISK OF LOSING
THEIR LIVES TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHICH IS OUR BLACK RESIDENTS.
AND THAT IS ABSOLUTELY.
AS I SAID SOMETHING.
IT IS ON US TO CORRECT.
AND I'M SO PROUD TO BE PART OF
THAT CORRECTION.
AND I'M ALSO VERY PROUD THAT THE
TRAINING IS PART OF IT.
IN [inaudible]
AND I'M.
FIND WE WILL BE MONITORING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE TRAINING
INCLUDES THAT BIAS TRAINING THAT
IS SO ESSENTIAL BECAUSE
OTHERWISE.
WHEN WE STAND HERE AND VOTE FOR
THIS BILL?
WE WANT IT TO WORK WE DO NOT
WANT THIS JUST TO BE SYMBOLIC WE
ACTUALLY WANT.
TO CHANGE THAT BY S.
[inaudible]
AND THUS.
REDUCE THE DEATH BECAUSE IT IS
NOT APPROPRIATE AND I WOULD
FINALLY SAY [inaudible]
SOME.
PEOPLE WERE JOKING.
WHEN AROUND ME WHEN [inaudible]
THE AND I'M NOT TRYING TO
CRITICIZE THEM BUT WHEN THE
RAPPER WHO IS IN HIS MERCEDES.
AT THE FAST FOOD STOP IN VALLEJO
ANY FELL ASLEEP.
HE FELL ASLEEP.
HE HAD I DON'T KNOW IF THE GUN
WAS IN HIS LAP I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE THE ACTUAL RECORDS BUT THE
INFORMATION THAT WAS PORTRAYED
WAS THAT HE DID [inaudible]
AND THE FAST FOOD WORKERS.
CALLED THE POLICE BECAUSE THEY
COULDN'T REVIVE FROM THERE THE
DOORS WERE LOCKED AND ALL BUT HE
WAS STATE TO SLEEP AND THEY
NEEDED HIM TO MOVE OUT OF THE
WAY.
SO THEY COULD GET THE NEXT
CUSTOMERS THEY DIDN'T CALL THE
POLICE BECAUSE THEY WERE FEARFUL
OF THEIR LIVES THEY WERE JUST
TRYING.
TO GET THE DRIVE THROUGH GET THE
CUSTOMER'S.
BUT WHEN THE POLICE CAME
[inaudible]
AND A KNOCKED ON HIS WINDOW AND
OF COURSE STARTLED.
HE WOKE UP [inaudible]
HE WENT. TWO IS SUPPOSEDLY TO
HIS LAP FOR THIS GUN HE DID NOT
LIFTED UP IT REYES SAID HE WAS
DEAD BEFORE THAT.
BUT THE POINT OF BRINGING UP IS
THAT SOME FRIENDS MY JOKED THAT.
IT WOULD NEVER HAPPEN TO ME AND
THEY WERE JOKING JUST BECAUSE
I'M WHITE BUT THEY WERE LIKE.
SOME COPS ARE YOU.
SITTING IN THE CAR AN OLD LADY
AND ME NOT TO PUT MYSELF DOWN.
A WHITE WOMAN.
WITH A GUN IN HER CAR IN VALLEJO
THEY JUST THINK YOU WERE TRYING
TO PROTECT YOURSELF.
AND WITH THAT I ASKED FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO SENATOR ARCHULETA
THEY WERE GOING TO SENATOR PAN
AND THEN COPY HERE.
SEARCH A LETTER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
YOU SO VERY MUCH I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AND MY SENATOR FROM GARDENA WHAT
A GREAT JOB HE DID IN HIS
PRESENTATION.
AND HOLLY MITCHELL I WILL POINT
YOUR NAME OUT WHAT A GREAT JOB
YOU'VE DONE.
AND I KNOW -- THE COMMUNITY
REPRESENT.
BUT THIS BILL OPENS THE DOOR IS
THE FIRST STEP AS I SEE IT NOW I
SEE THAT THE JOINT.
BILL AB THREE NINETY TWO THAT
THAT BRINGS THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY TOGETHER UNDERSTANDING
THAT SOMETHING HAD TO GET DONE.
AND I'M SO PROUD THAT WE HAVE
COME TOGETHER AS LEGISLATORS
THAT.
RECOGNIZES AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE ISSUES OUT THERE IN
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY.
AND OUR OWN COMMUNITIES WITH A
BLACK HISPANIC WEBER.
THAT ISSUES NEED TO BE RAISED.
AND IT STARTS WITH THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY WHERE THEY
RECEIVE THE TRAINING.
AND THE GUIDANCE AND THE
EQUIPMENT AND THE NECESSARY
FUNDING FOR THAT TRAINING.
SO POST IT'S GOT A LOOK INTO
THEIR STANDARDS POSES GOT IT SEE
WHAT THEY CAN DO SENSITIVITY
TRAINING THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
THAT NEEDS TO BE AT THE MINUTE
IMPLEMENTED IN OUR POLICE
ACADEMIES WE HAVE TO MAKE OUR
POLICE DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA LOOKED LIKE
CALIFORNIA.
LOOKED LIKE ALL OF US.
IF WE CAN GO BACK IN HISTORY THE
HISPANIC COMMUNITY GO BACK IN
HISTORY IN THE FORTIES WHEN THE
JUKE SHOOTERS WERE BEATEN -- IN
THE STREETS OF LOS ANGELES THAT
HAPPENED.
WITH AND THAT WAS AGAINST THE
MILITARY FOR GOD SAKES BUT
BECAUSE THE THE JEW TUTORS WERE
ENJOYING THEIR MUSIC THEIR CARS
AND THEY WANDERED OFF EAST LA IN.
AND INTO DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES
THE MILITARY WERE WERE CALLED IN
TO BE EATEN AT THAT THE RIOTS
HAPPENED.
SO THERE'S HISTORY ON ON EVERY
SIDE IF WE LOOK FOR IT.
BUT I THINK THE HISTORY IS IS A
IS WITH US RIGHT NOW.
THE THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT HAS IT AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN WHO NUMBER.
TWO IN THAT ORGANIZATION NUMBER.
TWO HOW MANY GENERATIONS UPON
GENERATIONS HAS IT TAKEN.
AND THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
ARE COUNTY SHERIFF NUMBER
[inaudible]
ONE HISPANIC AMERICAN.
WE ARE MAKING INROADS IN
EDUCATION WE'RE MAKING INROADS
EVERYWHERE WE GO BECAUSE I THINK
WE ALL REALIZE NOW THAT WE ARE.
ALL.
ONE IN WE TALK ABOUT.
THE WOMEN IN THE MILITARY WE
TALK ABOUT WOMEN IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE TALK ABOUT.
WOMEN IN THE QUALITY AND PAY AND
SO ONE BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
REMEMBER IT STARTS WITH JOBS AND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE SO MUCH
TO DO.
SO IT'S NOT CHEST WHAT'S
HAPPENING RACIAL WISE IT HAS TO
DO WITH.
WHAT WE'RE PROVIDING THE
COMMUNITIES IN THAT'S NUMBER ONE
I BELIEVE IS JOB MEALS EDUCATION
THE HOMELESS SO MANY THINGS?
BUT IN THIS LAW ENFORCEMENT BILL
WHAT I'M PROUD OF IS WE'VE COME
TOGETHER WE'RE ALLOWING.
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO WANT TO GO
INTO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE PART OF THE BEST.
THE BEST TRAINED AND BEST
ORGANIZED THAT WILL EVER HAVE
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF WHAT WE'VE DONE.
WITH THIS BILL.
SO I KNOWLEDGE WHAT WE'RE GOING
WE'VE GOT A LONG WAYS TO GO.
BUT I KNOW WERE UNDERWAY
EQUALITY FAIRNESS ACROSS THE
BOARD SHOULD BE WHAT WE'RE AFTER
AND I THINK THIS BILL SET IT
FORTH SO I THANK YOU ALL. FOR
GOING FORWARD WITH THIS TO OPEN
UP THE DOORS TO ADDITIONAL
TRAINING AND AND COMING TOGETHER.
EVERY LIFE DOES MATTER AND I
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER PAN THE
FLOOR IS YOURS GOOD EVENING
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
CENTERS I TO STAND IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND FOLKS WHO WORK
TOGETHER -- TO TO COME TO
AGREEMENT AROUND THIS BILL --
YOU KNOW STEFAN CLARK DIED IN MY
DISTRICT.
AND THERE'S A TERRIBLE TRAGEDY.
AND I THINK THAT -- AND
FORTUNATELY -- YOU KNOW HIS
STAFF IS FORTUNATELY NOT A
SINGULAR EVENT.
AND THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS SO
IMPORTANT -- BECAUSE WE HAVE
[inaudible]
A DISPARITIES.
AND I THINK OF MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM GUARDINO SPOKE.
TO THAT -- THE FEAR THAT'S OUT
IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND SO THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP FORWARD.
AND I'M GLAD WE WERE ABLE TO
COME TOGETHER -- AROUND THIS
BILL.
HOWEVER WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO.
THIS BILL WILL CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR TRAINING AND
EDUCATION.
HOPEFULLY -- WILL ALSO CHANGE --
ATTITUDES AND PERCEPTIONS
BECAUSE THOSE ARE IMPORTANT
[inaudible]
BUT WELL WE CAN TRY TO EDUCATE
AND IMPROVE OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT --
TRAINING -- WE STILL HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE UNDERLYING CULTURE.
AND UNDERLYING CULTURED AND
UNFORTUNATELY HAS RESULTED IN --
PARTICULARLY BLACK MEN DYING
DISPROPORTIONATELY.
AT THE HANDS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND SO WELL CERTAINLY I THINK
THAT THIS ON HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND I AM
HOPEFUL THAT THIS BILL WILL
CHANGE.
THAT.
NOT TO DISTINCT CHANGE THAT
CURVE -- I WOULD ALSO AY IS IS
THAT A WORK IS NOT DONE IF THAT
DOES NOT CHANGE.
SO CERTAINLY WE WANT TO GIVE
THIS BILL AND I APPRECIATE ALL
THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE AND I
KNOW THAT THE FOLKS FROM WHAT
THE PEOPLE FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHO -- CAME TO AGREEMENT.
WHAT SEE A CHANGE -- TO BUT WE
DO NEED TO CHANGE [inaudible]
THOSE NOT JUST NUMBERS ALISON
NUMBERS WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE
SITUATION PEOPLE'S LIVES.
SO I AM PROUD TO STAND SUPPORT
THIS BILL TO VOTE FOR THIS BILL
BUT I ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT --
THIS BILL.
UNLESS IT'S TRULY EMBRACE AND
PEOPLE RECOGNIZE IF THEY HAVE TO
DO MORE THAN JUST WHAT THIS BILL
CALLS.
FOR PEOPLE HAVE TO DO MORE THAN
JUST WHAT THIS BILL CALLS.
FOR AND SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
CHANGE THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
UNDER WHICH PEOPLE [inaudible]
LIVE.
WE ALSO NEED TO CHANGE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH LAW
ENFORCEMENT FEELS LIKE THAT
THEY'RE OPERATING IN TERMS OF
THEIR OWN PERCEPTION THEIR OWN
SAFETY.
AND SO THAT WE CAN -- TRULY.
ELIMINATE THE DISPARITY THAT WE
SEE AND THE FEAR AND JUSTIFIABLE
FEAR IN MY MIND THAT WE SEE.
N. R. -- THE TYPICALLY ARE BLACK
COMMUNITY BUT ALSO SOME OF OTHER
COMMITTEES AS WELL -- SO I HAD
URGED A SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SENATOR MEMBERS
BREAD TURN THE FLOOR OVER.
CENTER COPIER.
GOOD EVENING.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT -- BUT MY
COLLEAGUE AYE I WANNA --
PUBLICLY THANK HER FOR THE HARD
WORK THAT SHE SHE DID AND FOR
HER -- HER COMMUNICATION WITH ME
AS WE WE WORKED ON BOTH OF OUR
BILLS -- A DOCTOR WEBER -- I
THINK DID A YEOMAN'S JOB ON THIS
ON THIS BILL AND SHE TOOK THE
THE PAIN AND THE ANGUISH OF OF
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
WORKED TREMENDOUSLY HARD TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT SHE COULD TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE BILL WOULD
WORK -- AND THAT -- WE COULD.
WE COULD GO TO THE COMMUNITY AND
TELL THEM LOOK THINGS ARE GOING
TO BE DIFFERENT AND HERE'S THE
REASON THAT THINGS ARE GOING TO
BE DIFFERENT AND SO -- I WANT TO
PUBLICLY THANK HER FOR FOR HER
HARD WORK AND ALSO FOR HER --
HER COMMITMENT TO SIT DOWN AND
HAVE CONVERSATIONS SOMETIMES IT
DOESN'T ALWAYS HAPPEN -- IN THE
LEGISLATURE -- PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
NEGOTIATING AND AND WORKING
THINGS OUT AND THEN THEY THEY
DON'T REALLY WANT TO BUT DOCTOR
WEBER SINCERELY WANTED TO AND I
AND I REALLY WANT -- TO GIVE HER
KUDOS FOR THAT.
THERE'S A LOT OF PAIN IN IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND THIS IS THE FIRST STEP I
THINK SOMEONE ELSE SAID IT A
LITTLE BIT MORE ELOQUENTLY THAN
I DID THAT THIS IS THE FIRST
STEP IN TRYING TO ACHIEVE --
SOME PEACE AND AND ASSURANCE
THAT WE LISTENED.
THAT -- SOME CHANGES ARE GOING
TO HAPPEN AND THAT.
UP PART OF THE PROCESS IS THAT --
THAT WILL HAVE NEW RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR FOR POLICE
OFFICERS -- THAT WILL BE PART OF
THE POST TRAINING PROGRAM.
AND THAT THE POST THAT WE'RE
GOING TO INVEST MONEY IN POST
TRAINING SO THAT.
OFFICERS CAN CAN GET THE
TRAINING THAT THEY NEED IN IN
PLACE IN AN EXPLICIT BIAS AND
UNDERSTAND -- WASTED DE ESCALATE
AND TO BE ABLE -- TO KEEP
THEMSELVES SAFE AS WELL AS KEEP
THE COMMUNITY SAFE AND AND TO DO
IT IN A WAY THAT SHOWS THAT A
TROUPE.
SHE XIN OF OF HOW THINGS HAVE TO
CHANGE SO I SAY THAT BECAUSE
THAT PART OF THE BILL THAT PART
OF THE OF THE WORK IS IN.
SB.
TWO THIRTY WHICH IS THE BILL
THAT I AUTHORED IT'S OVER IN THE
ASSEMBLY IT CURRENTLY IS BEING
HELD IN THE SEND ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS.
AND SO WE IT NEEDS TO MOVE SO
THAT IT CAN IT CAN BE -- IT CAN
REALLY I THINK IT'S THE
COMPANION.
TO THREE NINETY TWO AND AND A
LOT OF HARD WORK WENT INTO THAT
SO I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I
ATE I SHOW TO APPRECIATION TO
LEADERSHIP AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE -- FOR FOR THEIR
DEDICATION AND AN INSISTENCE
THAT WE GET THIS RIGHT AND SO
THIS REALLY IS THE FIRST STEP
AND AND I AND I I THINK THERE'S
THERE'S A LOT MORE A MORE TO BE
DONE A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE.
BUT I THINK THAT -- THAT WERE
ALL INTERESTED IN THE SAFETY OF
OUR COMMUNITY.
WHETHER IT'S THE BILL -- LAY
PERSON ON THE STREET OR WHETHER
THAT'S THE OFFICER THAT THAT
PUTS ON THE BADGE AND AND SWEARS
TO PROTECT AND SERVE AND SO -- I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
THANK YOU SIR [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WHEN IS A GOOD EVENING TO THE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM [inaudible]
CENTER ACT.
MISTER PRESIDENT.
I WANT TO START BY THANKING MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
PRESENTING THE BILL ON THE FLOOR
TODAY -- YOU KNOW LAST SESSION I
I MADE A COMMITMENT. TO A
COLLEAGUE AND A FRIEND.
THAT THIS LEGISLATION WOULD MAKE
IT TO THIS FLOOR.
AND WE KNEW THAT IT WOULD TAKE A
LOT OF WORK BECAUSE WE WEREN'T
THERE LAST YEAR WE DIDN'T WE
HADN'T HAD THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE OBVIOUSLY NEEDED TO HAVE.
BUT WE'VE HAD THOSE
CONVERSATIONS NOW IT'S TAKEN A
LONG HERE.
OF COMMITMENT BY A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN PARTICULAR -- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO'S ON THE
FLOOR IN THE BACK TODAY
[inaudible]
AND YOU KNOW WE WANTED TO DO IT
IN A WAY THAT ACTUALLY FURTHER
TO DIALOGUE IN THE DISCUSSION.
ANY TIME YOU FORCE LEGISLATION I
IN A WAY THAT -- PEOPLE.
BOTH SIDES AREN'T HEARD.
IT'S NOT A RECIPE FOR A WAY TO
MOVE FORWARD OR SUCCESS.
AND WE HOPE THAT THIS WILL BE.
I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT
WE'RE DOING TODAY WITH AB.
THREE NINETY TWO IT'S A HUGE
STEP FORWARD.
THE FALL OUT OF NOT.
ADDRESSING ISSUES LIKE THIS HAS
BEEN SEEN ALL ACROSS OUR COUNTRY.
EXAMPLE AFTER EXAMPLE.
AND WE WANTED TO DO THIS IN A
WAY.
THAT RECOGNIZE THE NEEDS OF
PUBLIC SAFETY AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT BUT WE WANTED TO
REALLY ADDRESS AN ISSUE THAT
OBVIOUSLY.
IS QUITE A SWORE IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
AS WE TRY -- TO TO FIND WAYS TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC SAFETY AND AT THE
SAME TIME RESPECT THE RIGHTS OF
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO ARE MARGINALIZED WHO ARE
OVERLOOKED TO FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
NOT HEARD?
I WANT TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
PICO RIVERA WHO TALKED ABOUT.
THIS BEING CRITICAL STEP BUT
THERE ARE SO MANY OTHER THINGS
THAT COME ALONG WITH HEALING A
COMMUNITY -- THAT HAS FELT THE
PAIN -- AND THAT IS ECONOMIC
JUSTICE.
AND EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY AND
ALL OF THOSE THINGS WE TALK
ABOUT EVERY DAY.
SO THAT EVERYONE FEELS ACCESS.
BUT SINCE LAST YEAR.
I WOULD SAY THAT WE'VE SPENT
COUNTLESS HOURS.
A AFTER SESSION ENDED BRINGING
DIFFERENT GROUPS TOGETHER SO
THAT WE CAN BEGIN THOSE
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS NEEDED
TO ARRIVE WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
WE KNEW THAT CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT USE OF FORCE STANDARD
WITH OUTDATED AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
DOING NOTHING WAS NOT AN OPTION
BUT PLEADING FOR A LITTLE MORE
TIME TO TRY TO BRING SOMETHING
FORWARD THAT WE ALL COULD FEEL --
PRETTY GOOD ABOUT WAS ALSO
NECESSARY [inaudible]
THE BILL.
BEFORE YOU TODAY BY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO MAKES
CALIFORNIA'S USE OF FOR STANDARD
A MODEL.
A MODEL FOR THE REST OF THE
NATION.
THAT'S WHAT THAT WORK.
MAY PUT BEFORE THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY TO LOOK AT WHAT WE'VE
DONE HERE.
AND HOPEFULLY TAKE THAT DIALOGUE
FORWARD AND FIND WAYS IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT PEOPLE CAN WORK
TOGETHER.
SOON HOPEFULLY VERY SOON WE WILL
SEE THE COMPANION.
BILL SB TWO THIRTY AUTHORED BY
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SALINAS
REFERENCED ALREADY ON THE FLOOR.
THAT WILL ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
THE TRAINING -- THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE REFORM AFFECTED IF WE IF WE
DON'T PUT THE RESOURCES THERE.
TO HELP LAW ENFORCEMENT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- THAT'S A
PART OF THE EQUATION.
I WANT TO COMMEND EVERYONE
INVOLVED THE FAMILIES OF VICTIMS.
THAT WERE ABLE.
TO TALK TO A STEP FORWARD AND
SHARE WITH US THEIR STORIES LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
WHO SHARE THEIR STORIES?
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
THEIR COMMITMENT TO THIS. FOR
THIS WORK FOR NOT WALKING AWAY
FROM THE DISCUSSION.
EVEN WHEN THOSE DISCUSSIONS WERE
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT AND THEY
WERE.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE -- OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY CHAIR AND THE
ENTIRE COMMITTEE BECAUSE THAT
WAS NOT AN EASY CONVERSATION
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY WE'VE HAD
TO ADDRESS PEOPLE'S FEELINGS.
AND THE LANDS FOR WHICH THEY PUT
THINGS THROUGH FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO THE VICTIMS AND I
I'VE FAMILIES OF VICTIMS.
WHO CAME FORWARD TO SPEAK AND I
HAVE TO SAY IT WAS NOT A SIMPLE
THING TO WEAVE TOGETHER? TO FIND
A WAY TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
AND KEEP THE PARTIES.
COMING TOGETHER TO WORK TOWARDS
SOMETHING THAT WE COULD AGREE
UPON.
AND YOU DID THAT.
SO I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE YOU IN
YOUR ENTIRE COMMITTEE -- MY
COLLEAGUE OVER HERE TO THE LEFT
ALSO SERVED ON THAT COMMITTEE IS
HE SAID -- AND LASTLY I JUST
WANT TO THANK MY A FRIEND OF MY
DEAR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO.
WHO TOOK A RISK AND BELIEVE TO
ME WHEN I SAID LET'S GIVE IT A
LITTLE MORE TIME I DON'T KNOW?
IF WILL BE SUCCESSFUL.
BUT I THINK WE MUST WORK AT IT
TOGETHER.
AND SHE TOOK THAT SHE TOOK THAT.
STEP AND SHE BELIEVE THAT WE
COULD GET IT DONE BUT IT WAS HER
WORK.
AND HER TENACITY AND HER PASSION
AND HER COMMITMENT TO HER
COMMUNITY -- THAT'S ENABLED US
TO BE HERE TODAY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO COMPLETING.
ALL OF THE WORK WE NEED TO DO ON
THIS.
THAT WE DO PROVIDE THE RESOURCES
AND TOGETHER I THINK WE REALLY
WILL FEEL PROUD AT THE END OF
THE DAY.
WHEN WE MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN OUR
COUNTRY?
AND WE BRING THIS MODEL FOR WORK
I ASK AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
HEARING SEEN NO OTHER DEBATE.
SENATOR MITCHELL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
MISTER PRESIDENT I WOULD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
YOU KNOW COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
MATTERS.
AND TO SUGGEST OTHERWISE IS A
BLATANT DENIAL OF THE OBVIOUS.
YOU KNOW WE ALL HAVE WORK TO DO.
TO CHANGE OUR PERSONAL IN. TO
NOT BE HERE A YOUNG MAN WALKING
DOWN THE STREET SIMPLY BECAUSE
HE HAS IS HOOKED UP ON HIS HAND
OVER HIS HOODIE. TO NOT FEAR A
YOUNG MAN PERHAPS WITH A SHAVED
HEAD WITH TATTOOS ON HIS NECK.
WALKING DOWN THE STREET. TO NOT
PASS INSTANT JUDGMENT BASED ON
NO ACTION OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
BUT MERELY BASED ON OUR
HISTORICAL ATTITUDES AND
PERCEPTIONS ABOUT WHAT PEOPLE
WHO LOOK LIKE THEM DO AND
MEETING.
ALL OF US IN THIS COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW WITH IN MY LIFETIME MY
LIFETIME MY OWN POLICE
DEPARTMENT LAPD.
WENT FROM HAVING NO AFRICAN
AMERICAN OFFICERS WITHIN ITS
RANKS.
UP UNTIL THE WATTS UPRISING OF
SIXTY FIVE TO HAVING BLACK CHIEF.
FLORAL. TO HAVE AN OVERSIGHT
COMMISSION THAT SELF FUNDED
THEIR OWN IMPLICIT BIAS.
TRAINING.
SO CLEARLY WE HAVE COME A LONG
WAY.
BUT IT'S ALL OF US ON THIS FLOOR
IF WE CHOOSE TO BE HONEST WITH
OURSELVES MUST ACKNOWLEDGE WE
HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO
[inaudible]
RACE MATTERS.
I'D LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY FOR HIS
DEEPLY PERSONAL SENTIMENT.
AND I APPRECIATE HIS OBVIOUS
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT THE NEED FOR
BALANCE.
BALANCE TO CREATE TRUE PUBLIC
SAFETY FOR ALL.
AND TO THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO
CONTINUE TO DEBATE LANGUAGE
THAT'S NO LONGER IN THIS BILL I
SAY THIS.
I TOO AM A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I SUPPORT A LAW ENFORCEMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT REFLECTS THE
DIVERSITY OF THE COMMUNITIES
THEY ARE CHARGED TO SERVE.
AND I DEEPLY RESENT ANY
ASSERTION OTHERWISE.
IT'S OBVIOUS TO SO MANY THAT THE
CURRENT.
REASONABLE STANDARD OF USING
FORCE AND SPECIFICALLY DEADLY
FORCE SET FORTH IN CALIFORNIA
LAW AND THE CONSTITUTION DOES
NOT PROTECT PEOPLE'S FUNDAMENTAL
HUMAN RIGHTS.
DAN FOR FAR TOO MANY.
THOSE INSTANCES DON'T APPEAR TO
BE JUST.
BECAUSE CLEARLY JEFF THIS IS NOT
BLIND.
AND THAT'S WHY MANY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES HAVE
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO HOLD
THEMSELVES TO A HIGHER STANDARD.
UPDATING THEIR USE OF FORCE
POLICIES TO ADOPT BEST PRACTICES
LIKE REQUIRING DE ESCALATION
WHEN FEASIBLE.
USING FORCE THAT IS PROPORTIONAL
TO THE LAWN FORSMAN OBJECTIVE.
AND GROUNDING THEIR POLICIES IN
THE SANCTITY OF HUMAN LIFE OF
ALL HUMAN LIFE.
BY AUTHORIZING PEACE OFFICERS TO
USE DEADLY FORCE ONLY WHEN
NECESSARY TO DEFEND AGAINST AN
IMMINENT THREAT OF DEATH OR
SERIOUS BODILY INJURY.
AND CONSIDERING THE ACTIONS OF
OFFICES LEADING UP TO USE THE
FORCE.
AB THREE NINETY TWO WOULD BRING
CALIFORNIA UP. TO THAT HIGHER
STANDARD.
AB THREE NINETY TWO IS THE
NECESSARY STEP. TO AFFIRMING THE
SANCTITY OF HUMAN LIFE AND
PROTECTING HUMAN RIGHTS.
FAR TOO MANY DAYS HAVE GONE BY
WITH FAR TOO MANY DEATHS BECAUSE
OF THE INACTION OF THOSE WHO
HAVE THE POWER TO ENACT CHANGE.
WE HAVE THE POWER TO CHANGE THAT
TODAY.
THE NEED FOR REFORM IS CLEAR AND
LONG OVERDUE.
THE NATION IS WATCHING.
OUR CHILDREN ARE WATCHING.
BECAUSE WE ARE LIVING IN A
TINDER BOX OF RACIALLY MOTIVATED
TENSION IN OUR COUNTRY.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS THIS HAS
TO WORK.
IT'S TIME FOR US TO ENACT A
STATE WIDE POLICY.
THAT WILL THAT WILL WITHOUT
QUESTION.
FAITH HUMAN LIFE. FOR THOSE
REASONS I ASK THAT YOU VOTE
FAVORABLY. FOR A. B..
THREE NINETY TWO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
WELL.
I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CAN [inaudible]
I DALY [inaudible]
I DODD.
I TO WRESTLE [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
HUESO -- TADA [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I BROWN [inaudible] FIVE NIELSEN
[inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I LIKE OWSKI.
WIENER.
AYE WILK [inaudible]
I HUESO I SENATOR MITCHELL MOVES
THE CALL.
MEMBERS WE'RE NOW GOING TO TAKE
UP TO ITEMS UNDER UNFINISHED
BUSINESS.
ITEM.
TWENTY FIVE IN ITEM.
TWENTY SIX CENTER WINTERS
PREPARED TO PRESENT.
BETTER SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY THREE BY
SENATOR WIENER AND AFTER LEADING
THE CRIME.
CENTER WE ARE THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
I THANK REGISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES -- THIS ITEM IS -- AS
TO TWO THIRTY THREE RETURNS TO
US ON CONCURRENCE AFTER PASSING
THE ASSEMBLY -- THE BILL IS
LARGELY SIMILAR -- TO WHEN IT
WAS HOT PASSED PREVIOUSLY -- BY
THIS BODY -- WITH SOME --
TECHNICAL AND TIGHTENING
AMENDMENTS SB -- TWO THIRTY
THREE IS DESIGNED TO PROMOTE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF SEX WORKERS --
BY ENSURING THAT SEX WORKERS ARE --
FEEL CONFIDENT BEING ABLE TO
COME FORWARD TO REPORT VIOLENT
CRIMES.
WITHOUT FEAR OF BEING ARRESTED
FOR SEX WORK.
HI SO THE BILL PROVIDES THAT IF
A SEX WORKER IS REPORTING A
VIOLENT CRIME -- THEYCOULD NOT-BE ARRESTED FOR SEX WORK RELATED
OFFENSES.
IN ADDITION -- TOO MANY SEX
WORKERS FEAR CARRYING CONDOMS
BECAUSE DO WE STILL HAVE POLICE
DEPARTMENTS THAT WERE USE
CONDOMS AS EVIDENCE OF SEX WORK.
WHICH CREATES A DISINCENTIVE TO
CARRY CONDOMS AND PROTECT US SEX
WORKERS SEXUAL HEALTH -- AS A
RESULT THE BILL PROVIDES A SEX
WORK IS NOT EVIDENCE -- THIS
PARTICULAR CONDOMS ARE NOT
EVIDENCE OF SEX WORK --
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
BELL. FIVE FOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DALLY [inaudible]
NO DON.
I TO WRESTLE [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER. FIVE AND SALAS
[inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I WAS SO.
I TADO [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO HAN [inaudible] FIVE
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROB [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I WAKE OWSKI. FIVE WIENER
[inaudible]
HI WELL [inaudible]
HI.
THEN REMOVES THE CALL MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
SIX SENATOR DODD MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES SENATOR
DODD BETTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB
ONE SEVENTY THREE IS BACK ON
CURRENTS.
THIS BILL WILL HELP INCREASE
AWARE AWARENESS AND UTILIZATION
OF CALIFORNIA I STUDENTS
PARTICIPATING THE WORK STUDY.
THROUGH MORE UNIFORM ELIGIBILITY
TURMAN.
DETERMINATION PROCESS
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS INCLUDING THE
DEADLINE BY WHICH THE DEPARTMENT
MUST CREATE THE STANDARDIZED
ELIGIBILITY DOCUMENT REQUIRED BY
THE BILL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
I FORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DOLLY [inaudible]
I DON.
I TO RUSSELL [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON.
JONES.
I LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I MORALE [inaudible] FIVE
NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I NUMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
FORTY SENATOR HILL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN NINETY
VICE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STONE
AND ACTUALLY NEW DIVERSION.
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AB THIRTEEN NINETY
MAKES A MINOR EXPANSION TO THE
TRANSITIONAL AGE.
YOUTH PILOT PROGRAM THAT WAS
APPROVED IN CHAPTER IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THIS MEASURE WILL ALLOW
PILOT COUNTIES TO INCLUDE
DEFENDANTS.
THAT ARE OLDER THAN TWENTY ONE
YEARS OLD BUT TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
OUR OR UNDER ON THE DATE THE
OFFENSE WAS COMMITTED THE
EXISTING PROGRAM ALLOWS ALAMEDA
BUTTE NAPA NEVADA.
SEND A CLEAR OR VENTURA COUNTIES
TO CREATE A DEFERRED ENTRY OF
JUDGMENT PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS
YOUTH AGED BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY ONE YEARS. TO BE
VOLUNTARILY HOUSED IN A JUVENILE
DETENTION FILL FACILITY RATHER
THAN A COUNTY JAIL THIS PROGRAM
RECOGNIZES THAT ALTHOUGH THESE
YOUTH ARE LEGALLY ADULTS.
SCIENCE DEMONSTRATES THAT THOSE
WOULD BETWEEN EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE ARE
STILL UNDERGOING SIGNIFICANT
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT.
AB THIRTEEN NINETY EXPANDS THE
PROGRAM TO AGE TWENTY FIVE
BRINGING THE PROGRAM MORE IN
LINE WITH THE MOST RECENT BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT STUDIES THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THE TRANSITIONAL
YOUTH.
HAVE THE BEST OPPORTUNITY TO
RECEIVE AGE APPROPRIATE CARE THE
MEASURE HAS NO OPPOSITION HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU SENATOR HILL MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I WELL [inaudible]
I FORGES.
BRADFORD.
I HAVE A A CHIANG [inaudible]
DOLLY [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
HI WITH SO.
I TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROB [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible] FIVE SKINNER
[inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WELL [inaudible]
HI.
SENATOR MOVES THE CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM FORTY EXCUSE ME FIFTY SEVEN
SENATOR HUESO.
FILE ITEM.
FIFTY SEVEN AB.
TEN NINETY FIVE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN NINETY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND ACTUALLY TO HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS SENATOR HUESO THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO PRESENT AB TEN NINETY
FIVE THIS BILL SO TECHNICAL
CLEAN UP TO AB TWENTY FOUR
FOURTEEN CHAPTER.
TO IN TWENTY SIXTEEN IT'S A
DISTRICT BILL WHICH ALLOW THE
EXPANSION OF A OF THE DESERT
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT TO INCLUDE
THE EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY
REGION.
AND REQUIRED THE ADDITION OF TWO
NEW BOARD MEMBERS TO THE
DISTRICT'S GOVERNING GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE.
TRIP TO REPRESENT THE NEWLY
ANNEXED TERRITORY.
AB TWENTY FOUR FOURTEEN
DESIGNATED THAT ALL.
THAT THAT THE BOARD SHALL
APPOINT ONE APPOINTEE FOR
INITIAL TERM.
OF OFFICE OF TWO YEARS AND THE
REMAINING.
EASTERN COACHELLA AVAILABLE AT
MEMBER FOR TERM OF FOUR YEARS
THIS WOULD SIMPLE BOOK SIMPLY
MAKE SOME.
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD --
NUMBER ONE BUT NOT ALLOW OF THE
TEMPORARY APPOINTMENT TO RUN FOR
REELECTION.
BUDGET JUST TO FILL THE END OF
THAT -- SHORT SHORT IN TERMS.
AND IT ALSO.
OF ALSO A SEEKS TO RECTIFY --
THAT SPECIFIC PROVISION TO ALLOW
THOSE APPOINTEES ABILITY SEEK
ELECTION FOLLOWING FOLLOWING THE
TERM OF THEIR INITIAL
APPOINTMENT THIS BILL RECEIVE NO
NO VOTES.
AND HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AREAS RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY THANK
YOU SENATOR HUESO MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible] FIVE DOLLY
[inaudible]
I DON.
I TO RESUME [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL [inaudible]
HI HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
HI I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
CENTER DORADO.
THIRD RAZA REJECTED TAKE UP FILE
ITEM SIXTY THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO AN ACT
RELATING TO BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT.
CENTER DRAWS SO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND AND MEMBERS AB THREE
FIFTY SIX WOULD AUTHORIZE A
PILOT PROGRAM.
UNTIL DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR BUT THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT. TO
USE THE BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT
METHOD FOR CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
EXCEEDING ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY
APPROVED THE BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT METHOD FOR THE UC
AND LA U. S. D. AND HAS PROVEN
TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
IN REDUCING OVERALL COSTS AND
CONSTRUCTION DELAYS.
THAT LOS ANGELES COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY HAS ALSO HAD
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS UTILIZING A
BEST VALUE FRAMEWORK FOR A FEW
YEARS.
COUPLED WITH INNOVATIVE GOOD
JOBS POLICIES SUCH AS THE U. S.
EMPLOYMENT PLANNING CONSTRUCTION
CAREERS.
IN TURN METRO HAS CREATED
THOUSANDS OF LIVING WAGE JOBS IN
CONSTRUCTION AND RAIL CAR
MANUFACTURING WITH HIRING
PIPELINES FOR WOMEN.
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS VETERANS AND OTHER
GROUPS FACING SYSTEMIC.
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT.
TAXPAYERS AND THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT STAND TO BENEFIT
GREATLY FROM MY BEST VALUE
PROCUREMENT METHOD I WOULD LIKE
TO ADD AS A SIDE NOTE.
THAT I ALSO BELIEVE IT'S
CRITICAL TO PAIR THIS METHOD
WITH TRANSPARENCY AND MEASURES
DISTRICTS STRENGTH IN CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC RECORDS LAWS.
TOGETHER WE CREATE A RACE TO THE
TOP AMONG CONTRACTORS TO LIVE
DELIVER THE BEST PRODUCT AND
BROUGHT ITS BENEFITS TO THE
PUBLIC I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
AB THREE FIFTY SIX PROPOSED
PROPOSES A PILOT PROJECT. FOR
CONSTRUCTION FOR LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT.
THE JUNE THIRTY TWENTY SEVENTEEN
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
REPORT FOR THIS DISTRICT.
SHOW THAT THE DISTRICT HAD A NET.
UNRESTRICTED DEFICIT OF FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
THE NEXT YEAR THE REPORT FOR
JUNE THIRTY TWENTY EIGHTEEN SHOW
THAT THE UNRESTRICTED NET
DEFICIT HAD GROWN TO ONE BILLION
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
THIS IS A FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWO MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE IN
AN ALREADY.
LARGE DEFICIT AND IT PLACE THEM
WHEN THEY WERE IN SEVENTH PLACE
PER CAPITA OR SEVENTEEN NOW
THEY'RE DOWN TO THIRTY SECONDS
SO.
L. A. C. C. D. CERTAINLY NEEDS
SOME ASSISTANCE READ.
BECAUSE OF THIS MASSIVE
HEMORRHAGING BUT I'M NOT SURE
THE BEST VALUE PROCUREMENT
METHOD AND ITS PARTIALITY TO
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS WILL
SOLVE THIS FISCAL ISSUE GOING
FORWARD. FOR BETTER BIDS I WOULD
RECOMMEND DROPPING THE PL A
PROVISION BECAUSE AB THREE FIFTY
SIX DOESN'T APPEAR TO STOP THE
DIGGING I AM OPPOSED THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
DRAWS SO YOU MAY CLOSE I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A BI I VOTE
FOR GOOD JOBS.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN WE ARE GOING AYE ARCHULETA
[inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible] FIVE BATES.
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD.
I HAVE A ADAM [inaudible]
HI CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DOLLY [inaudible]
DODD.
I THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO. FIVE TADO.
BY JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I MORE LOG [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO HAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI.
I WIENER [inaudible]
HI WELL [inaudible]
HI.
SENATOR DORADO MOVES TO CALL
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
SENATOR DODD.
A META PRESIDENT IN MEMBERS I
MOVE TO SUSPEND THE SENATE RULES
FOR AB TEN FIFTY FOUR IN ORDER
THIS BILL. TO THIRD READING.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
[inaudible]
SENATOR.
THERE IS OBJECTION.
ALRIGHT WE WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL
ON THIS SENATOR DODD IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND THE SENATOR GROWTH IS ASKING
FOR NO VOTE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALAN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES.
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DOLLY [inaudible]
NO DODD.
I THERE ARE SO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI HELLO [inaudible]
HI HUESO.
I TADO [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE.
AYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE KING.
HI WIENER.
AYE WILK [inaudible]
NO.
VICE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TEN THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE READ THE COMMITTEE REPORT.
WE ARE IN SUPPLEMENTAL FILE
NUMBER.
ONE MADAM PRESIDENT THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS TO
WHICH WAS REFERRED ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN FIFTY FOUR REPORTS THE SAME
BACK WITH A RECOMMENDATION DO
PASS.
BILL ORDERED TO THIRD READING.
THANK YOU AND IF YOU WOULD NOW
READ THE BILL SENATOR DODD IS
PRESENTING.
THIS IS SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER.
ONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN AND
ACTUALLY IN THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION THEIR
FOREIGN DECLARING THE URGENCY
THERE OF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
SENATOR DODD THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS WE'VE
ALL LEARNED HARD LESSONS OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS WITH
UNPRECEDENTED WILDFIRES%
DEVASTATING OUR STATE.
CLAIMING LIVES DESTROYING TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF HOMES AND
BURNING MILLIONS OF ACRES.
IT'S CLEAR WE MUST RAPIDLY ADAPT
TO RESPOND TO THE EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND OTHER CAUSES
DRIVING THESE MONSTER INFERNOS.
TOO OFTEN ELECTRIC UTILITIES ARE
BLAMED. FOR THESE DEVASTATIONS
AS A STATE WE MUST HAVE SMART
POLICIES TO KEEP US SAFE AND
PREVENT RATEPAYERS FROM GETTING
HIT WITH A TREMENDOUS COSTS OF
THESE WILDFIRES.
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR HAS BEEN A
TICKET TEAM EFFORT WITH THE
AUTHORS AND GOOD CENTERS FROM
VAN NUYS IN SAN DIEGO.
ALONG WITH OUR LEADERSHIP.
GOVERNOR NUISANCE TEAM DESERVES
A LOT OF CREDIT FOR CAUGHT THE
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH TO
DEVELOPING THIS BILL AND TAFFY
ONE OF THE GREATEST THREATS.
OUR STATE SPACES.
BUT NO PLAN IS PERFECT.
BUT NEITHER IS WILDLIFE'S SICH
WILDFIRE SITUATION WE FACE AS
CALIFORNIANS.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS DRIVING MORE
DESTRUCTIVE FIRES THAN EVER AT A
TIME WHEN THE STATE'S LARGEST
UTILITY P. GENIE IS
UNFORTUNATELY DUCT ITS
RESPONSIBILITIES.
UNDER STATE LAW.
THIS BILL REPRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF THE SOLUTION.
IT WILL HELP COMPENSATE PASSED
IT PRESENT VICTIMS.
PREVENT FUTURE DISASTERS FOR
PROTECTING IT PROTECT UTILITY
RATE PAYERS FROM SUBSTANTIAL
RATE INCREASES.
CLEARLY IT'S A LIFELINE FOR
UTILITY CUSTOMERS.
MAKE NO MISTAKE THIS IS NOT A
UTILITY BAIL OUT.
IT'S ALREADY PAYER BILL OUT.
IT REQUIRES P. GENIE IN THE
STATE'S OTHER TO BIG UTILITIES
TO PONY UP FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
TO INVEST IN SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS
UTILITIES WILL NOT BE ALLOWED.
TO MAKE A SAID A PROFIT FROM
THOSE EXPENSES.
THE PLAN ALSO CREATES A
LIABILITY FUND TO HELP SHIELD
CUSTOMERS FOR THE COST OF FUTURE
WILDFIRES.
INCLUDING THE COST OF CAPITAL
BECOME WITHOUT RISK.
IN THE LARGE I USE WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO CONTRIBUTE TEN POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS TO THAT
FUND.
IT ALSO MANDATES A STRICT ONE
YOUR TIME LINE FOR P. JEANNIE TO
EMERGE FROM CHAPTER ELEVEN
INSURING SETTLEMENTS ARE PAID.
TO ALL TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AT
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FIRE
VICTIMS IN THE BILL IMPROVES
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT OF
UTILITIES.
THESE KEY MANDATES INCLUDE.
REQUIRING A MORE ROBUST WILD
FIRE MITIGATION PLANTS THE
COVERS THREE YEARS.
BOLSTERING SAFETY BY INSURING
PHYSICAL COMPLIANCE AUDITS ARE
CONDUCTED.
ESTABLISHING THE CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRES SAFETY ADVISORY BOARD
IN A NEW WILDFIRE SAFETY
DIVISION WHICH WILL ULTIMATELY
BECOME A STANDALONE DEPARTMENT.
SOLELY FOCUSED ON SAFETY.
PROVIDING A CLEAR WERE RECORD
STANDARD SKEWS ME PROVIDING A
CLEAR STANDARD FOR COST
RECOVERED CUT RECOVERY THE HOLDS
BAD ACTORS RESPONSIBLE.
IT CREATES NEW PENALTIES FOR
VIOLATION THREE TIMES GREATER
THAN EXISTING LAW.
IN MANDATED THAT THE CPUC
PROTECT THE INTEREST.
OF REPAIRS EMPLOYEES THE OF A
UTILITY CHANGES CONTROL.
THIS BILL IS THE PRODUCT OF
DELIBERATIVE IN PUBLIC PROCESS
WHICH INCLUDES REPORTS FROM THE
GOVERNOR STRIKE FORCE AND THE
WILDFIRE COMMISSION ESTABLISHED
BY MY SB.
NINE OH ONE DOING NOTHING.
IS NOT AN OPTION IF WE SIT IDLY
BY UTILITY RATES COULD DOUBLE.
UNDER THE STATUS QUO.
WE TOOK IMPORTANT STEPS LAST
YEAR INCLUDING STRENGTHENING OUR
FIRE PREVENTION AND RESPONSE
CAPABILITIES.
IN WE BUILD ON THAT FOUNDATION
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
WITH THE SIGNIFICANT NEW
INVESTMENTS BUT THERE'S STILL
MUCH MORE TO DO.
I EXPECT THAT MANY OF THE BILLS
INTRODUCED THIS YEAR ON WILD
FIRE PREVENTION AND MITIGATION
WILL HELP FILL OUT SOLUTIONS.
PUT FORWARD IN THIS BILL.
OUR FOCUS MUST REMAIN ON
COMPENSATING VICTIMS STOPPING
NEW WILDFIRES IN PREVENTING
OUTRAGEOUS.
COSTS ON REPAIRS THERE'S NO
SILVER BULLET FOR THIS PROBLEM
BUT THE LEGISLATURE HAS A CHANCE
TO MAKE MAJOR STRIDES TOWARD
TOWARDS THOSE AIMS IT COULDN'T
COME SOON ENOUGH.
THAT'S WHAT ALLOWED WHILE I WILL
BE SUPPORTING AB TEN FIFTY FOUR
AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR HERTZBERG
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR DOLLY.
AND WE'LL GO FROM THERE CENTER
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MADAM PRESIDENT.
TODAY MADAM PRESIDENT.
IS AN IMPORTANT DAY.
IN THIS LEGISLATIVE CHAMBER.
OVER MANY YEARS WE HAVE PROUDLY
PASS [inaudible]
LANDMARK.
MEASURES THAT HAVE IMPACTED THE
HOPES AND DREAMS AND QUALITY OF
LIFE.
BUT SO MANY CALIFORNIANS.
WE'VE ENACTED MINIMUM WAGE.
WE HAVE PASSED MEASURES TO
SAFEGUARD CONSUMERS FROM
EVERYTHING FROM FRAUD TO THE
SALE OF THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED DOZENS OF
IMPACTFUL CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORMS OF EXONERATED THE
INNOCENT AND BUT FAIRNESS TO IT
OFTEN DEEPLY FAULT FLAWED
PROCESS AND JUST TODAY.
WE PASSED THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND
SOMETHING OF EXTRAORDINARY
IMPORTANCE AND OF COURSE WE HAVE
ENACTED CREATIVE AN AGGRESSIVE
CLIMATE CHANGE POLICIES
[inaudible]
BUT MEMBERS.
BUT WITH REGARD TO THE CLIMATE
CHANGE POLICIES IN MY VIEW WE
HAVE TALKED ABOUT IT IN TERMS OF
PUBLIC POLICY THAT SLOWS DOWN
THE DISTANT THREAT.
OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
BUT THIS MEASURE.
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR ADDRESSES THE
URGENCY AND IMMEDIACY OF CLIMATE
CHANGE HERE AND NOW.
OUR GREAT FORMER GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN.
CALL THIS EXTREME WEATHER IS
WE'VE ALL HEARD THE NEW ABNORMAL.
IT'S A PERIL THAT IS
EXTRAORDINARY NOT JUST BECAUSE
OF ITS REMARKABLE COMPLEXITY.
BUT BECAUSE IT TOUCHES EVERY
CORNER OF THE STATE AFFECTING
CALIFORNIANS IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES OF ALL AGES AND
POLITICAL PARTIES RIGHT NOW HERE
EVERY DAY.
EVERY YEAR.
CALIFORNIANS DEPEND ON WELL I A
BILL RELIABLE ELECTRICITY FOR
MORE THAN JUST LIGHTS.
RELY TO TO POWER HOSPITALS IN
THE NEEDED NEONATAL UNITS.
ARE MASS TRANSIT SYSTEMS IN OUR
MODERN COMMUNICATION TECHNOLOGY.
AND WHAT ECONOMIST MEMBERS TO
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES.
WHICH BY ALL ACCOUNTS IS JUST
ONE JUST ONE HARSH ELEMENT OF
THIS NEW ABNORMAL.
OUR STATE'S HISTORY BEARS NO
RESEMBLANCE. TO THE REALITY OF
TODAY.
THE RISKS OF OF ALL THE ALARMING
RATE.
YEARS OF DROUGHT CREATED A
PERFECT STORM. FOR WILDFIRES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE WHICH WAS
ARTICULATED IN GOVERNOR BROWN'S
EMERGENCY DECLARATIONS ON TREE
MORTALITY IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN THIS LED
TO SEVEN OF THE OUT OF TEN OF
THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRES
IN OUR STATE.
OCCURRING IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
WITH ALMOST FIVE MILLION ACRES
BURNED.
IN THAT TIME AND NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED CALIFORNIANS LOST THEIR
LIVES AND THOUSANDS MORE.
LOST EVERYTHING.
THIS NEW REALITY HAS RESULTED IN
STAGGERING COSTS IT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY TRANSFORM THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN EVERY DAY
CALIFORNIANS THEIR ENERGY
PROVIDERS THE ENVIRONMENT.
THAT CONNECTS THEM.
WITH REGARD TO THE IMPACT OF
WILDFIRES ON OUR SYSTEM OF
ELECTRICITY DELIVERY.
WE ARE FACED WITH A PROBLEM OF
FOUR PARTS.
MAINTAINING A SUPPLY OF SAFE AND
RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE ENERGY.
TO ENSURING THE FINANCIAL
VIABILITY OF OUR ELECTRICITY
UTILITY SYSTEMS IN A MANNER THAT
IS FAIR TO RATE PAYERS.
THREE EQUITABLY COMPENSATING
VIST VICTIMS OF THE RECENT
HORRIBLE WILD FIRES AND FOR
FORTIFYING OUR STATES
COMMUNITIES WITH THAT AT A
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT.
AGAINST FUTURE WILD FIRES.
FIGURE OUT HOW TO RECONCILE EACH
OF THESE CHALLENGES FEELS LIKE
THREADING TEN THOUSAND EAGLES
WHILE RIDING.
A UNICYCLE BACKWARD.
THAT IS WHY AT NINETY EIGHT
PAGES LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
NINETY EIGHT PAGES AND NEARLY
FORTY TWO THOUSAND WORDS THIS
MEASURE BEFORE US A. B.. TEN
FIFTY FOUR IS THE SIZE OF A
SMALL BOOK.
IT ALONG WITH SEVERAL TRAILER
BILLS DOES THE FOLLOWING.
IT IMPACTS FIVE DIFFERENT
CALIFORNIA CODES AND SIX STATE
AGENCIES IT ESTABLISHES
INTRICATE CORPORATE
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES AND
RESTRUCTURE SOPHISTICATED LEGAL
STANDARDS.
AND IT PROVIDES FOR THE CREATION
OF NEW GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES AND
TO MULTI BILLION DOLLAR FUNDING
SOURCES TO COMPENSATE VICTIMS OF
WILDFIRES PASS.
AND INTO THE FUTURE.
THIS SMALL BOOK IN FRONT OF EACH
OF US WAS ONLY POSSIBLE BECAUSE
OF A SMALL ARMY OF PUBLIC
SERVANTS.
WHO WORK LIKE CRAZY TO GET IT
DONE?
FROM THE FIRST DAY IN OFFICE
LITERALLY THE FIRST DAY IN
OFFICE I THINK CLOSE TO IT.
WHEN THE BANKRUPTCY WAS FILED TO
STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS?
TACKLING THIS EXTRAORDINARY
CHALLENGE WAS A PRIORITY FOR OUR
NEW GOVERNOR.
AND SO MANY OF US WHO WORK
CLOSELY WITH HIS CHIEF OF STAFF
AND OTHERS.
AUTUMN ON A SONG TOAST AND YOU
WAY AFTER THE WILLIAMS AND
PATTERSON AND THE TEAM FROM
O'MELVENY MYERS AND GUGGENHEIM.
TOGETHER THEY WORK THEIR HEART
OUT THEY WORK LATE NIGHTS AND
THEY WERE JUST EXHAUSTED AND YET
DEEPLYCOMMITTED TO GETTING IT
RIGHT.
OUR LEADERSHIP THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
BOTTOM PRO TEM YOU HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLE IN MAKING SURE THAT
WE DRILL DOWN ON THE SERIOUS.
COMPLEX ISSUE THANK YOU FOR GUYS
IN THE SELECT COMMITTEE AND FOR
BEING INCLUSIVE THROUGHOUT THE
CONVERSATION AS WE WORK.
WITH YOUR HARD WORKING STAFF TO
ENSURE THAT RATE PAYERS AND
VICTIMS WERE PROTECTED.
AND PUTTING IN THE TIME TO FINE
TUNE THE DETAILS THANK YOU MADAM
PRO TEM.
SENATOR DODD IN IS EXTRAORDINARY
STAFF CHIEF OF STAFF THANK YOU
GUYS YOU ARE ROCK STARS YOU HAVE
WORKED IT LIKE CRAZY SENATOR
HUESO AND CHIEF CONSULTANT MEDIA
SHE IS JUST NOTHING LET MEDIA.
BUT HE SAYS NOTHING LESS THAN
BRILLIANT AND REALLY PUT A LOT
OF HARD WORK AND OF COURSE MY
OWN STAFF.
N. THOUGH COMPLEXES IT MAY BE I
STAND HERE IN SUPPORT OF WHAT I
DEEM TO BE AN ELEGANT AND
EFFECTIVE SOLUTION.
AND THAT IS.
AB EIGHT TEN FIFTY FOUR BEFORE
US WE HAVE A MEASURE THAT
INTELLIGENTLY BALANCES THE
INTEREST OF FIRE VICTIMS RATE
PAYERS.
UTILITIES AND OUR NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT.
IT IS A MEASURE THAT STRENGTHENS
THE FOUNDATION OF OUR ENERGY
SYSTEM THAT WORKS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WERE INSURING THAT
RESILIENCE AGAINST WHATEVER
PERILS MEKONG.
AND IT STRIKES A VERY A
DIFFICULT YET CORRECT BALANCE
BETWEEN THE ISSUE OF INVERSE
CONDEMNATION ON THE ONE HAND AND
CREATING AN INSURANCE FUND AND
FINANCIAL STRUCTURE THAT AVOIDS
BANKRUPTCY. FOR INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES THAT PROVIDE ELECTRONS
275%.
OF CALIFORNIANS.
OKAY ROOSEVELT ONCE SAID.
IN A MOMENT OF DECISION IN ANY
MOMENT OF DECISION THE BEST
THING YOU CAN DO IS DO THE RIGHT
THING.
THE NEXT BEST THING YOU CAN DO.
IS DO THE WRONG THING.
AND THE WORST THING YOU CAN DO
IS DO NOTHING.
I STAND IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
FIFTY FOUR BECAUSE IN THIS
MOMENT OF DECISION IT IS THE
RIGHT AND TIMELY SOLUTION.
I STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE AT THIS CRITICAL
JUNCTURE THE COST OF DOING
NOTHING IS SIMPLY TOO HIGH.
DOING NOTHING LOOKS LIKE AT
LEAST TWELVE DOLLARS A MONTH.
IN TERMS OF INCREASES
IMMEDIATELY TOOK TO RATEPAYERS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE-THE HIGH COST OF BORROWING WE
JUST SAW HERE ON PAGE SEVENTEEN
OF THE ANALYSIS IN THE COMMITTEE
TODAY.
UP TO THIRTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS ADDITIONAL COST IN
INTEREST COSTS TO RATEPAYERS
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T GET THIS
DONE AND SOLVE THIS PROBLEM THIS
IS.
EXTRAORDINARY WE HEARD THE
TESTIMONY OF DOCTOR STEPHEN
WEISSMAN AT UC BERKELEY GOLDMAN
SCHOOL TESTIFYING TO THE SAME
THING.
IT WOULD MEAN THAT THE
INDEPENDENT.
ON THE THE I. O. U.'S WOULD NOT
HAVE THE OBLIGATION TO INVEST
MONEY FOR PREVENTION THIS
REQUIRES A SENATOR DODD
INDICATED INVESTMENT OF FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS AS AN ADMISSION
TICKET.
JUST TO GET ACCESS TO THE WILD
FIRE INSURANCE FUND SAFETY
SAFETY SAFETY IT DON'T DO
ANYTHING THE RISK IS EVEN HIGHER.
AND FAULTY PREVENTION MEASURES I
SAY MEANS MORE FIRES AND MEETS
DEADLIER FIRES.
THERE IS STILL WORK TO DO.
AS MANY MEMBERS ON THIS FLOOR
KNOWS THE REMAINS QUESTIONS
ABOUT FIRE INSURANCE POLICIES.
FOLKS WHO LIVE IN COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN REDLINED WERE
POLICY HOLDERS HAVE BEEN
CANCELED WITH NO NOTICE OR VERY
LITTLE NOTICE AND LITTLE OR NO
ABILITY CHOIR ALTERNATIVE
INSURANCE OR HOMEOWNERS
INSURANCE RATES THAT HAVE
SKYROCKETED.
WE NEED TO FURTHER ADDRESS
ENHANCE DEFENSIBLE SPACE IN TO
PROTECT PROPERTY AS WELL AS
SENSIBLE LAND USE AND ZONING
POLICIES.
MANY OF THOSE IDEAS ARE
CONTAINED IN MEASURES STILL
PENDING BEFORE US BY MEMBERS OF
THIS HOUSE.
AND BY MY ESTEEMED COLLEAGUES WE
WILL BE ADDRESSING THIS IN MY
BEST JUDGMENT AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS SESSION BUT NOT TODAY.
ALMOST TWO DECADES AGO SOME OF
US WERE SERVING IN THIS BUILDING
WHEN DEREGULATION AND MARK
MARKET MAKE MANIPULATION DROVE
CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY SECTOR TO
THE BRINK OF COLLAPSE MADAM
PRESIDENT.
AND PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE FACE
ROLLING BLACKOUTS AND SOARING
ENERGY PRICES.
AT THAT TIME P. GENIE AGAIN FOR
BEFORE THIS FILED FOR BANKRUPTCY
PROTECTION.
THE GOVERNOR DECLARED A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND THE RISK OF
PLUNGING IT'S COMMUNITIES INTO
DARKNESS THE STATE WAS FORCED TO
BUY POWER AT IT RAGES COSTS.
IN THE WINTER OF TWO THOUSAND
ONE THIS LEGISLATURE FACED WITH
SEEMINGLY LIKED AN IMPOSSIBLE
DILEMMA.
IN THAT MOMENT OF DECISION WE
WERE CALLED UPON TO BE TO BOLDLY
AND WE DID PASS AMONG OTHER
MEASURES AB ONE X. BY THEN
ASSEMBLY SPEAKER PRO TEM FRED
KAYLEE.
WHICH CONTAINS THE IN FORMS THE
FOUNDATION OF THE GW ARE BONDS
WHICH ARE AT THE CENTER OF THE
MEASURE BEFORE US TODAY.
MEMBERS MILLIONS OF ACRES OF
PRISTINE CALIFORNIA LAND NOW IS
IN ASHES.
HUNDREDS OF LIVES HAVE BEEN LOST
THE NEW ABNORMAL WE ARE FACING
TOGETHER HAS CLEAR PROSPECT TO
BRING YOUR ENERGY SYSTEM TO ITS
KNEES RIGHT NOW RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE OF THE HARD WORK AN
EXTRAORDINARY EFFORT OF SO MANY.
WE ARE WE IN THIS HOUSE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE AND WITH THIS
GOVERNOR HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
STEP UP. TO BE BOLD THE BALD
MEASURE THAT'S BEFORE US WE WILL
THROUGH THE BOARD MEASURE BEFORE
US WE WILL LEAD CALIFORNIA OUT
OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF A
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT NONE OF US
NONE OF US COULD HAVE EVER
PREDICTED.
YET THAT IS OUR JOB OUR JOB IS
TO FIGURE IT OUT FIX IT AND GET
IT RIGHT.
MEMBERS I EMPHATICALLY ASK YOU
TO JOIN ME IN ANSWERING THAT
CALL IN CASTING AN AYE VOTE
TODAY FOR A. B.. TEN FIFTY FOUR
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG FURTHER
DEBATE AND DISCUSSION SENATOR
DOLLY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I CAME HERE SIX AND A
HALF YEARS AGO TO THE STATE
ASSEMBLY.
FROM A COUNTY OF LASSEN.
DATA.
IS VERY OVERGROWN WITH FUEL.
AND I TALKED ABOUT WILD FIRE
FROM THE DAY I CAME I'VE HAD
MANY OF YOU.
OVER A HUNDRED AND TEN
LEGISLATORS TO MY DISTRICT --
SHOWING THE PROBLEM WE HAVE WITH
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
WE HAVE A HUNDRED YEARS OF FIRE
SUPPRESSION.
CALIFORNIA NATURALLY BURN EVERY
TEN TO TWELVE YEARS.
BEFORE WE CAME.
EN US STARTED PUTTING OUT FIRES
SO WE HAVE A HUGE MASSIVE LOAD
OF VEGETATION.
NOW THIS BILL WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TALKS ABOUT UTILITY TO
PROVIDE POWER.
THROUGH THIS MASS MAYES OF
VEGETATION.
ONLY TWO OUT OF TEN FIRES IN
CALIFORNIA -- APPROXIMATELY ARE
MARK CAUSED BY UTILITIES.
SO WE REALLY HAVE -- TO
OBVIOUSLY KEEP.
THEM WHOLE SO WE CAN MANAGE --
GETTING POWER TO OUR COULD CUT A
CONSUMERS.
BUT THE BIGGEST THREAT WE HAVE
IS TOO MUCH VEGETATION.
LAST YEAR WE DID SB NINE OH ON
WORK VERY CLOSE WITH MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM NAPA AND MANY
OTHERS.
BECAUSE WE HAD THE TUBS FIRE WE
HAD THE BUTTE FIRE.
WE HAD THE CAR FIRE WHICH WAS
BURNING AT THE TIME WE ARE
ACTUALLY DOING.
THE BILL THAT NINE OH ONE BILL.
AND THEN THIRTY DAYS AFTER WE
GOT NINE A ONE PASSED WE HAD THE
CAMPFIRE THE LARGEST FIRE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA MOST
DEVASTATING FIRE.
BECAUSE A LEGISLATOR WE HAVE TO
PLAY THE HAND WE'RE DEALT.
IN UNFORTUNATELY THE HAND WE
HAVE DEALT TO US TODAY IS THAT
WE HAVE -- ONE UTILITY THE GENIE
IN BANKRUPTCY.
DUE TO CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE.
WE HAVE TWO OTHER.
I'LL USE THAT ARE ON THE VERGE
OF BANKRUPTCY.
SO WHAT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO
THE RIGHT THING TO DO IS PASS
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
BECAUSE IT ENSURES THAT THE RATE
PAYERS WILL BE LEVELED OUT AS
GOOD AS YOU CAN.
IN A PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
NUMBER TWO ALL THOSE VICTIMS WHO
LOST THEIR HOMES.
IN THE TUBS FIRE IN THE CAMP
FIRE.
WHOTHEIR COMPANIES IN
BANKRUPTCY RIGHT NOW HAVE A
SECURE?
WAY TO GO AFTER THOSE FUNDS.
THAT THE THE COMPANIES ARE GOING
TO PUT UP THE THE THE REVENUES
TO OFFSET THE COST OF THEM.
THINK ABOUT IT IF YOU'RE
SOMEBODY WHO LOST HER HOME WHO
IS UNDER SHIRT OR NOT INSURED.
BY AN INSURANCE COMPANY.
YOU HAVE NO WHERE TO GO IF
YOU'RE IN THE P. JEANNIE
TERRITORY RIGHT NOW BECAUSE YOUR
BANKRUPTCY.
SO THIS A PERFECT BILL
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
BUT WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO
I WOULD JUST VENTURE TO SAY MOST
OF THE MEMBERS HERE KNOW THAT
TOM THIS IS A PIECE OF THE PIE.
WE'VE DONE ALL KINDS OF CAP AND
TRADE BILLS WE'VE MOVED OUR PS
STANDARD UP I VOTED AGAINST ALL
THOSE BILLS.
WE REGULATED THE COMMERCIAL
TRUCKS I OWN.
THE LAWN MOWERS THE WE YEARS
BECAUSE OF CARBON SEQUESTRATION
AS WE LET OUR POOREST.
BURN IT'S WRONG WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON THE BIGGEST EMITTER OF CARBON
WHICH IS FORCE FIRE CALIFORNIA.
SO I WANTED.
COMMITTEE YOU I'M GONNA SUPPORT
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION I
THINK THE RIGHT THING TO DO FOR
THOSE WHO LOST EVERYTHING.
I THINK WE HAVE. FOR ONE FIRE
AWAY OR COUPLE FIRES AWAY FROM
BEING RIGHT BACK HERE ON THIS
FLOOR THIS THIS ISN'T A FIX ALL.
THIS IS PART OF A LONG TERM
PROCESS WE DIDN'T GET HERE
OVERNIGHT IT IS A HUNDRED YEARS
TO GET HERE.
BUT IT'S OUR JOB TO DO THE RIGHT
THING THE RIGHT THING IS TO VOTE
FOR THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
AND THEN LET'S GO BACK TO THE
DRAWING BOARD IN THE START
LOOKING AT THAT VEGETATION.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES THAT NEED TO
HAVE.
THE CLEANING DONE AND THE
VEGETATION MOVE THE THERE'S
THERE'S THREE THINGS THAT.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE TO HAVE FIRE
[inaudible]
OXYGEN.
FUEL AND IGNITION.
THERE'S TWO THINGS WE CAN'T
CONTROL OXYGEN AND IGNITION BUT
WE CAN'T CONTROL THE FUEL.
THAT'S FOR ME TO TARGET WE NEED
A TARGET ON THE FUEL MAKE OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE.
AS SAFE AS WE CAN AND THIS IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. TO
STABILIZE OUR UTILITIES AND THEN
WE NEED TO TACKLE THE BIG
PROBLEM WHICH IS VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT THROUGHOUT THE STATE
I HEARD AND I ABOUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER DOLLY SENATOR
RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS AT THIS BILL IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
THERE ARE SEVERAL THINGS I
WANTED TO SEE IN A BILL AND
TODAY I BELIEVE WE HAVE THAT.
I WANTED TO SEE RATE PAIR
PROTECTION.
CORPORATE ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND A NEWLY CREATED FOR TWENTY
SURE ONGOING SAID SAFETY
MEASURES WERE IN PLACE.
THE MEASURE BEFORE US TODAY
INCORPORATES KEY ASPECTS THAT
WILL ENSURE THE HEALTH OF OUR
STATE.
AND CITIZENS AND IT'S ALSO A
VICTIM FOCUS WE HAVE HEARD OF
MANY VICTIMS COME FORWARD AND
SHARE THE STORIES AND WE CANNOT
FORGET THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
BEHIND POLICIES.
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT THAT WE
PRIORITIZE OUR TAXPAYERS OVER
PROFITS.
EQUALLY IMPORTANT IT HOLD.
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS I'M ALSO ENCOURAGED THAT
AB TEN FIFTY FOUR WILL MEDICAID
FUTURE WILDFIRES BY ENGAGED IN
GAUGING NATIONAL EXPERTS ON
WILDFIRES IN UTILITIES WHO WILL
SIT ON THE NEWLY CREATED.
WHILE FIRE SAFETY BOARD
ADDITIONALLY IT WILL ALLOW THE
COMMISSION TO REGULARLY CHECK
SAFETY STANDARDS IN ISSUE
CERTIFICATIONS.
WE CAN ALL AGREE THE BAD ACTORS
NEED TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS PROPOSAL DOES THAT AND IT
AND INCENTIVIZE IS UTILITIES TO
ACT PRUDENTLY.
UTILITIES WILL NEED TO
DEMONSTRATE PROOF OF ACTING IN
GOOD FAITH BEFORE THEY'RE ABLE
TO TAP INTO THE WILDFIRE FUND.
MEMBERS EXECUTIVES CANNOT
CONTINUE TO MAKE PROFITS ON THE
BACKS OF TRAGEDIES.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO THE TO THE
SAME THING WITH THE SAME PEOPLE
AND EXPECT DIFFERENT RESULTS.
THAT'S WHAT I'M ENCOURAGED TO
SEE THAT WE'RE BRINGING NATIONAL
EXPERTS TO THE TABLE.
AS CHAIR OF INSURANCE.
I SEE THAT IN ADDITION TO
STABILIZING THE IMPACT A
WILDFIRE IN OUR ENERGY INDUSTRY
WE ALSO NEED TO ENSURE WE HAVE A
STABLE INSURANCE MARKET. FOR THE
SAKE OF HOMEOWNERS WE NEED A
HEALTHY MARKET THAT OFFERS A
VARIETY OF PRODUCTS HOMEOWNERS
NEED.
THAT ENSURES THAT THEY GET THE
PROTECTION THEY DESERVE SHOULD
AN UNFORTUNATE EVENT OCCUR AND
THAT KEEPS COST AFFORDABLE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH
THAT INSURANCE SERVICES AND
PROTECTIONS ARE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION MOVING FORWARD. FOR
NOW ON THE CREATION OF A
WILDFIRE FUN IS ESSENTIAL FOR
ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND REPAIRS AS
WE MOVE FORWARD.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE BOTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR GALGIANI.
THANK YOU I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL BUT I DO WANT TO RAISE
A CONCERN THAT HAS BEEN RAISED
BY SOME OF THE MUNICIPALITIES IN
MY DISTRICT.
I AM FORTUNATE TO HAVE -- MERCED
IRRIGATION DISTRICT MODESTO
IRRIGATION DISTRICT PER LOCK
IRRIGATION DISTRICT IN OUR
REGION AND THEY PROVIDE SERVICE
TO CONSTITUENTS AND I HAVE DONE
A VERY GOOD JOB OF DOING SO FOR
A NUMBER OF YEARS.
SOUTH SAN JOAQUIN IRRIGATION
DISTRICT HAS BEEN EN A COURT
BATTLE ESSENTIALLY FOR THE LAST
FOURTEEN TO FIFTEEN YEARS FIRE
TRYING TO ACQUIRE ASSETS IN
SOUTH SAN JOAQUIN IRRIGATION
DISTRICT. TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
POWER CHART CONSTITUENTS IN THAT
AREA.
PC CODE SECTION EIGHT FIVE ONE
ALREADY EMPOWERS THE PC TO
ANALYZE POTENTIAL ACQUISITION OF
ASSETS FROM ELECTRICAL OR GAS
COMPANY TO ENSURE THAT THE
REMAINING BUNDLE CUSTOMERS ARE
NOT ADVERSELY IMPACTED.
THIS BILL ALSO IN SECTION EIGHT
FIFTY FOUR AM EIGHT FIFTY FOUR
POINT TO PROVIDES A THAT CPUC
MUST ACTUALLY AUTHORIZED THE
CHANGE IN OWNERSHIP FROM MANY
GAS ELECTRICAL CORPORATION. TO
MUNICIPALITY SO I AM -- WANTING
SOME ASSURANCES THAT WHETHER
IT'S IN A TRAILER BILL OR
SOMETHING AND A FUTURE EFFORT
THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT.
THIS NEW CHANGE THROUGH THIS
BILL IS NOT IN ANY WAY GOING TO
HAMPER EFFORTS TO MINUTES SUPPLY
MUNICIPAL ALLIES WHETHER IT'S
FROM A MEET NISA POLITY IN MY
DISTRICT OR ANOTHER IN ANY OTHER
PART OF THE STATE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MATTER
PRESIDENT I RISE -- FRANKLY
RELUCTANTLY AND RESPECTFULLY --
IN OPPOSITION I TO TO THIS
LEGISLATION AND I SAY
RELUCTANTLY ON BECAUSE THERE'S A
LOT OF GOOD IN THIS LEGISLATION.
ON A LOT OF REALLY GOOD WORK BY
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BY AUTHORS
I WENT INTO THIS BILL -- AND
THIS BILL WILL HAVE BENEFITS FOR
REPAIRS ON YOU KNOW THE I KNOW
THERE ARE SOME OUT THERE WHO SAY
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE HAD THE
SHAREHOLDERS SHOULD BE A 100%.
RESPONSIBLE AND WE NEED TO KNOW
AND REPAIRS SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
BEAR ANY OF THE COSTS OF THESE
WILDFIRES I WISH THAT WERE TRUE
THAT WOULD BE AMAZING -- BUT NO
MATTER WHAT WE DO WHETHER WE DO
NOTHING OR DO SOMETHING.
REPAIRS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION -- AND I
THINK THERE ARE ASPECTS OF THIS
BILL THAT WILL MAKE THINGS-BETTER OP.
TIRES ON I ALSO BELIEVE IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE STABILIZE OUR
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES THEY
ARE UNSTABLE RIGHT NOW AND THERE
ARE ASPECTS OF THIS BILL.
THAT WILL STABILIZE OUR OHIO USE.
MY CONCERN -- AND THE REASON WHY
I WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY AND I'M NOT IN ANY
WAY CRITICAL OF ANYONE ELSE FOR
SUPPORTING A CAUSE I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND WHY THESE ISSUES ARE
SO IMPORTANT.
IS THAT -- WE ARE IN A TRIAGE
SITUATION WITH OUR INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES BUT I ALSO
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO TAKE
WHAT IS A BROKEN MODEL RIGHT NOW
IN TERMS OF FIRE USING
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE NEED TO LOOK TOWARDS THE
FUTURE.
BUT I THINK WE IT WAS A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY NOT TO INCLUDE OTHER
ELEMENTS OF THIS BILL TO MOVE US
IN THAT DIRECTION -- THE MOST
SPECIFICALLY -- I AM VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT WAS ADDED
INTO THE BILL LAST WEEK -- THAT
WILL SIGNIFICANTLY ON MAKE IT
SIGNIFICANTLY HARDER -- TO
CREATE -- MUNICIPAL UTILITY A
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITY WOR FOR
A PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITY TO BE
ABLE TO EXPAND BY ACQUIRING
ASSETS FROM AND I OWE YOU -- I
YOU KNOW THAT THIS DRAMATICALLY
INCREASES THE CPU SEES OVERSIGHT
AND THE STANDARDS REQUIRED -- TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE THOSE
ACQUISITIONS -- SO AS A RESULT
BECAUSE I'M A STRONG BELIEVER --
THAT ARE MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
WHETHER WATER POWER CALIFORNIA.
I'VE BEEN A VERY POSITIVE FORCE
IN THE STATE -- I DO BELIEVE WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THOSE MODELS FOR
A FUTURE WITH A MORE SUSTAINABLE
AND RESILIENT -- ELECTRIC SYSTEM
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I
BELIEVE IT THIS ONE PROVISION --
IS VERY DETRIMENTAL THAT HAVE --
FOR AND AS A RESULT I WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I'LL BE BRIEF I MENTION
THIS MORNING IN COMMITTEE BUT
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE TALK WITH
THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WILD FIRE
VICTIMS AS A CLASS OF PEOPLE OR
SOME GENERIC [inaudible]
GROUP BUT WE KNOW THEY'RE REAL.
I WAS ONE OF THEM IN SOME SMALL
RESPECT I'M A RENTER AND I DON'T
DESERVE.
PUBLIC SYMPATHY BECAUSE I WENT
THROUGH A LOT LESS THAN MANY
OTHER PEOPLE I STILL HAVE MY
LIFE.
I LOST THINGS -- BUT I WASN'T
BROKEN FINANCIALLY I HAD A
FAMILY TO GO -- TO WARM BED TO
SLEEP IN -- STILL TO GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS OF WHAT IT FEELS
LIKE WHEN EVERYTHING BURNS DOWN.
AND THAT'S WEIGHED HEAVILY ON MY
MIND.
THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE PROCESS
IS THAT.
I THIS ISN'T JUST POLICY.
IT'S ABOUT PEOPLE'S LIVES.
AND WHEN THE GOVERNOR SHOWED UP
IN THE ASHES THE WILL THE FIRE.
AS A NEWLY ELECTED IN -- THE
SHRINE.
LEADER AT THE HELP ME SAID I'M A
STEP UP AND HELP.
WE GOT ACT ON CLIMATE THIS YEAR.
AND THAT MEANS DEALING WITH HIS
WILD FIRE RISK.
AND I THINK THE GOVERNOR'S
FOLLOWED THROUGH ON HIS WORK.
AND FOR ALL THE UNFINISHED
BUSINESS THAT WE HAVE HERE TODAY
AND I ONE EIGHT KNOWLEDGE.
SERVER SAN FRANCISCO.
AND OTHERS HERE WHO ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE AND IN OUR
INSURANCE COMMITTEES WHO WHO HAD
KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE'S MUCH
UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
WITH THE INSURANCE NON RENEWALS
OCCURRING.
WITH THIS SORT OF FEELING A
DISEMPOWERMENT THE PEOPLE FEEL
WHEN THEY LIVE IN THIS WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE WITH THEY SAY.
WE WE DON'T HAVE THE POWER TO
CONTROL THESE WILDFIRES THAT
SACRAMENTO MAKE SOME DECISIONS
BUT WE SIT HERE IN THE WE WE
POWERLESS.
THEY'RE ON A RESPIRATOR LIVING
IN A NURSING HOME OR THEY'RE
LIVING AMONGST IN A TEN FOOT
HIGH MUSTARD PLANTS AND THEY
WONDER.
HOW'S IT GOING.
TO HOW MY GONNA PROTECT MY
FAMILY AND MY PROPERTY WHEN THIS
HAPPENS AGAIN BECAUSE IT WILL
HAPPEN AGAIN.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF IF IT'S
MATTER WHEN.
SO WITH THAT UNFINISHED BUSINESS
WE NEED TO GIVE COMMUNITIES
THOSE TOOLS TO HARDEN THEIR
HOMES ON A COMMUNITY BASIS.
THE USE DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN
THERE'S TE ENERGY IS ATION THAT
THEIR POWER DOESN'T GO DOWN IT
HURT THEIR HEALTH.
OR TURN OFF THE RESPIRATOR OR
MAKE THOSE COOLING CENTERS OF
THOSE OTHER EVACUATION CENTER
SHUT DOWN WE CAN'T AFFORD THAT
RISK AND THOSE AREN'T SOLVED IN
THIS BILL.
SO WE STILL HAVE WORK TO DO THIS
SESSION ON THIS FRONT.
BUT THE REASON I'M RISING IN
SUPPORT TODAY'S BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK WE CAN AFFORD TO WAIT.
ON THIS CRITICAL PIECE THE
FORMULA.
PEOPLE WILL BE HURT.
VICTIMS WILL BE DENIED JUSTICE.
IF WE ALLOW THE SYSTEM TO
COLLAPSE.
AND DENY THEIR CLAIMS AND EXTEND
THEM FOR ANOTHER THOUSAND DAYS
THOSE OF THOSE OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WHO WENT THROUGH
TUBS.
OR NORTH BAY FOR NAPA THEY'RE
STILL WAITING.
AND THOSE IN BANKRUPTCY THEY'RE
BUT ARE VICTIMS OF WAS HE THERE
STILL WAITING.
SO WE CAN'T WAIT TODAY.
AS MUCH AS I'D LIKE TO SEE MORE
DITIONS MADE AND I APPRECIATE
THE COMMITMENT FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND FROM THE
AUTHOR THERE'S A LETTER TO THE
JOURNAL PENDING.
IT'LL BE COMING BEFORE US LATER
THIS WEEK ADDRESSING SOME OF
THESE GAPS IN THEIR COMMITMENTS
ON IMPLEMENTATION AROUND
RESILIENCY AND HARDENING
INSURANCE AND DISTRIBUTED.
ENERGY RESOURCES ANOTHER SORT OF
CRITICAL UPGRADES TO OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE IN OUR OUR
CIRCUITS TO MAKE SURE THESE
EVENTS DON'T SHUT DOWN OUR LIVES
AND THEY SET DOWN THE GREED.
WITHOUT THIS ACT TODAY WITHOUT
THIS AYE VOTE TODAY.
WILL FORCE CALIFORNIANS TO WHICH
AND THAT JUSTICE DEFERRED CANNOT
BE DENIED.
SO WITH THAT HEAVY WEIGHT ON OUR
SHOULDERS I RISE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
BUT ALSO WITH THE COMMITMENT.
THE KEEP SWEATING.
AND GO DO THAT WORK.
AND GRAIN OURSELVES IN THESE
COMMUNITIES.
ARE COUNTING ON THANK YOU.
SENATOR MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
WHAT A WAY TO COME BACK FROM AN
INDEPENDENCE DAY WEEKEND -- THIS
IS A MASSIVE BILL.
AND IT IS BEING FAST TRACKED IN
SUCH A SHORT TIME.
SO I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
FROM LOS ANGELES FOR GIVING THE
DETAILS OF ALL THE PAGES AND ALL
THE ISSUES AND ALL THE
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE.
IMPACTED -- BECAUSE HE JUST
CALLED ME A WEEK AGO SUNDAY THEY
LET ME KNOW WHAT'S IN THE BILL
AND AND HERE WE ARE LITERALLY
EIGHT DAYS LATER VOTING ON IT --
AND THE SENATOR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO MAKES A VALID POINT OF
BOY WITH A LITTLE MORE TIME FOR
A LITTLE MORE DEBATE BE HELPFUL.
IN THIS OPPORTUNITY.
THE MAJOR REASON I'M HEARING
[inaudible] FOR THE FOR NOT
DOING INACTION TODAY IS BECAUSE
THE CREDIT RATING AGENCIES START
THREATENING TO DOWNGRADE THE
OTHER TWO INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES.
THIS WOULD POSSIBLY PUT ONE OF
THEM.
MAYBE BOTH INTO BANKRUPTCY COURT
AS WELL [inaudible]
OR AT THE LEAST MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THEM.
AFTER BEING DOWNGRADED.
TO GOING TO THE COMMERCIAL PAPER
MARKET.
MAKING IT VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE
TO DO THEY'RE SHORT TERM
BORROWING [inaudible]
SO.
IF IF WE WOULD'VE HAD A LITTLE
MORE TIME IT WOULD HAVE BEEN.
INTERESTING TO HAVE PROVIDED.
AN AMENDMENT TO THE BILL.
AND DO THE AMENDMENT DRILL AND
JUST SIMPLY SAY HEY WHY DON'T WE
PROVIDED PROVISION.
IN GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION
SIXTEEN FOR THIRTY WHICH IS.
WHICH IS THE CODE SECTION THAT
DICK TAKES THE INVESTMENT POLICY
STATEMENT FOR THE STATE
TREASURER.
AND ALLOW THE STATE TREASURER TO
PURCHASE DEBT OF INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES AS DEFINED IN SECTION
TWO ONE EIGHT OF THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES CODE.
THAT HAVE BEEN RATED BELOW
INVESTMENT GRADE [inaudible]
SO.
I COVER MARCH COUNTY.
OUR TREASURE IN DECEMBER
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR IS SAYING
HEY I'M HAVING TROUBLE WITH MY
PORTFOLIO.
WE WERE JUST TRANSITIONING.
KATHLEEN BROWN WAS TREASURER AND
SHE WAS PACKING UP HER OFFICE
AND MATT FONG WAS MOVING IN.
GOING TO BE SWORN IN.
AND WE COULDN'T GET STATE HELP
BUT WE JUST ALWAYS WONDER BOY
THE STATE TREASURER GONNA STEP
THEN.
AND MAYBE HELP WE CAN TO HELP
OUR PORTFOLIO FOR SIX MONTHS.
WE WE MAYBE WOULD NOT HAVE LOST
ONE POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS.
THIS IS ACTUALLY AN ARGUMENT
MADE BY MERRILL LYNCH FOR THE
LONGEST TIME AND LITIGATION IT
WAS CALLED THE WHAT IS SURE TO
CUT A STRATEGY BUT IT WAS SAYS
SOMETHING THAT WAS -- PROFFERED
IN THE MIDDLE OF ALL OF OUR
DELIBERATIONS BUT WE COULDN'T
GET.
ASSISTANCE FROM A BIG PLAYER
THAT HAD A LARGE PORTFOLIO.
SAME THING SORT OF HAPPEN IN THE
STATE OF ALABAMA FEW YEARS AGO
THE COUNTY OF JEFFERSON
JEFFERSON COUNTY.
FOUND ITSELF -- WITH A FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR INTEREST RATE
SWAP DEAL.
AND THEY FOUND THEMSELVES IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT THE MIDDLE OF THE
CREDIT CRISIS.
AND THEY HAD TO PURCHASE PAPER
EVERY WEEK CALL IT A PUT.
AND THEY WERE PAYING 15% SOME
HIGHER RATES WHEN THEY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN ONE OR TWO NOW THE
STATE TREASURER COULD A JUMPED
IN AND PURCHASED.
THEIR PUTS THEN THEY COULD AT A
SMALL PRMIUM AND SAVE THAT
COUNTY A LOT OF MONEY AND IT
WOULD HAVE SAVED THE TAXPAYERS
BUT INSTEAD JEFFERSON COUNTY HAD
TO FILE FOR CHAPTER. NINE
BANKRUPTCY PROTECTION AS WELL SO
WITH THAT IDEA IF.
IF OUR TREASURE COULD PURCHASE
COMMERCIAL PAPER FROM THE I. O.
USE -- CHARGE A LITTLE PREMIUM
FOR TAKING THE RISK BUT THAT'S A
WHOLE LOT LESS THAN WHAT THEY
WOULD PAY IN THE OPEN MARKET
THAT'S YOU WOULD IN A SENSE.
YOU WOULD YOU WOULD YOU WOULD
PAY THE TAXPAYERS FOR TAKING ON
THIS OPPORTUNITY BUT YOU
WOULDN'T.
PENALIZE THE RATE PAYERS SO MUCH
[inaudible]
BY.
ARE NOT CHARGING A YOU KNOW AN
EXORBITANT AMOUNT AND IT WOULD
BE A GOOD SIGN OF PARTNERSHIP
BECAUSE THE UTILITIES ARE TIED
TO THE HIP.
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT
IS THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
THAT DICTATES WHAT RATES ARE
SPENT WHAT PRIORITIES ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE PURSUED AND WE
COULD HAVE A LONG DISCUSSION IF
WE HAD THE TIME ON HOW IT COULD
HAVE PERHAPS.
ACTED DIFFERENTLY SO HERE WE
HAVE MAYBE A CHANCE TO BUY SOME
TIME TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SOME DISCUSSION.
AND EVERYBODY SORT OF WINS WE
WOULDN'T BE BEHOLDEN.
TO CREDIT RATING AGENCIES AND
I'VE BEEN THERE BEFORE AND I'VE.
TO GET MORE STORIES ABOUT THAT
SO I RESPECT ALL THE WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE AND IT'S BEEN DONE IN
A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
BUT I WILL SAY IT IS A LITTLE
RUSHED FOR SOMETHING AS MASSIVE
IS THIS AND THERE IS A WAY TO
FIND A LITTLE MORE TIME WORKING
WITH THE RATING AGENCIES.
I'M JUST SORRY THE PERCEIVED
IMMEDIACY IS DICTATING THE PACE
OF AB TEN FIFTY FOUR I WOULD
HAVE LOVED TO SEE A FIFTEEN YEAR
STRATEGIC FINANCIAL PLAN FROM
OUR I USED JUST TO SEE HOW
EVERYTHING WOULD PENCIL OUT WORK
OUT -- BUT I GUESS I GUESS.
I SHOULD BE HAPPY MAYBE STATE
GOVERNMENT.
CAN ACT QUICKLY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
[inaudible]
SENATOR NIELSEN.
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE.
I RISE IN SUPPORT AND I SPEAK
VICARIOUSLY THROUGH THE EYES OF
THE PEOPLE WHO HAD TO ONE DOOR
[inaudible]
THESE FIRES.
PARTICULARLY.
IN BUTTE COUNTY [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMAN GALLAGHER.
SENATOR DOLLY AND I REPRESENT.
AND WE HAVE BEEN THERE.
SINCE THE FIRE STARTED.
IN THE THROES OF THE FIRE.
WATCHING THE TERRIFIED EVACUEES.
HEARING THEIR STORIES.
TALKING TO THEM ON THE CELL
PHONES IS A WERE BLOCKED ON THE
SKY WAY TRYING TO ESCAPE.
OR COMING DOWN ANOTHER BACK
WROTE.
AND AS I NORMALLY AM RESISTANCE
TOWARDS PASSED TRACKING
LEGISLATION.
THIS IS A VERY DIFFERENT MATTER.
I THINK MY COLLEAGUES HAVE JUST
VERY ACCURATELY.
INDICATED WHY THAT IS SO.
BUT NOT THE LEAST IS THOSE
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO WERE HORRIFIED?
WHO LOST LOVED ONES LOST
EVERYTHING THEY HAD?
THEY NEED SOME ASSURANCE.
THAT THEY WILL GET SOME HELP.
THIS OFFERS THEM HELP.
I DON'T ARGUE THAT THIS IS A
BAILOUT OF GREEDY UTILITIES.
THERE ARE MANY PROVISIONS IN
HERE.
THE HELP CONSTRUCT CONSTRAIN
THAT I'M SATISFIED WITH THAT
EXCEPT I DON'T LIKE THEM BEING
EXEMPTED FROM THE BAGLEY KEENE
ACT BUT THAT'S ANOTHER MATTER.
YOU WEIGH THE GOOD WITH THE THE
NOT SO GOOD.
BUT MOST IMPORTANT THERE IS AN
URGENCY. TO THOSE CITIZENS.
IN THESE FIRE [inaudible]
INFLAMED AREAS.
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE DECISIONS
NOW ABOUT THEIR OWN FUTURES.
THAT THEY LOST EVERYTHING THAT
THERE IS SOME RELIEF COMING TO
THEM THAT THEY CAN COUNT ON THAT
THERE WILL BE A REBUILDING.
THAT WILL GIVE THEM ASSURANCE.
OF A FUTURE.
AND VERY PARTICULAR THAT THERE'S
A LONG TERM PLAN.
THAT WE WILL MINIMIZE THE
PROBABILITY OF THIS HAPPENING
EVER AGAIN.
AND NOT THE LEAST OF WHICH IS
ENSURING.
A ONGOING PROGRAM.
OF MANAGING THE FORCE AND WILD
LANDS INSTEAD OF JUST TURNING
OUR BACKS ON THEM AS WE DID HERE
FOR DECADES IN THIS STATE.
WE HAVE NOW HARVESTED
[inaudible]
THE BANE.
OF THAT NEGLECT.
WE MUST NOT REPLICATE THAT.
AND SOME OF THAT HAS BEEN DEALT
WITH IN THE LAST TWO BUDGETS FOR
THE FIRST TIME WE'VE.
PUT MONEY IN THE BUDGET.
THE GOVERNORS HAVE BEEN HELPFUL.
THIS GOVERNOR WAS WHETHER FROM
THE START.
GOING UP. TO THESE FIRES FROM
THE GET GO.
LOOKING AT RIGHT IN THE EYE.
AND AS WE'VE TALKED CENTS
[inaudible]
MANY TIMES.
I KNOW THAT THAT IS IN HIS HEART.
AND A SINCERE.
ABOUT GETTING CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
GOING AGAIN.
AND THIS IS INDEED A BIG PART.
ONE OF THE CHANGES IN THIS
DECADE.
HAS BEEN THE WILDFIRES FORMERLY
WERE JUST THE AFFLICTION OF THE
RURAL AREAS.
THE MORE URBANIZED IN SUBURBAN
CENTERS.
DIDN'T HAVE MUCH PROBLEMS WITH.
I REMEMBER THOUGH THE BERKELEY
HILLS FIRE THAT COST ONE OF MY
FORMER COLLEAGUE SENATOR PETROUS
IS HOME THE BERKELEY HILLS.
WE ALL GATHERED UP THE BOOKS TO
HELP.
RESTOCK HIS LIBRARY IN FACT.
A TRULY GREAT MAN I HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE HIM.
BUT WE ARE RALLYING TOGETHER NOW.
TO GET OUR FELLOW CALIFORNIANS
BACK ON TRACK AND THEN FOR THE
LONG RUN FOR THE GENERATIONS FOR
OUR CHILDREN AND FOR OUR
GRANDCHILDREN.
THAT THERE CAN BE A FUTURE THERE
FOR THEM.
NOT JUST IN THE RURAL AREAS BUT
NOW AS WE SEE.
THE CATACLYSMIC FIRES.
ARE SO GREAT.
THEY COME TO VISIT OUR CITIES.
THE DRUG DESTROY PARTS OF THE
FIRE CAME RIGHT TO THE ROAD THE
CITY LIMITS OF RED BLUFF WHERE
WE LIVE [inaudible]
THAT SUMMER.
AS WELL AS INTO READING TO THE
NORTH.
BUT I USED TO REPRESENT.
OUR CITIZENS OF PRAIRIE A VERY
DEAR PRICE.
AND WE CANNOT.
ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN AGAIN.
IT IS AN OPPORTUNITY HERE IN A
FAIRLY.
AND EXTENSIVELY CRAFTED BILL.
AND I WOULD SAY CAREFULLY. TO
PROTECT AND TO ENSURE.
THE BUILT IN CHECKS AND BALANCES.
AND DO SOME THINGS NEW. ONE OF
THE APPREHENSION SOME OF US
COULD HAVE IS INTRIGUING AND AND
TRUSTING TO THE P. YOU SEE A
VERY TROUBLED AGENCY
[inaudible]
NEW AUTHORITIES.
WELL I DON'T SEE US AS DOING
THAT HERE.
IN FACT TO THE CONTRARY.
NOT ONLY THE GOVERNOR WILL
APPOINT PEOPLE TO THAT
COMMISSION WHO WILL BE COGNIZANT
AND SENSITIVE. TO THE
AUTHORITIES NOW ACCORDED THE P.
YOU SEE AND THESE NEW ENTITIES.
RELATED TO MANAGING OUR FUTURE
[inaudible]
RELATED [inaudible] TO WILDFIRES.
IT'S SAD THAT WE HAVE TO SUFFER.
SUCH A GREGIS LOSSES.
BEFORE WE AWAKEN.
AND BECOME PROACTIVE.
BUT WE'VE BEEN BLESSED WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY NOW.
THE FIRES ARE DOWN.
OTHERS ARE WAITING TO START
AGAIN.
LET US HERE NOW GET ABOUT.
ATTENDING TO THE FUTURE.
I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
SKI.
GOOD EVENING MADAM PRESIDENT I
REVIEWED EVENING I TRY TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AND
THE FLOOR MANAGER MIGHT SEAT
MATE OTHER MEMBERS HAVE TALKED
ABOUT MUCH MORE -- TO DO AND THE
CALL FOR FUTURE INVESTMENTS IN
PREVENTION AND FORCE MANAGEMENT
AND LONG TERM RESILIENCY AND YES
AS THE GENTLEMAN FROM SHASTA AND
THE GENTLEMAN FROM TAMAR.
HAVE A S. STATED WE NEED TO DO
MORE AND VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
WE'RE ASKING DE I USED TO INVEST
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND
HARDENING THEIR ASSETS AND
THAT'S PROBABLY A GOOD NUMBER.
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
TO LOOK AT AS FAR AS WE LOOK AT
NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET ON WHAT WE
WANT TO DO WHAT INVESTMENTS WE
CAN MAKE.
I'D LIKE TO FOR A SECOND TWO
APPLIED THE AUTHORS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION.
ON THE DELICATE BALANCE THAT I
THINK THAT THEY'VE REACHED WITH
REGARD TO THE BANKRUPTCY COURT.
WHEN FORMER NORMALLY WE DON'T
HAVE MUCH TALK ABOUT BANKRUPTCY
COURTS USUALLY THERE'S A LOT OF
DISPARAGING STATEMENTS THAT MAKE --
MADE WITH PEOPLE THEY TALK HERE
IN THE COFFEE HOUSES ABOUT P.
GENIES FIND INTO BANKRUPTCY
THERE'S ANIMOSITY THERE'S ANGER
AND PEOPLE PEOPLE.
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT COME
OUT ARE QUITE SELF SERVING
STATEMENTS PEOPLE WANT TO CHERRY
PICK ASSETS OUT OF A RECOVERING
BANKRUPTCY WE HAVE SOME IMPLICIT
BIAS THAT WE TALK ABOUT WE LEARN
MORE ONE OF THE BIASES WE HAVE
ABOUT IS ABOUT.
PEOPLE WHO ARE FACED WITH BILLS
THAT THEY CAN'T PAY AND TRYING
TO REORGANIZE THEMSELVES.
AND I THINK WHEN THE FOUNDING
SEPARATE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
FROM THE STATE GOVERNMENT THERE
WAS A BALANCE AND I THINK PART
OF THE PROVISION THAT WE HAVE
HERE.
IN THE IN THE BILL THAT
INCENTIVIZE IS THE STATE THE I.
O. USING P.JEANNIE AND
PARTICULARLY.
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS FUN SO
THAT THEY WILL BE THEY WILL BE
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE MONEY AND ALSO THE
PAY THESE CLAIMS.
IS THE RIGHT BALANCE THAT THE
FOUNDING FATHERS THOUGHT THAT
THE CITY WHAT CAN CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ABOUT THIS COMPLICATED
BANKRUPTCY AND A COMPLICATED
PARTICULARLY COMPLICATED WHEN
YOU'RE DEALING WITH UTILITIES
AND THE IDEA IS THAT.
AT LEAST MY READING OF THE BILL
IN THE DAYS THAT WE'VE HAD IT IS
THAT WE'VE INCENTIVIZE THE
DEBTOR TO DO THE RIGHT THING
WE'VE INCENTIVIZE WE PROVIDED A
PATHWAY FOR THEM TO EMERGE FROM
BANKRUPTCY BY DOING THE RIGHT
THING BY.
SPENDING THE MONEY ON HARDENING
THEIR ASSETS BUT ALSO.
BUT ALSO TO BOMB.
PARTICIPATE IN THIS FUN AND WE
HAVEN'T BEEN BULLIES AND WE
HAVEN'T BEEN -- SECOND GUESSER
IS BUT WE SAID THIS IS THE
PATHWAY FOR SUCCESS IN
CALIFORNIA AND SOMEDAY IN THE
FUTURE PEOPLE IN MY WORLD OF
BANKRUPTCY WILL WRITE ABOUT THE
ACTIVE THE ACTIONS THAT WE TOOK
TODAY.
IT'S A SMALL FOOTNOTE IN IN THE
BIGGER PICTURE HERE OF THE OF
THE BILL BUT I WANTED TO RISE IN
SUPPORT AND THANK THE THE
AUTHORS FOR PUTTING THOSE THINGS
AND THANK YOU SIR Y. CASKEY FOR
THAT HISTORY LESSON.
SENATOR BATES THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU OF AN A PRESIDENT -- I
HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR
IF HE'S WILLING.
TO TAKE A YOU ACCEPT THE
QUESTION SENATOR.
VERY GOOD ALL RIGHT CENTER BATES --
CERTAINLY AMONG OUR CONSTITUENTS
SANDRA OTHERS THERE'S DISTRUST
THIS IS A VERY COMPLICATED BILL
AND THE QUESTION AT HAND THE
CONCERN THAT IS FREQUENTLY
PRESENTED TO ME IS THAT THE THIS
IS A BAILOUT OF THE UTILITIES I
THINK OVER THE LAST HOUR.
SEVERAL HOURS OF DEBATE AND
DISCUSSION ON IT'S COMING CLEAR
THAT THAT'S NOT.
REALLY -- SPECIFIC ARE TO THE
UTILITIES IT SEEMS THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE BEING HELPED WITH
THIS BUT I'D LIKE TO ASK THE
AUTHOR TO CLARIFY ON AND IT
RELIEVED THAT CONCERN REGARDING
WHAT THIS IS OR IS NOT DOING ARE
SPECIFICALLY.
ARE TO BAIL OUT UTILITIES.
WELL TO MY CALLING FROM --
ORANGE COUNTY FIRST OF ALL I
WOULD BE SUPPORTING THIS IF IT
WERE A BAILOUT FOR THE UTILITIES
OBVIOUSLY LAST YEAR.
AFTER SB NINE OH ONE WE WERE
ACCUSED OF HAVING THAT BE A BAIL
OUT SO AS WE EVEN THOUGH IT WAS
NOT IN -- YOU CERTAINLY WAS NOT
BUT NEVER THE LESS THERE WERE
MANY PEOPLE -- THAT I RESPECTED
BELIEVE THAT IT WAS SO THIS TIME
AROUND WE WORKED HARDER WITH
THAT STAKEHOLDERS WITH THE
LEADERSHIP WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
WAS CRAFTED IN A WAY THAT WAS
NOT A BAIL OUT OF THE UTILITIES.
LET ME TELL YOU A FEW THINGS IT
DOES NUMBER ONE IT INVEST
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN SAFETY
AND NORMALLY WHEN A UTILITY.
INVESTED EVERYTHING THEY GET A
RETURN.
OF TEN AND A HALF PERCENT THAT
JUST BY STATUTE.
BUT IN THIS BILL IT DOESN'T
ALLOW ANY PROFIT ON ANY OF THAT
INVESTMENT.
I DID ALSO -- FUNDS A NEW
LIABILITY FUND OF WHICH ARE --
UTILITIES ARE PUTTING AND NOW UP
FRONT TEN POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS.
BUT ALSO INVEST UP TO COULD IT
AT THE END OF TIME IT INVEST
OVER FORTY BILLION DOLLARS AGAIN
WITH NO PROFIT THERE. FOR P.
JEANNIE.
GETTING OUT OF BANKRUPTCY AND
PAYING OFF VICTIMS HAS TO BE.
RATE PAYER NEUTRAL LET ME REPEAT
RATE PAYER NEUTRAL RATE PAYERS
ARE NOT GOING TO BE PAID.
AT A PREVIOUS REPAIRS ARE NOT
GOING TO PAY. FOR THAT FINALLY --
THE VICTIMS -- I GOT THAT -- I
GUESS THERE'S THERE'S OTHER TO
TURN AND OTHER REPAIR GROUPS
LAST TIME AROUND SB NINE TO ONE
BECAUSE OF THAT BELIEVE THAT IT
WAS.
A REPAIR BILL A BAILOUT THIS
MORNING THERE ARE COMMITTEE
HEARING LOTS OF PEOPLE WERE
THERE THE REPAIR GROUPS.
I DID NOT OPPOSE THIS BILL WHICH
LAST TIME THEY DID OPPOSE THIS
BILL AND THEN FINALLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT REASON.
WHY THIS IS NOT A UTILITY -- A
BAIL OUT IS IT MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM SAN MATTEO IS JUST ABOUT
READY TO GET UP AND TESTIFY THAT
HE SUPPORTS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD.
NO PRESSURE SO IN ORDER HILL BUT
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND AND
COLLEAGUES -- I RISE IN SUPPORT
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION TODAY AND I DON'T DO
THAT LIGHTLY.
THIS WAS NOT AN EASY DECISION
FOR ME BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND TEN FOLLOWING
P. JEANNIE FOLLOWING OUR
UTILITIES FALLING IN OUR PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION.
AND WHAT I FOUND WAS A UTILITY
THAT WAS.
DIVERTING HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS FROM SAFETY.
FROM MAINTENANCE FROM OPERATIONS
TO BONUSES EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION PROFITS.
WHAT I SAW WAS A PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION?
THE FRANKLY WAS CORRUPT.
WHO IS CORRUPTED LEADERSHIP?
IT WAS CORRUPT IN THE MANNER IN
WHICH YOU DEALT.
WITH ITS UTILITIES INCESTUOUS
WAS THE RELATIONSHIP A COZY
RELATIONSHIP WHERE THEY WALKED
THE HALLS OF THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION.
ON A REGULAR BASIS TALKING TO
THE STAFF.
KEEPING THAT RELATIONSHIP CLOSE.
WHICH DIFFICULT TO WATCH.
AS I SAW THE POWER OF THOSE YET
UTILITIES IN THIS BUILDING.
THE CHALLENGES THAT THAT FACED
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS SO LAST
YEAR.
AFTER THE WILDFIRES OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND AS I SAW.
SB.
NINE OH ONE I DID NOT VOTE FOR
THAT LEGISLATION BECAUSE FRANKLY
I DID FEEL.
IT WAS A BAILOUT.
I FELT THAT IT GAVE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE UTILITIES FOR P. JEANNIE
ESPECIALLY [inaudible]
THE BENEFIT. TO GET PAID.
THE END TO GET RELIEF FROM
HAVING TO PAY THE FULL AMOUNT TO
THE VICTIMS OF THOSE FIRES.
I SAW IT AS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THEM I SAW WAS CLEAR.
IN A DISTINCT POSSIBILITY.
AND NOW AFTER THEY FILED FOR
BANKRUPTCY IT IS MORE A CLEAR
POSSIBILITY.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE.
NO RESOURCES TO COMPENSATE THOSE
VICTIMS.
THIS LEGISLATION SOLVE A LOT OF
THOSE PROBLEMS BECAUSE TO ME THE
ISSUE IS WE WANT OUR UTILITIES
TO SUCCEED IN CALIFORNIA.
WE WANT THEM TO HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO BORROW
THOSE RESOURCES TO PROVIDE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S NECESSARY
FOR A SOUND UTILITY.
END THIS WILL ALLOW THEM TO DO
THAT.
IT WILL ALLOW THEM TO DO IT IN A
WAY THAT PROVIDE STABILITY TO
THE MARKETS.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY IT DOES IT
IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS THE RATE
PAYERS BECAUSE THAT'S THE LENS
WITH WHICH I HAVE BEEN LOOKING
AT THIS LEGISLATION.
IS THE LENS TO SEE AND MAKE SURE
THAT THE RATE PAYERS ARE NOT
PUNISHED.
ARE NOT HELD TO A UP A LOWER
STANDARD BASICALLY ARE A HIGHER
STANDARD DEPENDING ON HOW YOU
LOOK AT THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
HELD RESPONSIBLE.
IN THOSE IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND EIGHTEEN FIRES.
THEY ARE PROTECTED IN THIS.
THE BAIL OUT OF NINE OH ONE IS
NO LONGER IN EFFECT.
BECAUSE P. JEANNIE OR THE RATE
PAYERS WE COULD HAVE BEEN HELD.
FOR TWENTY THIRTY FORTY BILLION
DOLLARS TO COVER THE COST NOW
WE'RE NOT.
IS THIS LEGISLATION MOVES
FORWARD WITH A CAP ON A REPAIR
CONTRIBUTION A CAP.
OF TEN POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IT WILL GO BEYOND THAT.
IN THAT'S THE EXPOSURE THAT WE
HAVE WE COULD HAVE BEEN SADDLED
WITH THIRTY FORTY FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS BUT NOW IT'S TEN POINT
FIVE AND WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT
WILL BE THE AMOUNT WE WILL HAVE
TO PAY.
AT THE END BECAUSE WE'RE NOT OUT
OF THAT TEN AND A HALF BILLION
GOING TO PAY. FOR THOSE VICTIMS
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT WILL COME FROM P.
JEANNIE AND IT SHOULD COME FROM
PGA.
I WAS IMPRESSED WHEN I SAW THE
ORIGINAL [inaudible]
BILL.
WHEN THIS BILL CAME FORWARD AND
WAS EXPLAINED HADN'T READ IT YET
BUT IT LOOKS GOOD?
IT SOUNDED GOOD.
THEN IN THE DETAILS THERE WERE
SOME CHALLENGES CHALLENGES WITH
LIABILITY HOW IS THAT GOING TO
BE DEFINED TO PROTECT US AS WE
GO FORWARD AS THOSE FIRES WILL
COME AS WE WILL SEE.
AND HOW WE DEFINE WHO'S GOING TO
PAY FOR THOSE AT THE END.
AND WE WERE ABLE TO WORK WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S STAFF WHO DID AN
OUTSTANDING EXTRAORDINARY JOB.
IN REACHING OUT COMMUNICATING IN
TRYING TO TO CREATE A AND CRAFT
A SOLUTION OF WORDS.
IN THOSE WORDS MEAN SOMETHING IN
THIS LEGISLATION AS IT GOES.
FOR AS WE DEFINE RESPONSIBILITY
AS WE DESPITE DEFINED REPAIR
RESPONSIBILITY BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY AS WE DEFINED
UTILITY RESPONSIBILITY AND
LIABILITY.
THIS BILL DID THAT IN DOES IT
TODAY.
THE IDEA OF EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I HAVE
LEGISLATION ON EIGHT YEARS AGO.
AFTER THE FIRE IN SAN BRUNO THE
GAS EXPLOSION KILLED EIGHT
PEOPLE.
AND THE C. E. O. OF P. JEANNIE
PETER DARBY LEFT THAT COMPANY
WITH A TWENTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS GOLDEN PARACHUTE. TWENTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT WON'T HAPPEN WITH THIS
LEGISLATION.
WILL BE PROTECTED FROM THAT.
AND WE WON'T SEE THAT.
AS REPAIRS ARE PROTECTED
LIABILITY GOING FORWARD WILL BE
FAIR.
IF THOSE UTILITIES BECAUSE THEIR
NEGLIGENCE YOUR RESPONSIBILITY
CAUSES THAT FIRE THEY'RE GOING
TO PAY.
IF IT'S NOT THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
[inaudible]
IF IT'S THOUGHT NOT IF THEY
HAVEN'T DONE AND RECEIVE THEIR
CERTIFICATE THEIR SAFETY%
CERTIFICATION AND IT IS AS THIS
BILL NOW DOES.
IT WILL BE MONITORED IT WILL BE
INSPECTED IT WILL BE AUDITED IT
WILL BE ANNUALLY CERTIFY
RECERTIFIED IT'LL BE CHECKED ON
A REGULAR BASIS IF THEY MEET
THAT STANDARD.
IT'S A HIGH STANDARD IF THEY
MEET THAT STANDARD AND SOMETHING
HAPPENS.
IT'S NOT THEIR FAULT.
AND THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE TO PAY.
AND WE SHOULD SHARE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY.
BECAUSE AND SOCIALIZE THAT COST
BECAUSE WE ALL BENEFIT FROM
THOSE WIRES WILL BENEFIT FROM
THAT ELECTRICITY.
AND WE SHOULD ALL HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
SO WHEN I LOOK AT THE LIABILITY
WHEN I LOOK AT THE EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION WHEN I LOOK AT THE
REPAIR PROTECTION.
IN A LOOK AT THE VICTIMS BEING
PAID.
I THINK THIS LEGISLATION AND I
APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR I REALLY DO.
BECAUSE HE TOOK THIS ON IN
JANUARY HE TOOK AROUND PROBABLY
BEFORE HE WAS ELECTED AFTER THE
FIRES IN OCTOBER WHEN HE THOUGHT
HE KNEW SOMETHING HAD TO BE DONE.
AND HE HAS WHAT I BELIEVE IS A
HISTORY.
WHERE HE COMES FROM FRANKLY OF
P. JEANNIE?
HE KNEW AND KNOWS THE TYPE OF
COMPANY THAT THEY WERE.
AND HE IS PROTECTING THE RATE
PAYERS IN THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA FROM THAT COMPANY
TODAY AND MAKING THEM PAY IN THE
END.
AND FOR THAT I'M THANKFUL AND
THANKFUL TO HAVE STAFF.
THE FOR ALL THOSE REASONS MATTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I'M
SUPPORTING THIS LEGISLATION
TODAY.
IT WAS NOT EASY FROM THE START.
BUT IT'S EASY RIGHT NOW I ASK
FOR YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU SENATOR HILL.
SENATOR ATKINS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT IT IS BEEN A VERY.
SEEMINGLY LONG DAY ALTHOUGH ONLY
A FEW HOURS REALLY.
MOSTLY I I STOOD UP I DON'T WANT
TO REPEAT WHAT MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE SPENT --
ACTUALLY -- DAYS WEEKS AND IN
SOME CASES -- THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS WORKING ON THIS.
I JUST WANTED TO ADD MY THANKS
TO OUR MAJORITY LEADER MY
COLLEAGUE FROM NAPA MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN MATTEO -- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO WHO CHAIRS THE
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE.
AS WELL AS COLLEAGUES WHO STOOD
UP AND TOLD PERSONAL STORIES OF
SACRIFICE THEMSELVES.
AS WELL AS OUR COMMUNITY AND
FAMILY MEMBERS.
IF ONLY WE HAD LOOKED AT THIS A
DECADE AGO WHEN MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO AND MY SEVERAL
COLLEAGUES FROM SAN DIEGO.
AND I WITNESSED TWO FIRES IN OUR
COUNTY THAT WERE DEVASTATING.
THAT WITHOUT A LOT OF
CONVERSATION DISCUSSION THAT.
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY I HAD TO
FIGHT ITS WAY BACK AND FIGURE
OUT HOW IT WAS GOING TO PROVIDE --
ENERGY TO OUR COMMUNITIES IN THE
SAN DIEGO AREA.
AND SOME OF THE TECHNOLOGIES
THEY HAVE PUT IN PLACE -- NOW
SPOKEN OF ACROSS THE COUNTRY AS
STATE OF THE ART.
WELL THEY DID THAT OUT OF
NECESSITY AN OUT OF
UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY WERE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE ENERGY. TO US IN OUR
COUNTY IF THEY WEREN'T PREPARED
TO DEAL WITH WILD FIRES.
AND SO WE WANT TO SEE THAT
REPLICATED ASA AND THEY STAND ON
THE VERGE OF ACTUALLY FACING.
THE DOWNGRADING THAT ARE A GOOD
FRIEND FROM ORANGE COUNTY TALKED
ABOUT THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR
OWN IN THE LAST DECADE.
THEY WORK TO IMPROVE AND YET
THEY STAND TO LOSE ALL THAT
THEY'VE OBTAINED IT GAINED.
ODD BECAUSE OF IT.
ALL OF THE REASONS TO SUPPORT
THIS LEGISLATION MY ELOQUENT
COLLEAGUES HAVE MENTIONED.
THIS IS ABOUT RATE PAYERS THIS
IS ABOUT FIRE VICTIMS THIS IS
ABOUT COLLEAGUES WHO HAD TO PUT.
HOURS OF THOUGHT INTO WHAT IT
MEANS TO SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION THIS IS ABOUT
ARGUING WITH OURSELVES HAVE WE
DONE ENOUGH.
ARE WE ARE WE TAKING A RISK HERE.
THAT WE'RE AFRAID MAY NOT
PRODUCE WHAT WE NEEDED TO DO.
ALL OF THOSE FEARS MAKE US WANT
TO TAKE A STEP BACK I KNOW.
BUT SHOULD WE NOT ACT.
THE DAMAGE DONE GOING FORWARD
WOULD BE MUCH MUCH MORE SEVERE.
AND WE IN OUR FEAR WOULD BE
IRRESPONSIBLE TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND TO CALIFORNIA.
SO IT IS MY HOPE THAT WE COME
TOGETHER BAND TOGETHER AND DO
THIS WORK KNOWING THAT OUR WORK
IS NOT DONE OF COURSE IT IS NOT
DONE.
CITIES AND COUNTIES NEED TO
ADDRESS ISSUES OF HARDENING IN
THEIR VERY.
ODD COMMUNITIES IN THAT EXTENDS
NOT JUST -- TO TO DEALING WITH --
THE GROWTH IN THE FUEL -- IS IT
AROUND OUR HOMES THAT WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS BUT ALSO -- EVEN MORE
THAN THAT -- ZONING ORDINANCES
AND THINGS THAT PROVIDE FUEL
LIKE SHAKES SHINGLE ROOFS AND
THINGS THAT MY COLLEAGUE AND I
FROM SAN DIEGO HAD TO ADDRESS A
DECADE AGO AND PEOPLE WERE NOT
HAPPY.
AND THEY WOULD THEY WERE A
LITTLE FURTHER IN THE IN THE
CITY THE BIG CITY OF SAN DIEGO
BUT LET ME TELL YA.
I STILL HAVE THE PICTURE OF ME
HOLDING THE NEWSPAPER.
AND THE SKY BEHIND US WAS SO RED
BECAUSE OF THE FIRES.
AND THE DATE ON THE NEWSPAPER
YOU COULD SEE.
ARM YOU KNOW THOSE ARE REAL
CONSEQUENCES THAT HOPEFULLY
FORCE US TO TAKE MORE ACTION.
THAN WE HAVE HAD THE LUXURY NOT
TO TAKE UP UNTIL NOW SO I
COMMEND ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES
THAT HAVE REALLY.
DONE THE HARD WORK THE INTERNAL.
DEBATE THE DEBATE WITH EACH OF
US TO GET WHERE WE ARE TODAY IT
WOULD BE IRRESPONSIBLE NOT TO
TAKE ACTION I URGE YOU. TO
SUPPORT THIS IN WITH THAT AGAIN
THANK MY COLLEAGUES THAT HAVE
REALLY TAKEN THE LEAD TO DO THE
HARD WORK.
PLEASE I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS ALL
DEBATE HAVING SEE SENATOR DODD
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
MEMBERS OF RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW.
ASHLEY SECRETARY TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALL MEMBERS WE HAVE A
FULL HOUSE WE'RE GOING TO CALL
THE ROLL TWICE AND THEN WE WANT
TO CLOSE THE ROLE SO.
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALAN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
I FELL. FIVE FOR JUST.
BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO VALLEY [inaudible]
I DON.
I THERE ARE SO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I HUESO.
I TADO.
JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
AROUND [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
NO WILK.
NOW PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
GORGEOUS -- TADA [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible] FIVE
UMBERG [inaudible]
HI.
ALL EYES THIRTY ONE KNOWS SEVEN
ON THE URGENCY VICE THIRTY ONE
NO SEVEN ON THE MEASURE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
SENATOR MITCHELL.
RESIDENT HI MOVE JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO WAY THE WAY FOR THE
BUTTON FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE
TO MEET IN HERE SIMPLY BILLS ONE
TEN AND ONE ELEVEN ON WEDNESDAY
JULY.
TEN WITHOUT FOUR DAYS NOTICE IN
THE DAILY FILE I'M ASKING FOR AN
I. ABOUT THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL SENATOR NIELSEN I URGE
A NO VOTE.
THEY'RE ALL RIGHT WE HAVE TO GET
TO TWENTY ONE IN ORDER TO
SUSPEND THE RULES SENATOR
MITCHELL IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE SENATOR NIELSEN IS ASKING
FOR NO VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DOLLY [inaudible]
NO DODD.
I THERE ARE SO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GONZALEZ [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
HI HUESO.
I TADO.
I JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MOREAU [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I LIKE CASTING [inaudible] FIVE
WIENER [inaudible]
I WILL.
NOW I IS TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TEN
THE MOTION PASSES IN THE RULES
ARE SUSPENDED.
COLLEAGUES WE ARE GOING TO GO --
AND LIST ALL THE CALLS.
WE WILL THEN HAVE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
AND THEN WE WILL DO OUR GERMAN
MEMORIES AND BE DONE FOR THE
EVENING SO WITH THAT COLLEAGUES.
WE'RE GONNA ASK THE SECRETARY
PLEASE LIFT ALL THE CALLS
STARTING WITH FILE ITEM.
FOURTEEN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NO MCGUIRE.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
AMBERG [inaudible]
I WIENER.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA S. THE
SECTOR ONE MORE TIME AND THEN
FOLKS IF WE COULD GET YOU ALL
BACK ON THE FLOOR SO WE CAN VOTE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AND FILE ITEM FOURTEEN ONE MORE
TIME [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
OUR EYES THIRTY KNOWS THREE THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MOVING
ON FILE ITEM FIFTEEN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
I THOUGHT [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I UMBERG [inaudible] FIVE WIENER
[inaudible]
HI.
VICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I BORDERS [inaudible]
DOLLY [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO MCGUIRE.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
I'M BURKE [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER I MORALE I DON'T KNOW.
VICE THIRTY ONE KNOWS FIVE THAT
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM.
TWENTY SEVEN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
I'M SORRY EXCUSE ME.
I'M SORRY FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN MY
APOLOGIES.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I GORGEOUS [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I DOLLY [inaudible]
I DON [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
I TADO. FIVE JACKSON HI I
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I UMBERG [inaudible] FIVE WIENER.
AYE AYES THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED AND
NOW WE WILL GO TO FILE ITEM.
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I DOLLY [inaudible]
I DON [inaudible] FIVE HILL
[inaudible] FIVE JACKSON
[inaudible]
HI.
OUR EYES THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ONE
ON THE URGENCY ICE THIRTY EIGHT
KNOWS ONE ON THE MEASURE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM.
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
THE RAZA [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
HILL.
I JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
HI.
MY CAO SKI [inaudible]
MORRELL I DON'T KNOW.
I THIRTY FOUR KNOWS THREE THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I BATES.
NO FOR AGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I THERE ARE SO.
I JACKSON HI I PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
HI.
OUR EYES THIRTY KNOWS KNOWS NINE
ON THE URGENCY ICE NO ORIGINS
EXCUSE ME ICE THIRTY KNOWS NINE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
TWENTY SIX PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALAN [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
I FORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
I JACKSON HI FIVE PAN.
HI ICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM FORTY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I FORGES [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DOLLY.
NO -- TADO.
NO.
JACKSON HI I MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO SKINNER [inaudible]
BY.
THE MEASURE PASSES THIRTY OUR
EYES AND NOSE. EIGHT MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM.
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible] FOR
JUST [inaudible]
GROWTH.
JACKSON HI I MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible] FIVE RUBIO.
SKINNER.
RUBIO I SKINNER.
HI ICE THIRTY FIVE NOSE ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM SIXTY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
DOLLY [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible] FIVE SKINNER.
HI LARGE THIRTY TWO NO SIX THE
MEASURE PASSES.
COLLEAGUES THAT IT CONCLUDES THE
MOM MATTERS THAT WERE ON CALL WE
NOW OF WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
WE'LL START WITH SENATOR HER
TITLE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- FOR
SENATE
MEETING AT OF IN FIFTEEN MINUTES
IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR NIELSEN FOR WHAT PURPOSE
SIR TO REMOVE AN ITEM CONSENT.
COULD YOU INDICATE FOR US WHAT
ITEM THAT IS PLEASE ITEM ONE
FIVE ONE A. B..
NINE NINE ONE THAT WILL BE THE
ORDER.
ANY OTHER ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SENATOR BRADFORD.
NOW UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
SENATOR BRADFORD FOR WHAT
PURPOSE UNDER MOTIONS A
RESOLUTION WITHOUT OBJECTION YES
AT THE REQUESTED AUTHOR I LIKE
TO REMOVE A. B.. TEN THIRTY
SEVEN FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SO NOTED.
ANY OTHER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS BEFORE WE GET TO THE
A CHURNING MEMORIES. ONE SECOND
PLEASE [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO GO NOW
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY AND IF WE
COULD HAVE YOUR ATTENTION PLEASE.
WE'LL START WITH SENATOR GARAGE
SO AND THEN THE SENATOR ON BURKE.
THANK YOU MANAGER RAZA.
THANK YOU MANAGER UP MEMBERS
IT'S OUR WITH GREAT PERSONAL
SADNESS THAT I A GERMAN IN THE
MEMORY.
OF A TO DAUGHTER OF CALIFORNIA
SISTER PAT CROMER.
SHE WAS BORN IN BERKELEY IN
NINETEEN THIRTY TWO WHEN SHE
COMMITTED HERSELF TO COMMUNITY
SERVICE.
AND MINISTRY AFTER GRADUATING
HIGH SCHOOL BY JOINING THE
SISTERS OF SAINT JOSEPH.
HE SPENT MOST OF HER LIFE IN
SERVICE AS AN EDUCATOR ORGANIZER
AND SCHOOL ADMINISTRATOR.
SHE WAS AN ACTIVIST ON BEHALF OF
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND BEYOND.
SHE PLAYED A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
THE MISSIONS OF TO NON PROFITS.
THE ARCHBISHOP ROMERO RELIEF
FUND WHICH COLLECTED AND SHIPPED
MEDICAL SUPPLIES TO THOSE
AFFECTED BY THE ARMED CONFLICT
IN THE GUT IOWA.
AND THE HUMANITARIAN LAW PROJECT
TO PROVIDE LEGAL ASSISTANCE AND
EDUCATION. TO THOSE FLEEING
CENTRAL AMERICA AND AT RISK FOR
DEPORTATION.
SHE ALSO ADVOCATED ON BEHALF OF
THE INDIGENOUS PEOPLES OF
CHIAPAS MEXICO RAISING AWARENESS
IN THE U. S. BUT THE HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSES THAT THEY FACED.
HER MANIFEST COMMITMENT TO
SERVICE SAVE COUNTLESS LIVES
MANY WHO NEVER HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK HER FOR
WHAT SHE HAD DONE FOR THEM.
I MET HER AND I SAW HER EVERY.
TIME I WENT TO MASS AS I WAS
SUPPOSED.
TO AND SHE ALWAYS SAT AT FIVE P.
USE BEHALF -- FROM THE FRONT SHE
WAS ALWAYS THERE EVERY SUNDAY
GIVE ME A BIG HUG AND A BIG KISS
AND THANKING ME IN ALL OF US FOR
WHAT WE WERE DOING.
SHE EMAILED NOTES TO US ALL THE
TIME ABOUT THE LATEST BECAUSE
AND WHAT WE SHOULD ALL BE DOING.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE EXAMPLE
THAT SHE SHOWED AND MORE IN THIS
TREMENDOUS LOSS.
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES THAT SHE SERVED.
UP THROUGH BOTH OUR PARISH THE
LORD'S MISSION AND MANY OTHER
COMMUNITIES -- WILL WE'RE FACING
A TREMENDOUS LOSS TO OUR
CONDOLENCES.
TO HER SISTERS THE SISTERS OF
SAINT JOSEPH REPAIRS DELORES
MISSION AND EVERYONE ELSE PLEASE
JOIN ME IN HONORING SISTER PAD
CROMER.
AND OUR CONDOLENCES TO HER
FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROSS SO PLEASE
MAKE SURE THAT YOU BRING HER
NAME -- TO THE FRONT DESK SO
THAT WE CAN PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE
FOR MEMORY.
WITHOUT SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT IN
MEMBERS.
I RISE -- ON THE SAID OCCASION.
TESTS THAT WE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF MY UNCLE ON DONALD C.
JANSEN.
BOTH DECATUR IN HUNTSVILLE
ALABAMA.
HE PASSED AWAY AS A TRUE PATRIOT
WOULD PASS AWAY ON JULY.
FOR JUST THIS PAST WEEKEND --
HE'S SURVIVED BY MY IN HIS WIFE
OF SEVENTY ONE YEARS MICHAEL
DUNN WAS NINETY FOUR YEARS OLD --
HE WAS THE PROUD PARENT HE AND
MY AUNT DOROTHY -- THEIR LEGACY
INDOORS THROUGH THEIR CHILDREN
AND GRANDCHILDREN THE PROUD
PARENTS OF THE JILL SHARON AND
HER HUSBAND DAVID SHERRIN.
WHO ARE THE PARENTS OF JULIE AND
SHELLY?
I HIS SON STEPHEN AND HIS SON'S
WIFE MARCY THE PARENTS OF ERIC
BRIAN LARA.
AND THEIR YOUNGEST DAUGHTER JOY.
HER HUSBAND DOG PARENTS OF
ALISON AARON AND JESSICA.
IN ADDITION THEY ALSO.
HAD EIGHT GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
HE WAS BORN IN CINCINNATI OF THE
OLDEST SON THE PATRIARCH OF OUR
FAMILY OF THE SON OF MARIE AND
MY GRANDFATHER RUDOLPH JANSEN AN
IMMIGRANT FROM THE NETHERLANDS.
ITALIAN RESISTANCE THAT HE
RECEIVED HIS MASTERS DEGREE IN
ECONOMICS AND UNIVERSITY CHICAGO.
HE SPENT HIS CAREER BOTH
TEACHING AS WELL AS WITH THE
GENERAL ELECTRIC IN LOUISVILLE
KENTUCKY.
AND DECATUR ALABAMA HE PROBABLY
WILL HE AND MY AUNT MAY BE THE
ONLY TWO DEMOCRATS AND THE CATER
ALABAMA SADLY ONE I'M IS NOW
GONE -- HE SERVED IN THE
MERCHANT MARINE.
THERE WERE TWO ON SHIPS THAT
PROVIDED COVER FOR THE CONVOYS
GOING BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
HERE IN EUROPE.
AND THEN TRANSITION TO THE NAVY
AND I RECALL AS A VERY YOUNG BOY
OPENING HIS THE LOCKER AND
SMELLING DIESEL AND ASKING HIM
WHAT WHY DO I SMELL WAS DIESELS
BECAUSE HE WAS.
ON SUBMARINES NET DIESEL HAD
BASICALLY.
IN FUSED HAD BEEN PART OF HIS
UNIFORMS -- HE HAD -- THE KEEN
KEEN SENSE OF HUMOR AND ALSO HAD
A KEEN CURIOSITY I VISITED THEM
NINE YEARS AGO INDICATOR AND I
REMEMBER WHEN HE WAS ABOUT
EIGHTY FIVE YEARS OLD I ASKED MY
IAN.
WHETHER MY UNCLE HAD ANY ISSUES
AND SHE SAID HE IRRITATED HER
CONTINUALLY BECAUSE HE WOULD
TAKE HIS BICYCLE AND RIDE TO THE
TOWN.
AND THE HE'D BE GONE ALL DAY.
AND SHE GOT THE CALL A LIBRARY
IN HIM SENT HOME BECAUSE HE
RIGHT AROUND ON THE TO GO LIVE
BRING SPEND SEVERAL HOURS WHEN
I'M EIGHTY FIVE YEARS OLD I WANT
MY WIFE TO CALL LIBRARIAN IS FOR
ME TO RIDE MY BICYCLE HOME.
HE'S GOING TO BE REMEMBERED --
FOR A LONG TIME IS LEGACY AS I
SAID IS IN HIS CHILDREN AND HIS
GRANDCHILDREN.
AND HE WILL BE MISSED DEARLY --
MEMBERS I ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN
HIS MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG HIM
PLEASE EXTEND CONDOLENCES FROM
THE SENATE OF CALIFORNIA TO THE
FAMILY OF THE ONE REMAINING
[inaudible]
DEMOCRAT IN.
THANK YOU CITY.
AND ALSO PLEASE MAKE SURE WE
HAVE.
HIS NAME FORWARD SO WE CAN
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZES FAMILY.
WITHOUT WE WILL GO TO A SENATOR
GLAZER.
AND FALL BY SENATOR BATES
[inaudible]
SENATOR GLAZERS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
WOULD ASK THE SENATE TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF KENNETH BEARING.
ANY SPACE PHILANTHROPISTS WHO
TOUCHED MANY LIVES WITH HIS MANY
ENTERPRISES.
AND CHARITABLE WORK.
HI CAN WHO WANTS TO OWN THE
NATIONAL FOOTBALL LEAGUE SEATTLE
SEAHAWKS AND FOUNDED THE FAMOUS
GOLF COMMUNITY LACK HAWK IN MY
DISTRICT DIED RECENTLY AT THE
AGE.
OF NINETY ONE HE WAS A WEALTHY
MAN -- A BILLIONAIRE.
BUT HE MADE SURE HE SURE THE
FRUITS OF HIS LABORS WIDELY.
HE FOUNDED THE WHEELCHAIR
FOUNDATION WHICH IS GIVEN AWAY
MORE THAN ONE MILLION
WHEELCHAIRS TO THE DISABLED.
AND LESS FORTUNATEAND A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FIVE COUNTRIES.
AROUND THE WORLD.
HE ALSO LED EFFORTS TO PROVIDE
CLEAN WATER IN RULE AREAS OF THE
WORLD.
AND TO PROVIDE CATARACT
SURGERIES IN ASIA AND MEXICO.
HE WAS INVOLVED IN HELPING WITH
THE BUILDING AND DEVELOPMENT OF
NATURAL HISTORY MUSEUMS
WORLDWIDE INCLUDING OVER.
FORTY MUSEUMS IN CHINA.
IS RECOGNIZED ACROSS MANY FIELDS
AS ONE OF THE BEST SHRINE IN THE
CALIFORNIA HOME BUILDERS
FOUNDATION HALL OF FAME.
AND THE BAY AREA SPORTS HALL OF
FAME ON OTHERS.
KEN BHRING LIVED A FULL LIFE.
AND TOUCH SO MANY N. -- SO MANY
WAYS IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
AND I WANT TO PASS ON MY
RESPECTS TO HIS WIFE OF SIXTY
NINE YEARS PAST.
HIS SONS TOM AND DAVID JEFF AND
SCOTT.
GRANDCHILDREN AND MANY GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AND ALL THOSE WHO
WERE GRACE WITH HIS PRESENCE
WITH THAT.
MADAM PRESIDENT ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN HIS WONDERFUL MEMORY
THANK YOU SENATOR GLACIER AND
PLEASE EXTEND THE CONDOLENCES OF
THE SENATE TO THE BERING FAMILY
[inaudible]
SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I ASK
ALL COLLEAGUES TO INTERNALIZE
THIS EENING IN MEMORY OF JAMES
TIME.
JAMES PASSED PEACEFULLY IN THE
EARLY MORNING HOURS OF JUNE
SECOND AT HIS HOME OF FORTY FIVE
YEARS IN SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO.
JUST ONE MONTH AND FIVE DAYS
AFTER HIS WIFE CAROL PASSED AWAY.
JIM WAS MORNING IN NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE IN SANTA ANA THE
YOUNGEST OF SIX CHILDREN MS WAS
BROUGHT UP DURING THE GREAT
DEPRESSION.
HIS DAD WAS AN ATTORNEY AT THAT
TIME SO IN ONE OF HIS DAD'S
CASES ALL THE CLIENT HAD TO GIVE
FOR SERVICES RENDERED WAS A
TRAINED CIRCUS PONY NAMED TONY.
OF COURSE THIS GAVE TEN YEAR OLD
JIMMY GREAT PLEASURE AS HE WOULD
OCCASIONALLY RIGHT TONY JUST
SCHOOL IMPRESSING THE GIRLS WITH
TONY'S BOW.
AND STAND ONE OF THOSE GIRLS WAS
CAROL HARVEY WHO HE WOULD END UP
LATER MARY.
HE SERVED IN WORLD WAR TWO IN
THE NAVY AND WHEN THE WAR ENDED
HE AND CAROL RAN INTO EACH OTHER.
AGAIN AT THE SANTA ANA AIR FORCE
BASE AND LATER MARRIED ON MAY
DAY.
NINETEEN FORTY NINE AFTER WORLD
WAR TWO JIM STARTED HIS CAREER
IN ORANGE COUNTY AS AN
APPRENTICE CLAIMS OFFICER. FOR
THE VETERANS SERVICE AND LATER
TOOK ON THE ADDITIONAL JOB THE
PUBLIC GUARDIAN HE WON THE
ELECTION FOR OUR IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SIX TO THE POST OF PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATOR.
IN SERVED IN ALL THREE
CAPACITIES UNTIL.
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE WHEN THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS COMBINED RULES OF
PUBLIC GUARDIAN AND PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATOR.
INTO ONE MAJOR OPERATION.
JIM ALWAYS PRIDED HIMSELF AS A
LOCAL BOY WHO CAME UP THE RANKS
TO BECOME A SUCCESSFUL STEWARD.
FOR THE COUNTY IN WHICH SHE WAS
RAISED HE RETIRED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE AFTER FORTY YEARS OF
SERVICE.
A MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN LEGION
VETERANS OF FOREIGN WARS
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
SERVICE FFICERS.
AS WELL AS PRESIDENT OF BOTH THE
SAN JUAN CAPISTRANO FIESTA
ASSOCIATION.
AND THE HISTORICAL SOCIETY HIS
HOBBIES INCLUDED HIS LEVEL
COURSES BOATING FISHING
BARBECUING AND CAMPING.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS THREE
CHILDREN AND THEIR SPOUSES AND
FIVE GRANDCHILDREN.
I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN AND JAMES
IS MEMORY THIS EVENING AND THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU AND CONDOLENCES PLEASE
TO THE FAMILY OF MISTER HAN.
OUR LAST ADJOURNED IN MEMORY
SENATOR UMBERG YOUR BACKUP
THAT'S NOT A GOOD SIGN WELL
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS -- I I DO STAND ONCE
AGAIN WITH A HEAVY HEART --
ASSET WE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF
MISTER DAVID TROUGHTON.
WHO WAS THE HUSBAND OF QUEEN
TRON A STAFF MEMBER OF MINE IN
OUR DISTRICT OFFICE?
DAVID WAS BORN IN FORTY ON
SAIGON.
VIETNAM AND HE WAS A MIDDLE
SCHOOL TEACHER IN VIETNAM FOR
TWENTY YEARS.
EVENTUALLY HE AND HIS FAMILY
IMMIGRATED TO THE UNITED STATES
IN SEARCH OF THE AMERICAN DREAM.
HE WAS RESPECTED MEMBER THE
BUDDHIST COMMUNITY IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND ATTENDED LEIGH EN
QUOI.
TEMPLE IN GARDEN GROVE AND FOOD
DA TEMPLE IN SANTA ANA -- HE
pINDUSTRY LAGOON THE GAL FOR TEN
YEARS AS ASSURANCE AGENT.
AN EASY CHOICE MEDICARE
ADVANTAGE INSURANCE FOR SEVEN
YEARS LIKE.
OTHERS WHO CAME TO OUR COUNTRY
FROM VIETNAM WAS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT PRODUCTIVE MEMBER OF
OUR COMMUNITY -- HE WORKED EVERY
DAY. FOR SENIORS TO RECEIVE
BETTER HEALTH CARE HE ENJOYED
PLAYING THE GUITAR AND WATCHING
SOCCER AND TENNIS IN HIS SPARE
TIME.
HE WAS MOST PROUD OF HIS
CHILDREN AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE
HIS SON WAS MARRIED IN.
TWO THOUSAND TEN AND HIS
DAUGHTER WAS MARRIED TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN AND THEY
ARE THE PROUD PARENTS.
OF GRAND SONS BENJAMIN AND
ALEXANDER.
HE PASSED AWAY ON JUST RECENTLY
ON JUNE THIRTIETH.
AND HE AS I MENTIONED WAS THE
PROUD HUSBAND OF QUEEN TRON.
OF OUR DISTRICT OFFICE
COLLEAGUES I S. THAT YOU JOIN.
ME IN A JOINING IN HIS MEMORY
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG CAM
CONDOLENCES PLEASE TO HIS FAMILY.
WITH THAT COLLEAGUES.
AND MADAME PRO TEM THE DESK IS
CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT WE
WILL.
MEET NEXT FOR FLOOR SESSION ON
THURSDAY JULY ELEVENTH AT NINE
AM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WE ARE ADJOURNED